hello everyone and welcome to this
Advanced deep learning full course by
simply learn in this comprehensive
program we will dive into the concept of
deep learning deep learning a subfield
of artificial intelligence has made
significance progress in recent years
and profoundly impacted various aspects
of modern world one area where deep
learning has been particularly
transformative is in the advancement of
chatbots and other conversational AI
systems chatbots are computer programs
designed to stimulate human conversation
and with the help of deep learning
techniques they have become increasingly
intelligent versatile and capable of
engaging in more natural and human-like
interactions professionals with deep
learning skills can access various
career opportunities including roles
like deep learning engineer machine
learning engineer data scientist
computer vision engineer and NLP
engineer and Based on data from
Glassdoor the average annual salary for
deep learning Professionals in the
United States is around 109 000 and the
average annual salary for deep learning
Professionals in India is 8 lakhs so if
you want to see expertise in deep
learning skills and aspect to be a part
of Cutting Edge field of building
chatbots and service Bots using deep
learning are Caltech postage program in
Ai and machine learning provides
comprehensive coverage of the latest
tools and Technologies within the AI
ecosystem
it offers master classes led by esteemed
Caltech faculty and IBM experts engaging
hackathons and interactive ask me
anything sessions by enrolling in this
program delivered in partnership with
IBM you will gain the expertise needed
to become a professional in a and ml
this comprehensive artificial
intelligence course will equip you with
the knowledge about various AI based
Technologies empowering you to excel in
this field so do check out the course
Link in the description for more details
let's get started now
and the 2.0 addressed so many things out
there that the 1.0 really needed so we
start talking about tensorflow 1.0
versus 2.0 I guess you would need to
know this for a legacy programming job
if you're pulling apart somebody else's
code the first thing is that tensorflow
2.0 supports eager execution by default
it allows you to build your models and
run them instantly and you can see here
from tensorflow 1 to tensorflow 2 we
have almost double the code to do the
same thing so if I want to do with
tf.session or tensorflow session as a
session the session run you have your
variables your session run you have your
tables initializer and then you do your
model fit X train y train and then your
validation data your x value y value and
your epics and your batch size all that
goes into the fit and you can see here
where that was all just compressed to
make it run easier you can just create a
model and do a fit on it and you only
have that last set of code on there so
it's automatic that's what they mean by
the eager so if you see the first part
and you're like what the heck is all
this session thing going on that's
tensorflow 1.0 and then when you get
into 2.0 it's just nice and clean if you
remember from the beginning I said cross
on our list up there
and cross is the high level API in
tensorflow 2.0 cross is the official
high-level API of tensorflow 2.0 it has
incorporated across as tf.corross cross
provides a number of model building apis
such as sequential functional and
subclassing so you can choose a right
level of abstraction for your project
and uh we'll hopefully touch base a
little bit more on this sequential being
the most common form that is your your
layers are going from one side to the
other so everything's going in a
sequential order
functional
is where you can split the layer so you
might have your input coming in one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models and then they come back
together and one of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff or neural basic reverse
propagation neural network and then
those all come together into another
layer which is your neural network
reverse propagation setup
subclassing is the most complicated as
you're building your own models and you
can subclass your own models into cross
so very powerful tools here this is all
the stuff that's been coming out
currently in the tensorflow cross setup
a third big change we're going to look
at is it in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use TF layers as variables
you would have to write TF variable
block so you'd have to pre-define that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers of course this
changes a little bit as a more
complicated tensor you have coming in
but all of it's very easy to do and
that's what 2.0 does a really good job
of and here we have a little bit more on
the scope of this and you can see how
tensorflow 1 asks you to do these
different layers and values if you look
at the scope and the default name you
start looking at all the different code
in there to create the variable scope
that's not even necessary intense or 2.0
so you'd have to do one before you do do
what you see the code in 2.0 in 2.0 you
just create your model it's a sequential
model and then you can add all your
layers in you don't have to pre-create
the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version and then we have the
last two which is our API cleanup and
the auto graph in the API cleanup
tensorflow one you could build models
using TF Gans TF app TF contrib TF Flags
Etc and tensorflow 2 a lot of apis have
been removed and this is just they just
cleaned them up because people weren't
using them and they've simplified them
and that's your TF app your TF Flags
your TF logging are all gone
so there's those are three Legacy
features that are not in 2.0 and then we
have our TF function and autograph
feature in the old version tensorflow
1-0 the python functions were limited
and could not be compiled or exported
re-imported so you were continually
having to redo your code you couldn't
very easily just put a pointer to it and
say hey let's reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the TF function to market
for the jit compilation for the python
jit so that tensorflow runs it as a
single graph autograph feature of TF
function helps to write graph code using
natural python syntax
uh now we just threw in a new word a new
graph graph is not a picture of a person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things graph is what are all those lines
that are connecting different objects so
if you remember from before where we had
the different layers going through
sequentially each one of those white
lined arrows would be a graph x that's
where that computation is taken care of
and that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using in
neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing next let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic Tools in
tensorflow before we roll up our sleeves
and dive into the example so let's just
take a quick look at tensorflow toolkits
in their hierarchy at the high level we
have our object oriented API so this is
what you're working with you have your
TF cross you have your estimators this
sits on top of your TF layers TF losses
TF metrics so you have your reusable
libraries for model building this is
really where tensorflow shines is
between the cross running your
estimators and then being able to swap
in different layers you can your losses
your metrics all of that is so built
into tensorflow makes it really easy to
use and then you can get down to your
low level TF API you have extensive
control over this you can put your own
formulas in there your own procedures or
models in there you could have it split
we talked about that earlier so with the
2.0 you can now have it split One
Direction where you do a linear
regression model and then go to the
other where it does a neural network and
maybe each neural network has a
different activation set on it and then
it comes together into another layer
which is another neural network so you
can build these really complicated
models and at the low level you can put
in your own apis you can move that stuff
around and most recently we have the TF
code can run on multiple platforms and
so you have your CPU which is basically
like on the computer I'm running on I
have eight cores and 16 dedicated
threads I hear they now have one out
there that has over a hundred cores uh
so you have your CPU running and then
you have your GPU which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
TPU setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models uh neural network kind
of setup so now you can export the TF
code and it can run on all kinds of
different platforms for the most
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture we
have you can see on the left this is
usually where you start out with and
eighty percent of your time in data
science is spent pre-processing data
making sure it's loaded correctly and
everything looks right so the first
level in tensorflow is going to be your
read and pre-processed data your TF data
feature columns this is going to feed
into your TF Cross or your pre-made
estimators and kind of you have your
tensorflow Hub that sits on top of there
so you can see what's going on uh once
you have all that set up you have your
distribution strategy where are you
going to run it are you going to be
running it on just your regular CPU are
you going to be running it with the GPU
added in like I have a pretty high-end
graphics card so it actually grabs that
GPU processor and uses it or do you have
a specialized TPU set up in there that
you paid extra money for it could be if
you're in later on when you're
Distributing the package you might need
to run this on some really high
processors because you're processing at
a server level for let's say net you
might be processing this at a distribute
you're Distributing it not the
distribution strategy but you're
Distributing it into a server where that
server might be analyzing thousands and
thousands of purchases done every minute
and so you need that higher speed to
give them a to give them a
recommendation or a suggestion so they
can buy more stuff off your website or
maybe you're looking for a data fraud
analysis working with the banks you want
to be able to run this at a high speed
so that when you have hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person probably has a
credit card so when we're talking about
all those fun things we're talking about
saved model this is we were talking
about that earlier where it used to be
when you did one of these models it
wouldn't truncate the float numbers the
same and so a model going from one you
build the model on your machine in the
office and then you need to distribute
it and so we have our tensorflow serving
Cloud on premium that's what I was
talking about if you're like a banking
or something like that now they have
tensorflow Lite so you can actually run
it denser flow on an Android or an iOS
or Raspberry Pi a little breakout board
there in fact they just came out with a
new one that has a built-in is this a
little mini TPU with the camera on it so
it can pre-process a video so you can
load your tensorflow model onto that
talking about an affordable way to beta
test a new product you have the
tensorflow.js which is for browser and
node server so you can get that out on
the browser for some simple computations
that don't require a lot of heavy
lifting but you want to distribute to a
lot of end points and now they also have
other language bindings so you can now
create your tensorflow back in save it
and have it accessed from C Java go
c-sharp rust r or from whatever package
you're working on so we kind of have an
overview of the architecture and what's
going on behind the scenes and in this
case what's going on as far as
Distributing it let's go ahead and take
a look at three specific pieces of
tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and sessions so very basic
things you need to know and understand
when you're working with the tensorflow
setup so constants in tensorflow in
tensorflow constants are created using
the function constant in other words
they're going to stay static the whole
time whatever you're working with the
Syntax for constant value d-type 9 shape
equals none name constant verify shape
equals false that's kind of the syntax
you're looking at and we'll explore this
with our hands on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do Z equals
tf.constant 5.2 name equals x d type is
a float that means that we're never
going to change that 5.2 it's going to
be a constant value and then we have our
variables in tensorflow variables in
tensorflow are in memory buffers that
store tensors and so we can declare a
two by three tensor populated by ones
you could also do constants this way by
the ways you can create a an array of
ones for your constants I'm not sure why
you do that but you know you might need
that for some reason
and here we have V equals TF dot
variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.1s
and you have the shape which is 2 3
which is then going to create a nice two
by three array that's filled with ones
and then of course you can go in there
in their variables so you can change
them it's a tensor so you have full
control over that and then you of course
have uh sessions in tensorflow a session
in tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate to the
nodes and remember when we're talking a
graph or graph x we're talking about all
that information then goes through all
those arrows and whatever computations
they have they take it to the next node
and you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as TF if we do x
equals a TF dot constant of 10 we do y
equals a TF constant of 2.0 or 20.0 and
then you can do Z equals TF dot variable
and it's a TF dot add X comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your TF
Global variables initializer with TF
session as session you can do a session
run knit and then you print the session
run y uh and so when you run this you're
going to end up with of course the 10
plus 20 is 30. and we'll be looking at
this a lot more closely as we actually
roll up our sleeves and put some code
together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today I'm going
to go ahead and go through anaconda and
then I'll use specifically the Jupiter
Notebook on there and of course this
code is going to work uh whatever
platform you choose whether you're in a
notebook the Jupiter lab which is just a
Jupiter notebook but with tabs for
larger projects we're going to stick
with Jupiter notebook pycharm whatever
it is you're going to use in here you
have your spider and your QT console for
different programming environments the
thing to note is kind of hard to see but
I have my main Pi 36 right now when I
was writing this tensorflow works in
Python version three six if you have
python version 3 7 or 3 8 you're
probably going to get some errors in
there might be that they've already
updated it and I don't know it now you
have an older version
but you want to make sure you're in a
python version 3 6 in your environment
and of course in Anaconda can easily set
that environment up make sure you go
ahead and and pip in your tensorflow or
if you're in Anaconda you can do a conda
install tensorflow to make sure it's in
your package so let's just go ahead and
dive in and bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
I just love the fact I can zoom in and
zoom out depending on what I'm working
on making it really easy to adjust a
demo for the right size go under new and
let's go ahead and create a new Python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it Untitled let's
go ahead and import import tensorflow as
TF at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick no errors yay no
errors I
I do that whenever I do my imports
because I unbearably will have opened up
a new environment and forgotten to
install tensorflow into that environment
or something along those lines so it's
always good to double check
and if we're going to double check that
we also it's also good to know what
version we're working with and we can do
that simply by using the version command
and tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the TF
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and you know it always confuses me
because sometimes you do tf.version for
one thing you do TF dot underscore
version underscore for another thing
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in tensorflow version 2.1.0 and I did
tell you the the um we were going to dig
a little deeper into our constants and
you can do an array of constants and
we'll just create this nice array a
equals tf.constant and we're just going
to put the array right in there four
three six one we can run this and now
that is what a is equal to and if we
want to just double check that remember
we're in Jupiter notebook where you can
just put the letter a and it knows that
that's going to be print otherwise you'd
surround it in print and you can see
it's a TF tensor it has the shape the
type and the and the array on here it's
a two by two array and just like we can
create a constant we can go ahead and
create a variable and this is also going
to be a two by 2 array and if we go
ahead and print the V out we'll run that
and sure enough there's our TF variable
in here
then we can also let's just go back up
here and add this in here I could create
another tensor and we'll make it a
constant this time
and we'll go and put that in over here
we'll have b t f constant and if we go
and print out V and B I'm going to run
that and this is an interesting thing
that always that happens in here you'll
see right here when I print them both
out what happens it only prints the last
one unless you use print commands so
important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print and Surround V with
brackets and now we can see with the two
different variables we have we have the
three one five two which is a variable
and this is just a flat constant so it
comes up as a TF tensor shape two kind
of two and that's interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a TF variable
so that's how it's looking in the back
end when you're talking about the
difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing I want you to notice is
that in variable we capitalize the V and
with the constant we have a lowercase C
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work so those are a couple little things
to note in here and just like any other
array in math we can do like a
concatenate or concatenate the different
values here and you can see we can take
a b concatenated you just do a TF dot
concat values and there's our a b axes
on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes and if we go ahead and print
this out you'll see right here we end up
with a tensor so let's put it in as a
constant nut as a variable
and you have your array 4378 and 6145 is
concatenated the two together and
a couple things on this our axes equals
one this means we're doing the columns
so if you had a longer array like right
now we have an array that is like you
know has a shape one whatever it is two
comma two
axes zero
is going to be your first one and axes
one is going to be your second one and
it translates as columns and rows if we
had a shape let me just put the word
shape here
um
so you know what I'm talking about it's
very clear and this is I'll tell you
what I spend a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction I'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
Matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axis axis one you know
zero one two that's going to be our
columns and if you can do columns then
we also can do rows and that is simply
just changing the concatenate we'll just
grab this one here and copy it we'll do
the whole thing over
um control copy
Ctrl V and changes from axis one
to actually 0 and if we run that you'll
see that now we concatenate by a row as
opposed to column
and you have four three six one seven
eight four seven so it just brings it
right down and turns it into rows versus
columns you can see the difference there
your output this really you want to look
at the output sometimes just to make
sure your eyes are looking at it
correctly and it's in the format I find
visually looking at it is almost more
important than understanding what's
going on because conceptually your mind
just just too many dimensions sometimes
the second thing I want you to notice is
this says a numpy array so tensorflow is
utilizing numpy as part of their format
as far as Python's concerned and so you
can treat you can treat this output like
a numpy array because it is just that
it's going to be a numpy array another
thing that comes up uh more than you
would think is filling one of these with
zeros or ones and so you can see here we
just created tensor tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell out what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer and then if we
print out our tensor again we're in
Jupiter so I can just type out tensor
and I run this you can see I have a nice
array of with shape three comma four of
zeros one of the things I want to
highlight here is integer 32. if I go to
the tensorflow data types I want you to
notice how we have float 16 float 32
float 64 complex if we scroll down
you'll see the integer down here 32. the
reason for this is that we want to
control how many bits are used in the
Precision
this is for exporting it to another
platform so what would happen is I might
run it on this computer where python
goes does a float to indefinite however
long it wants to and then we can take it
but we want to actually say hey we don't
want that high Precision we want to be
able to run this on any computer and so
we need to control whether it's a TF
float 16. in this case we did an integer
32.
we could also do this as a float so if I
run this as a float32 that means this
has a 32-bit Precision you'll see Zero
Point whatever and then to go with zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a tensorflow with ones
and you might ask yourself why would I
want zeros and ones and your first
thought might be to initiate a new
tensor usually we initiate a lot of this
stuff with random numbers because it
does a better job solving it if you
start with a uniform set of ones or
zeros you're dealing with a lot of bias
so be very careful about starting a
neural network for one of your rows or
something like that with ones and zeros
on the other hand I use this for masking
you can do a lot of work with masking
you can also have it might be that one
tenths a row is masked you know zero is
is false one is true or whatever you
want to do it
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones and there are cases
where you do want to initialize it with
all zeros or all ones and then swap in
different numbers as a as the tensor
learns so it's another form of control
but in general you see zeros and ones
you usually are talking about a mask
over another array and just like in
numpy you can also do reshapes so if we
take our remember this is shape three
comma four maybe we want to swap that to
four comma three
and if we print this out
you will see let me just go and do that
control V let me run that and you'll see
that the the order of these is now
switched instead of four across now we
have three across and four down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones
and I'm going to change the ones to TF
dot random uniform uh and we'll go ahead
and just take off well we'll go and
leave that we're going to run this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441 and
this way you can actually see how the
reshape looks a lot different uh
0.041.15.71 and then instead of having
this one it rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what I was talking about
sometimes you feel a lot of times you
feel these with random numbers and so
this is the random.uniform is one of the
ways to do that now I just talked a
little bit about this float 32 and all
these data types one of the things that
comes up of course is recasting your
data
um so if we have a d-type float32 we
might want to convert these two integers
because of the project we're working on
I know one of the projects I've worked
on ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
run it off to a dollar amount so we only
wanted two decimal points
um and in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by
100 and then round it off or whatever
you want to do there's a lot of or then
convert it to an integer was one way to
round it off kind of
a cheap and dirty trick
so we can take this we can take the same
tensor and we'll go ahead and create a
as an integer and so we're going to take
this tensor we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor and then we're going to go ahead
and print
our
tensor
let me just do a quick copy and paste
and when I'm actually programming I
usually type out a lot of my stuff just
to double check it in doing a demo copy
and paste works fine but sometimes be
aware that copy and paste can copy the
wrong code over personal choice depends
on what I'm working on
and you can see here we took a float32
4.6 4.2 and so on and it just converts
it right down to a integer value
sorry integer 32 setup and uh remember
we talked about a little bit about
reshape
as far as flipping it and I just did
four comma 3 on the reshape up here and
we talked about axis 0 axis one one of
the things that is important to be able
to do is to take one of these variables
we'll just take this last one tensor as
integer
and I want to go ahead and transpose it
and so I can do we'll do a
equals TF dot transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if I print the A out and we run
this
you'll see it's the same array but we've
flipped it so that our columns and rows
are flipped this is the same as
reshaping so when you transpose you're
just doing a reshape what's nice about
this is that if you look at the numbers
The Columns when we went up here and we
did the reshape they kind of roll down
to the next row so you're not
maintaining the structure of your Matrix
so when we do a reshape up here they're
similar but they're not quite the same
and you can actually go in here and
there's settings in the reshape that
would allow you to turn it into a
transform
uh so when we come down here it's all
done for you and so there are so many
times you have to transpose your digits
that this is important to know that you
can just do that you can flip your rows
and columns rather quickly here and just
like numpy you can also do multiple your
different math functions we'll look at
multiplication and so we're going to
take matrix multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a as a
constant 5839 and we'll put in a vector
v 4 comma two and we could have done
this where they matched where this was a
two by two array but instead we're going
to do just a two by one array and the
code for that is your TF dot mat mole so
Matrix multiplier and we have a times V
and if we go ahead and run this up let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this
you'll see that we end up with 36 by 30.
and if it's been a while since you've
seen The Matrix math this is five times
four plus eight times two
three times four plus nine times two
and that's where we get the 36 and 30.
now I know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality
so the Matrix or your Matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used back-end tool as
far as Computing
um
different models or linear regression
stuff like that one of the things
is to note is that just like in numpy
you have all of your different math so
we have our TF math
and if we go in here we have functions
we have our cosines absolute angle all
of that's in here so all of these are
available for you to use in the
tensorflow model and if we go back to
our example and let's go ahead and pull
oh let's do some multiplication that's
always good we'll stick with our av our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bitwise
multiplication and we'll create an AV
which is a times V let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here we
have the 4 2 and the 5839 and it
produces a 20 32 618
and that's pretty straightforward if you
look at it you have four times five is
twenty four times eight is uh 32 that's
where those numbers come from
we can also quickly create an identity
Matrix
which is basically your main values on
the diagonal being ones and zeros across
the other side let's go ahead and take a
look and see what that uh
looks like we can do let's do this uh
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way very similar to your numpy
you can do a DOT shape and it's going to
return a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick print
we'll do rows oops
and we'll do columns
and if we run this you can see we have
three rows two columns
and then if we go ahead and create an
identity Matrix
the scripts
the script for that hit a wrong button
there the script for that looks like
this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and D type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module available but
we do want to start looking at this as a
prediction model and seeing how it
functions so we're going to move on to a
more of a
direct setup where you can actually see
the full tensorflow in use for that
let's go back and create a new setup
and we'll go in here new Python 3 module
there we go
bring this out so it takes up the whole
window because I like to do that
hopefully I made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being a series
of numpy arrays you got your math
equations and different things that go
into them we're going to start building
a full
um
set up as far as the numpy so you can
see how Cara sits on top of it and the
different aspects of how it works the
first thing you want to do is we're
going to go ahead and do a lot of
imports date times warning SCI Pi SCI Pi
is your
maths or the back end scientific math
warnings because whenever we do a lot of
this you have older versions newer
versions and so sometimes when you get
warnings you want to go ahead and just
suppress them we'll talk about that if
it comes up on this particular setup and
of course date time
pandas again is your data frame think
rows and columns we import it as PD
numpy is your numbers array which of
course tensorflow is integrated heavily
with
Seaborn for our graphics and the Seaborn
as SNS is going to be set on top of our
matplot library which we import as MPL
and then of course we're going to import
our matplot library Pi plot as PLT and
right off the bat we're going to set
some graphic colors patch Force Edge
color equals true the style we're going
to use the 538 style you can look this
all up there's when you get into matplot
Library into Seabourn there are so many
options in here it's just kind of nice
to make it look pretty when we start the
um when we start up that way we don't
have to think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take and we
have our mplrc we're going to put a
patch Ed color dim Gray Line with again
this is all part of our Graphics here in
our setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell node interactivity
equals last expression uh here we are PD
for pandas options display Max columns
so we don't want to display more than
50. and then our matplot library is
going to be inline this is a Jupiter
notebook thing the matplot library
inline and then warnings we're going to
filter our warnings and we're just going
to ignore warnings that way when they
come up we don't have to worry about
them not really what you want to do when
you're working on a major project you
want to make sure you know those
warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background
uh so that's a little back end kind of
stuff then what we want to go ahead and
do is we want to go ahead and import our
specific packages that we're going to be
working with which is under Karas now
remember cross kind of sits on
tensorflow so when we're importing cross
and the sequential model we are in
effect importing
um tensorflow underneath of it we just
brought in the math probably should have
put that up above and then we have our
cross models we're going to import
sequential now if you remember from our
slide there was three different options
let me just flip back over there so we
can have a quick recall on that and so
in Cross we have sequential functional
and subclassing so remember those three
different setups in here we talked about
earlier and if you remember from here we
have uh sequential where it's going one
tensorflow layer at a time you go kind
of look at think of it as going from
left to right or top to bottom or
whatever Direction it's going in but it
goes in One Direction all the time where
functional can have a very complicated
graph of directions you can have the
data split into two separate tensors and
then it comes back together into another
tensor all those kinds of things and
then subclassing is really the really
complicated one where now you're adding
your own subclasses into the tensor to
do external computations right in the
middle of like a huge flow of data but
we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional but we're
running a sequential tensorflow and
that's what this first import is here we
want to bring in our sequential and then
we have our layers and let's talk a
little bit about these layers this is
where cross and tensorflow really are
happening this is what makes them so
nice to work with is all these layers
are pre-built so from Cross we have
layers import dents from Cross layers
import LST M when we talk about these
layers
cross has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers the dense layer
is your standard neural network by
default it uses relu for its activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data we
want to go ahead and do the lstm and if
we go into
um cross and we look at their layers
this is a cross website you can see as
we scroll down for the cross layers that
are built in we can get down here and we
can look at let's see here we have our
layer activation our base layers
activation layer weight layer weights
there's a lot of stuff in here we have
the rayleu which is the basic activation
that was listed up here for layer
activations you can change those and
here we have our core layers and our
dense layer so you have an input layer a
dense layer and then we've added a more
customized one with the long-term
short-term memory layer and of course
you can even do your own custom layers
in Karas there's a whole functionality
in there if you're doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the convolutional
layers this is for processing Graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do this is why cross is so popular
it's open source and you have all these
tools right at your fingertips so from
Cross we're just going to import a
couple layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer and
then of course from sklearn our site kit
we want to go ahead and do our min max
scalar standard scaler for pre-editing
our data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality.csv let's go ahead and take a
quick look at that this is in Open
Office it's just a standard you know we
can do excel whatever you're using for
your spreadsheet and you can see here we
have a number of columns a number of
rows it actually goes down to like 8 000
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row is kind of just a
random number put in going down probably
not something we're going to work with
the second row is Bandung I'm guessing
that's a reference for the profile if we
scroll to the bottom which I'm not going
to do because it takes forever to get
back up they're all the same the same
thing with the status the status is the
same we have a date so we have a
sequential order here
here is the jam which I'm going to guess
is the time stamp on there so we have a
date and time
we have our O3 CEO NO2 reading SO2
noco2 VOC and then some other numbers
here pm1 PM 2.5 pm4 pm10
without actually looking through the
data I mean some of this I can guess is
like temperature humidity I'm not sure
what the PMS are but we have a whole
slew of data here so we're looking at
air quality as far as an area and a
region and what's going on with our date
time stamps on there and so code wise
we're going to read this into a pandas
data frame so our data frame DF is a
nice abbreviation commonly used for data
frames equals pd.read CSV and then our
the path to it just happens to be on my
D drive separated by spaces and so if we
go ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in Jupiter I can take this and go
the other way make it real small so you
can see all the columns going across and
we get a full view of it
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at we're looking at
the number we're looking at the profile
which is the band done the date we have
a time stamp our O3 count Co and so
forth on here
and this is just your basic pandas
printing out the top five rows we could
easily have done three rows
five rows ten whatever you want to put
in there by default that's five for
pandas now I've talked about this all
the time so I know I've already said it
at least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together so we want to go ahead
and start with our date time let's come
in in two columns we have our date here
and we have our time
and we want to go ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combine date
time that's our formula we're building
or we're going to submit our pandas data
frame and the tab name when we go ahead
and do this that's all of our
information that we want to go ahead and
create and then goes for Iron Range DF
shape zero so we're going to go through
the whole setup and we're going to list
tab a pin DF location I and here is our
date going in there and then return the
numpy array list tab d-types date time
64. that's all we're doing we're just
switching this to a date time stamp and
if we go ahead and do DF date time
equals combine date time and then I
always like to print we'll do DF head
just so we can see what that looks like
and so when we come out of this we now
have our setup on here and of course
it's added it on to the far right here's
our date time you can see the formats
changed uh so there's our we've added in
the date time column and we've brought
the date over and we've taken this
format here and it's an actual variable
with a zero zero zero on here well that
doesn't look good so we need to also
include the time part of this we want to
convert it into hourly data so let's go
ahead and do that to do that to finish
combining our date time let's go ahead
and create a a little script here to
combine the time in there same thing we
just did we're just creating a numpy
array returning a numpy array and crit
forcing this into a date time format and
we can actually spend hours just going
through these conversions how do you
pull it from the pandas data frame how
do you set it up so I'm kind of skipping
through it a little fast because I want
to stay focused on tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 percent of
your coding when you're doing a lot of
this stuff is going to be reformatting
these things resetting them back up so
that it looks right on here and you know
it just takes time to to get through all
that but that is usually what the
companies are paying you for that's what
the big bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
um now remember we can select from DF
our different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped a couple of the
columns those ones I showed you earlier
they're just repetitive data so there's
nothing in there that exciting and then
we want to go ahead and we'll create a
second
data frame here let me just get rid of
the DF head
and df2 is we're going to group by date
time and we're looking at the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see we're talking about
we have now reorganized this so we put
in date time 03 Co so now this is in the
same order as it was before and you'll
see the date time now has our zero zero
same date one two three and so on so
let's group the data together so there's
a lot more manageable and in the format
we want and in the right sequential
order
and if we go back to there we go our air
quality you can see right here we're
looking at
um
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own date time column we can get rid
of those these are the different Columns
of information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there
that's all we've done is reformatted our
data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist first thing I want to do is
get a description what am I looking at
and so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our you know
describe gives us our basic data
analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation
minimum amount maximum amount we have
our first quarter second quarter and
third quarter
numbers also in there so you can get a
quick look at a glance describing the
data or descriptive analysis and even
though we have our quantile information
in here we're going to dig a little
deeper into that we're going to
calculate the quantile for each variable
we're going to look at a number of
things for each variable we'll see right
here q1 we can simply do the quantile
0.25 percent
which should match our 25 up here and
we're gonna be looking at the Min the
Max and we're just going to do this is
basically we're breaking this down for
each uh different
variable in there one of the things
that's kind of fun to do we're going to
look at that in just a second let me get
put the next piece of code in here I
clean out some of our
um we're going to drop a couple thing
our last rows and first row because
those have usually have a lot of null
values and the first row is just our
titles so that's important it's
important to drop those rows in here and
so this right here as we look at our
different quantiles again it's it's the
same and we're still looking at the 25
quantile here we're going to do a little
bit more with this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows we're going to go ahead
and go through all of our columns and
this way we can look at each column
individually and so we'll just create a
q1 Q3 min max Min IQR Max IQR and
calculate the quantile of I of df2
we're basically doing the math that they
did up here but we're splitting it apart
that's all this is
and this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual if this was
my own project I would probably spend
days and days going through what these
different values mean
one of the biggest data science uh
things we can look at that's important
is use your use your common sense you
know if you're looking at this data and
it doesn't make sense and you go back in
there and you're like wait a minute what
the heck did I just do at that point you
probably should go back and double check
what you have going on
now we're looking at this and you can
see right here here's our attribute for
our O3 so we've broken it down we have
our q1 5.88 Q3 10.37 if we go back up
here here's our five eight we've rounded
it off
10.37s in there
so we've basically done the same math to
split it up we have our minimum and our
Max IQR and that's computed let's see
where is it here we go uh q1 minus 1.5
times IQR and the IQR is your Q3 minus
q1 so that's the difference between our
two different quarters this is all data
science as far as the hard math we're
really not that we're actually trying to
focus on cross and tensorflow you still
got to go through all this stuff I told
you eighty percent of your programming
is going through and understanding what
the heck happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so when we're looking in that we're
going to go ahead and say hey
um
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum IQR
that means something's going wrong there
and usually in this case is going to
show us an outlier so we want to go
ahead and find the minimum value if it's
less than the minimum minimum IQR it's
an outlier and if the max value is
greater than the max IQR we have an
outlier and that's all this is doing low
outliers found minimum value High
outlier is found really important
actually outliers are almost everything
in data sometimes sometimes you do this
project just to find the outliers
because you want to know crime detection
what are we looking for we're looking
for the outliers what doesn't fit a
normal business deal and then we'll go
ahead and throw in just threw in a lot
of code oh my goodness so we have if
your max is greater than IQR print
outlier is found what we want to do is
we want to start cleaning up these
outliers and so we want to convert we'll
do create a convert Nan x max IQR equals
Max underscore IQR men IQR equals
midnight QR so this is just saying this
is the data we're going to send that's
all that is in Python and if x is
greater than the max IQR and X is less
than the Min IQR x equals null we're
going to set it to null why because we
want to clear these outliers out of the
data now again if you're doing fraud
detection you would do the opposite you
would be cleaning everything else it's
not in that Series so that you can look
at just the outlier and then we're going
to convert the Nan hum again we have X
Maxi QR is 100 percent Min iqrs Min IQR
if x is greater than Max IQR and X is
less than Min IQR again we're going to
return null value otherwise it's going
to remain the same value x x equals X
and you can see as we go through the
code if I equals our hum then we go
ahead and do this that's a column
specific to humidity that's your hem
column then we're going to go ahead and
convert do the run a map on there and
convert the none hum you can see here
it's this is just clean up we run we've
found out that humidity probably has
some weird values in it we have our
outliers
that's all this is and so when we go
ahead and finish this and we take a look
at our outliers and we run this code
here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier 99.06 outliers have been
interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are these days when you're
looking at something like these sensors
coming in they probably have a failed
sensor in there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then converting it
over and setting it up method linear
so we interpolate method linears it's
going to fill that data in based on a
linear regression model of similar data
same thing with this up here with the
df2i interpolate that's what we're doing
again this is all data prep we're not
actually talking about tensorflow we're
just trying to get all our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
oh so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
um
we ran through this you can see down
here that we have our outliers found
high low outliers
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data how
do we know that some of it's just
looking at the data playing with it
until you start understanding what's
going on let's take the temp value and
we're going to go ahead and use a
logarithmic function on the temp value
and it's interesting because it's like
how do you how do you have to even know
to use logarithmic on the temp value
that's domain specific we're talking
about being an expert in air care I'm
not an expert in Air Care
um you know it's not what I go look at I
don't look at Air Care data in fact this
is probably the first Air Care data
setup I've looked at but the experts
come in there and they come to even say
hey in data science this is a
exponentially variable variable on here
so we need to go ahead and do
transform it
and use a logarithmic scale on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts data analytics a lot of times
you're talking about somebody who is a
data analysis might be all the way
usually a PhD level data science
programming level interfaces database
manager that's going to be the person
who's your admin working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey domain Air Care this
needs to be this is a skew because the
data just goes up exponentially and
affects everything else and we'll go
ahead and take that data let me just go
ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it
um we have our uh we'll do a
distribution DF we'll create another
data frame from the temp values and then
from a data set from the log temp so we
put them side by side and we'll just go
ahead and do a quick histogram and this
is kind of nice plot a figure figure
size here's our PLT from matplot library
and then we'll just do a distribution
underscore DF there's our data frames
this is nice because it just integrates
the histogram right into pandas love
pandas and this is a chart you would
send back to your data analysis and say
hey is this what you wanted this is how
the data is converting on here as a data
science scientist the first thing I note
is we've gone from a 10 20 30 scale to
2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
adjusted a little bit based on some kind
of a skew on there so let's jump into
we're getting a little closer to
actually doing our
cross on here we'll go ahead and split
our data up and this of course is any
good data scientists you want to have a
training set and a test set and we'll go
ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 percent of the
data make sure it's an integer we don't
want to take a slice as a float value
give you a nice error and we'll have our
train size is 75 percent and the test
size is going to be of course the train
size minus the length of the data set
and then we can simply do train comma
test here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size and then if we go and print
this let me just go and run this we can
see how these values split it's a nice
split of 1298 and then 433 points of
value that are going to be for our setup
on here and if you remember we're
specifically looking at the data set
where did we create that data set from
that was from up here that's what we
called the logarithmic value of the temp
that's where the data set came from so
we're looking at just that column with
this train size and the test with the
train and test data set here and let's
go ahead and do uh converted an array of
values into a data set Matrix we're
going to create a little
um
set up in here we create our data set
our data set is going to come in we're
going to do a look back of one so we're
going to look back one piece of data
going backward
and we have our data X and our data y
for Iron Range length of data set look
back minus one
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data
and take a look at the shape of it let
me go ahead and just put that code in
here
so we're going to do a look back one
here's our trainex our train Y and it's
going to be adding the data on there and
then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape
there we go and we run this piece of
code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of X 1296 comma 1
shape of Y train y Test X text y
and so what we're looking at is that
the X comes in
and we're only having a single value out
we want to predict what the next one is
that's what this little piece of code is
here for what are we looking for well we
want to look back one that's the um then
what we're going to train the data with
is yesterday's data yesterday says Hey
the humidity was at 97 what should
today's humidity be at if it's 97
yesterday is it going to go up or is it
going to go down today if 97 does it go
up to 100 what's going on there and so
our we're looking forward to the next
piece of data which says Hey tomorrow's
is going to you know today's humidity is
this this is what tomorrow's humidity is
going to be that's all that is all that
is is stacking our data so that our Y is
basically X Plus 1 or X could be y minus
1.
and then a couple things to note is our
X data we're only dealing with the one
column but you need to have it in a
shape that has it by The Columns so you
have the two different numbers and since
we're doing just a single point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here now this is going to run into a
problem and the reason is is that we
have what they call a Time step
and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory layer so we're going
to add another reshape on here let me
just go down here and put it into the
next cell and so we want to reshape the
input array in the form of sample time
step features
we're only looking at one feature
and I mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am I getting an error in the
numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on so we're going
to do is we're going to add one more
level on here instead of being 12.99 one
we want to go one more
and when they put the code together in
the back you can see we kept the same
shape the 12.99 we added the one
dimension and then we have our train X
shape one and this could have depends
again on how far back in the long
short-term memory you want to go that is
what that piece of code is for and that
reshape is and you can see the new shape
is now one uh 12.99 one one versus the
1299 one and then the other part of the
shape 432 one one again this is our TR
our X in and of course our test X and
then our Y is just a single column
because we're just doing one output that
we're looking for so now we've done our
80 percent
um you know that's all the the writing
all the code reformatting our data
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit the lstm
neural network uh and if we're going to
do that the first thing we need is we're
going to need to go ahead and create a
model and we'll do this sequential model
and if you remember sequential means it
just goes in order that means we have if
you have two layers the layers go from
layer one to Layer Two or layer 0 to
layer one this is different than
functional functional allows you to
split the data and run two completely
separate models and then bring them back
together we're doing just sequential on
here and then we decided to do the long
short term memory and we have our input
shape which it comes in again this is
what all this switching was we could
have easily made this one two three or
four going back as far as the end number
on there we just stuck to going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck is this
model coming from what kind of models do
we have available
and there's let me go and put the next
model in there uh because we're going to
do two models and the next model is
going to go ahead and we're going to do
dents so we have model equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add a
dense model and if you remember from the
very top of our code
but we did the Imports oops there we go
our cross this is it right here here's
our importing a dense model and here's
our importing an lstm now just about
every tensorflow model uses dense your
dense model is your basic
forward propagation reverse propagation
error where it does reverse propagation
to program the model so any of your
neural networks you've already looked at
that lexan says here's the error and
sends the error backwards that's what
this is the long short term memory is a
little different the real question that
we want to look at right now is where do
you find these models what kind of
models do you have available and so for
that let's go to the Cross website which
is across.io if you go under API slash
layers and I always have to do a search
just search for cross API layers it'll
open up and you can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable weights all kinds of stuff
like there your Activation so a lot of
your layers you can switch how it
activates relu which is like your
smaller arrays or if you're doing
convolutional neural networks the
convolution usually uses a relu your
sigmoid all the way up to softmax soft
plus all these different choices as far
as how those are set up and what we want
to do is we want to go ahead if you
scroll down here you'll see your core
layers and here is your dense layer so
you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer this is your your kind of your one
setup on there that's most common uh
convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing uh image categorizing uh so trying
to find objects in a picture that kind
of thing we have pooling layers so as
you have the layers come together
usually bring them down into a single
layer although you can still do like
Global Max pulling 3D and there's just I
mean this list just goes on and on
there's all kinds of different things
hidden in here as far as what you can do
and it changes you know you go in here
and you just have to do a search for
what you're looking for and figure out
what's going to work best for you
as far as which project you're working
on long short term memory is a big one
because this is when we start talking
about text
what if someone says the what comes
after the The Cat in the Hat little kids
book there
starts programming it and so you really
want to know not only what's going on
but it's going to be something that has
a history the history behind it tells
you what the next one coming up is now
once we've built all our different you
know we built our model we've added our
different layers we went in there play
with it remember if you're in functional
you can actually link these layers
together and they Branch out and come
back together if you do a uh the sub
set up then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might become the linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model as part of your
functional split and then have that come
back together with other things so we're
going to go ahead and compile your model
this brings everything together we're
going to put in what the losses which
will use the mean squared error and
we'll go ahead and use the atom
Optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like any of these
different prediction models if you've
been doing any side kit from python
you'll recognize that we have to then
fit the model so what are we doing in
here we're going to send in our train X
our train y we're going to decide how
many epics we're going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this I'm
guessing it'd probably be about two or
three hundred probably do just fine our
batch size
so how many different when you process
it this is a math behind it if you're in
data analytics you might try to know
what this number is as a data scientist
where I haven't had the PHD level math
that says this is why you want to use
this particular batch size you kind of
play with this number a little bit you
can dig deeper into the math
see how it affects the results depending
on what you're doing and there's a
number of other settings on here we did
verbose two I'd have to actually look
that up to tell you what verbose means I
think that's actually the default on
there if I remember correctly there's a
lot of different settings when you go to
fit it the big ones are your epic and
your batch size those are what we're
looking for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times through all the data so if you
have a huge data set this is the point
where you're kind of wondering oh my
gosh is this going to finish tomorrow
if I'm running this on a single machine
and I have a terabyte terabyte of data
going into it
if this is my personal computer and I'm
running a terabyte of data into this you
know this is running rather quickly
through all 500 iterations but you got a
terabyte of data we're talking something
closer to days week
you know even with a
3.5 gigahertz machine in in eight cores
it's still going to take a long time to
go through a full terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will
prevail the process on there more across
multiple processors and multiple
computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 08089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere so we really
didn't need to go through a full 500
epics
uh you know if you're retraining this
stuff over and over again it's kind of
good to note where that error zone is so
you don't have to do all the extra
processing of course if you're going to
build a model
we want to go ahead and run a prediction
on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction and remember we have our
training test set and our test set or
the we have the
trainx and the train y for training it
or train predict and then we have our
test X and our test y going in there so
we can test to see how good it did
uh and we come in here we have you'll
see right here we go ahead and do our
train predict equals model predict train
X
and test predict model predict Test X
why would we want to run the prediction
on trainx well it's not a hundred
percent on its prediction we know it has
a certain amount of error and we want to
compare the error we have on what we
programmed it with with the error we get
when we run it on new data that's never
C the model's never seen before and one
of the things we can do we go ahead and
invert the predictions this helps us
level it off a little bit more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals and NP
exponential M1 the train predict and
then train y equals the exponential M1
for train Y and then we do it again that
with train test predict and test y
um again reformatting the data so that
we can it all matches and then we want
to go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error so we have our train score
which is your math square root times the
mean square root error train Y and train
predict and again we're just um this is
just feeding the data through so we can
compare it and the same thing with the
test
now let's take a look at that because
really the code makes sense if you're
going through it line by line you can
see we're doing but the answer really
helps to zoom in so we have a train
score which is
2.40 of our root mean square error and
we have a test score of 3.16 of the root
mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score then
we've over trained something's really
wrong at that point you got to go back
and figure out what you did wrong
because it you should never have a
better result on your test data than you
do on your training data and that's how
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing when you're going out
and quoting your publishing this you're
saying hey how good is my model it's the
test score that you're showing people
this is what it did on my test data that
the model had never seen before this is
how good my model is and a lot of times
you actually want to put together like a
little formal code
where we actually want to print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
test prediction and standard deviation
of data set to 3.16 is less than
4.40 I'd have to go back and we're up
here if you remember we did the square
means error this is standard deviation
that's why these numbers are different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we can go ahead and go with that
and along with putting a formal print
out of there we want to go ahead and
plot what's going on
uh and this we just want a pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on when I walk into a meeting and I'm
dealing with a number of people they
really don't want these numbers they
don't want to say hey what's I mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are you might be dealing with
a number of different departments head
of sales might not work with standard
deviation or have any idea what that
really means number wise and so at this
point we really want to put it in a
graph so we have something to display
and with displaying you gotta remember
that we're looking at the data today
going into it and what's going to happen
tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting we have our
train predict plot
NP MP like data set train predict plot
set it up with null values
you know it's just kind of it's kind of
a weird thing where we're creating the
um the data groups as we like them and
then putting the data in there is what's
going on here so we have our train
predict plot which is going to be our
look back our length plus look back
we're just it's going to equal train uh
try and predict so we're creating this
basically we're taking this and we're
dumping the train predict into it so now
we have our nice train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting we're going
to continue more of that oops looks like
I put it in here double no let's just uh
yeah they put it in here double
um didn't mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go
um this is where the problem was is
because this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here and then the
test predict we're going to look at that
same thing we're just creating those two
data sets uh test predict plot length
prediction set up on there
and then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions so we have a Time axes
always nice to have your time set on
there set that to the time array time
axes lap all this is setting up the time
variable for the bottom and then we have
a lot of stuff going on here as far as
setting up our figure
let's go ahead and run that and then
we'll break it down
we have on here our main plot we have
two different plots going on here the
ispu going up in the data and the ispu
here with all these different settings
on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot I mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here so
we're doing a figure PLT or plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there and so we take and if you go
through the code piece by piece which
we're not going to do we're going to do
the the
data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly we're going to label it
the original data set we're going to
plot the train predict plot that's what
we just created we're going to make that
orange and we'll label it train
prediction test predicts plot we're
going to make that red and label it test
prediction and so forth set our ticks up
let's actually just put time axes gets
its ticks little little marks that are
going along the axes that kind of thing
and let's take a look and see what these
graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output and you say hey this
is what we're looking at here's our
original data in blue
here's our training prediction you can
see that it trains pretty close to what
the data is up there
I would also probably put a um like a
little little time stamp and do just
right before and right after where we go
from uh train to test prediction and you
can see with the test prediction the
data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set looked like behind it
and how it differs and then we can just
isolate that here on the right that's
all this is is just the test prediction
on the right uh and it's you know
there's you'll see what the original
data set there's a lot of Peaks we're
missing and a lot of lows were missing
but as far as the actual test prediction
it's pretty it does pretty good it's
pretty right on you can get a good idea
what to expect for your ispu and so from
this we would probably publish it and
say hey this is what you expect and this
is our area of this is a range of error
that's the kind of thing I put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
sales are going to be this or maybe
weekly so you kind of get a nice you
kind of flatten the um data coming out
and you say hey this is what we're
looking at the big takeaway from this is
that we're working with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
um is this model here this is what this
is all about we work through all of
those pieces all the tensorflows and
that is to build this sequential model
and we're only putting in the two layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never it never
verges into a usable model so if you
have like 30 different layers in here
there's a good chance you might crash it
kind of thing so don't go too hate wire
on that and that you kind of learn as
you go again it's domain knowledge and
also starting to understand all these
different layers and what they mean
the data
analytics behind those layers is
something that your data analysis
professional would come in and say this
is what we want to try
but I tell you as a data scientist a lot
of these basic setups are common and I
don't know how many times uh working
with somebody and they're like oh my
gosh if I only did a tangent H instead
of a relu activation I worked for two
weeks to figure that out well as a data
science I can run it through the model
in you know five minutes instead of
spending two weeks doing the the math
behind it so that's one of the
advantages of data scientists is we do
it from programming side in a data
analytics it's going to look for it how
does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently and of course with any data
science putting out a pretty graph so
that your shareholders again we want to
take and reduce the information down to
something people can look at and say oh
that's what's going on they can see
stuff what's going on is as far as the
dates and the change in the ispu now
let's talk a little bit about a
recurrent neural networks so neural
networks are of different types we have
CNN we have RNN and so on now RNN is one
type of neural network RNN stands for
recurrent neural network the networks
like CNN and an are feed forward Network
which means that the information pretty
much only goes from left to right or
from front to back whichever way you
call it whereas in case of recurrent
neural network there will be some
information traveling backwards as well
so that is why it is known as recurrent
neural network and each of these types
have a specific application so for
example convolutional neural networks or
CNN are very good for doing image
processing and object detection using
for video and images whereas recurrent
neural networks are pretty good for
doing NLP or speech recognition and so
on okay so for the next few minutes we
will kind of focus on recurrent neural
networks and we will see an example of
how we can use RNN to do a Time series
analysis so in a typical neural network
this is how it looks right so where you
have a neuron and then the inputs are
coming to the neuron and then you have
an output which goes to other neurons in
the other layers in case of recurrent
neural network what happens is you have
the inputs let's say at a given point in
time but then a part of the previous
output also gets fed in along with the
inputs for the given time now this can
be little confusing so let's see if we
can take a little expanded view of this
so this is another view of one single
neuron which is what is known as in an
unfolded manner okay so if we are
getting inputs or data over a period of
time then this is how the neuron will
look remember these are not three
neurons this is one neuron and it is
what is known as it is shown in a
unfolded way okay we are on we have
unfolded this single neuron over a
period of time so at a given time let's
say T minus 1 an input of x t minus 1 is
fed to the neuron and it gets a output
of Y T minus 1 then the next instant
which is x t at a time T right there is
an input of x t and then there is an
output of y t so this is a single neuron
but it's displayed in an unfolded way so
this is like expanding it over a period
of time so let's start with this part
here this particular neuron gets an
input at an instant T minus 1 let's say
time is equal to T minus 1 it gets an
input of x t minus 1 and it gives an
output of Y T minus then when we go to
the instant T here it gets an input of x
t and it also additionally gets an input
from this previous time frame T minus 1.
so this y t minus 1 gets fed here and
that results in YT all right then when
we go to the time t plus 1 there is an
input of x t minus 1 at that given time
plus the input from the previous time
frame which is a time frame of T that
also gets fed in here and then we get an
output of y t plus 1 okay so let me
explain once again this is a single
neuron so these are not three different
neurons a single neuron seen over a
period of time from T minus 1 to t plus
1 and unlike a regular feed forward
neuron which only gets X in this case
the input is X and all also another
input which is coming from the previous
time frame and that is what this Loop is
in this on the left hand side diagram
this Loop is indicating that okay so on
the right hand side it is represented in
an unfolded way okay so the input if we
take a time frame T for example is not
only x t which is the input which is the
normal input at the time frame T but it
is also getting an input from the
previous time frame which is this y t
minus 1 will also being fed as an input
that is a key differentiator here okay
similarly at the instant t plus 1 it is
getting a normal input of x t plus 1
plus this y t is actually being fed here
and then the output comes as y t plus
one okay so this is the construct of a
recurrent neural network now recurrent
neural networks again can be of
different subtypes it can be one to one
one to many many to one and many to many
depending on what kind of application we
want to use one of the examples is like
the stock stock price so you're feeding
so there is only one input only thing is
it is spread over a period of time so
you're feeding the stock price input
that is what comes here as an input and
you get an output which is again the
stock price which is probably predicted
over the next uh two days three days or
10 days or whatever so the number of
outputs and inputs is the same there is
only one input there is only one output
only thing is it is spread over time so
variables are not many then you have one
too many so there is one input but you
are expecting multiple outputs what is
an example of this let's say you want to
caption an image so how do you want to
do that what is the input that will go
here is just an image which is one input
but what is output you are looking for
you are looking for a phrase maybe right
not just a word but a phrase so it's
like cat is sitting on a map right so
the image is there is only one image in
which consists of the cat sitting on a
mat but the output or like maybe three
or four words which is saying the cat is
sitting on a mat so this is one to many
right then you can have many to one
examples of this are like you're feeding
some text and you want to know the
output whether the text is what kind of
sentiment is expressed by the text it
could be positive it could be negative
so that's the output you're looking for
so you feed a large number of words
maybe the text May consist of words or
lines or whatever so that is what is the
multiple inputs but the output all it
says is the sentiment is positive it is
just one output or the sentiment is
negative just one output right so this
is minute over then we have many too
many so what is an example of this let's
say you want to do some translation so
how do you do a translation you feed in
a sentence maybe in a particular
language English and then you want
another a sentence actually in another
language so that is like there are
multiple inputs one sentence can consist
of multiple words and the output also is
a sentence consisting of multiple words
all right so how do we Implement RNN
this is an example of implementing an
RNN for a particular use case so in our
particular example we have the data
about milk production over a few months
and using RNN we want to predict because
this is time series analysis so RNN is
good to do time series analysis so using
RNN we want to predict what will be the
milk production in the future so let us
see how we can do that I will first take
you through quickly through the slides
and then I will actually run this in in
a jupyter notebook the code I will run
it in the jupyter notebook so this is
how it looks the code looks so while the
sustensorflow you still use the standard
python libraries like numpy and pandas
and even matplotlib to do some initial
processing getting the data processing
it cleaning it whatever all that can be
still done in within the same program so
that's what we're doing here we're
importing some libraries like numpy and
pandas and then we read the data file
and if we plot the data we see here it
is the data for for the years 1962 to 75
and we can see that there is a certain
Trend right so this is a typical time
series data would look again some of you
if you are not familiar with time series
and time series analysis and so on I
would recommend you to go through some
videos around that which will make it
easy to understand this so this is our
typical time series data would look in
this case it is nothing but there is
only one variable which is milk
production and it is spread across
several years so this is going from 1962
to 75 and that value has been plotted so
if you see there is a certain kind of a
trend here which is basically going
upwards and there will be some
seasonality so time series data has
these three components right so it will
have a trend it will have a seasonality
it will have seasonality and then it
will have some Randomness so that's what
this graph is showing and now if we want
to perform analysis on this time series
analysis on this first thing we need to
do is split the data into train and test
and in this case we will just use a
straightforward method which is taking
the data for the first 13 years so the
idea here is we need to train our model
right this is time series data so what
and we want to predict for the future so
the way we need to use this is we have
to take the data for a certain period of
time and train our model and then we use
a part of the known data so that we can
then ask our model to predict for that
duration and compare it with the known
information so what do we mean by that
so here if you see this data I will show
you in the notebook as well Jupiter
notebook as well this has 13 years of
data so what we are doing is we are
taking the first 12 years and using that
as our training set right so 12 years we
are doing and this has about I think 14
years of data so we are taking 13 years
of data for training purpose and then we
are using the last one year remaining
one year of data for testing purpose
because here what we can do is this one
year data we know the value right
because if we want to compare the
accuracy or anything like that we need
to know the value so in this case we
know the values of this one particular
year so we will use that but at the same
time we train the model for 13 years of
data and for the 14th Year we will ask
our model to predict and then compare it
with this known value so that we know
how accurate our model is I hope that
makes sense okay so that's what we are
doing here 156 is nothing but 12 into 13
on a monthly basis we get the data the
next step is to scale the data this is
all regular data manipulation data
managing activity and then you split it
you are basically assigning the train
and test data to the to the scaled
variables and then you need to read the
data in batches so it is very important
as I mentioned earlier also that instead
of reading the entire data in one shot
you feed the data in batches so in order
to do that we are writing a function for
that that's all we are doing here so
that is still here what we have done is
regular Python Programming there is no
tensorflow as of now here okay so so far
what we have done is preparation data
preparation data munching now what we
are doing is actually training our model
so this is where tensorflow now comes
into picture so we are importing first
step is to import the tensorflow library
so this is how you do it import
tensorflow SDF and then you can Define
some variables or constants whichever
way now here of course there are a
couple of ways of doing it you can
create them as tensorflow nodes but that
is a little bit of an overhead we will
just use the regular python variables
are constant so here I am creating
regular python variables and I'm saying
number of inputs is one so instead of
hard coding I'm just storing them as
variables so this is number of inputs is
one number of time steps is 12 number of
neurons is unread and so on right and
then learning rate is 0.03 and number of
iterations we are saying is four
thousand then we create placeholders now
we will be storing the independent
variables in X and the dependent
variables in y and this we will read
from an external file remember I told
you placeholders are used for getting
data from outside and then feeding it to
our model so that's the reason we have
two placeholders one for reading the X
values and another for reading the Y
values in this step we are only just
creating the nodes right so this is just
creating the graph and similarly we are
mentioning what is the loss function and
what is Optimizer and how to run the
optimizer and once that is done you are
initializing the variables and then
you're creating a saver variable or a
saver instance so saver is basically
nothing but in machine learning you can
train your model and you can save it for
later use so that's where the saving
comes into play we will see how to use
that as well and then the last step is
to create your session and run this
graph right so we are initializing the
variables remember this we run init so
which is nothing but this one so we are
initializing the variables whatever are
there instead of hard coding remember in
earlier case we were hard coding how
many iterations so here we are saying
for the given number of iterations which
are stored in this maybe how many
iterations We Said is What is the value
of iterations this is training
iterations is four thousand so we
specify that based on the number of
training iterations next batch will
basically fetch the data and then we run
the session we are basically saying
train is the node which we will run in
the session and this will basically
train our model and this is more for
printing every 100 times you print it
that's all this there's nothing more to
it so for example the output would look
somewhat like this this is for zero this
for 100 next for 200 and so on and then
you save the model remember saver we
created so you save the model for later
use so this is our test data remember we
are doing this on training data right so
once the training data training is done
we then try to create the inference on
the test data so that we can compare how
accurate this is right so this is how
the test set would look and then we will
basically restore this model okay
because in the previous slide we created
them model and we stored it so now we
have to restore the model and then run
our test data against it and see what
are the values that are predicted what
are the Y values and then compare with X
to see the accuracy so train seed is
what we are seeing here so that is what
will have the predicted values and these
predicted values what we want to do is
we want to create an additional column
because remember we need to compare
because we want to find out the accuracy
of this model so we need to compare the
predicted values with the actual value
so what we are doing here is adding
another column called generator and
assign a value to that all right so this
is the result of the prediction and then
if we need to reshape because we have to
show this in the form of a monthly
results so that's what we're doing here
and once we generate the results and
then display it we can actually see it
month wise here and the actual and the
generated values Okay so we create a
data frame which is a combination of the
actual values and the predicted values
from the test set and then we can plot
to see how the trend is as you can see
pretty much the actual value is in blue
color and the generated or predicted
value the curve is in yellow color the
trend is maintained so it will probably
it's not a hundred percent accurate but
the trend is maintained all right so
let's do one thing let's go into the
Jupiter notebook and take a look at how
this works in tensorflow environment
actually the code I will walk you
through the code this is my Jupiter
notebook and the data is taken from this
particular Link in case you're
interested you can download it from
there and this is the data for the years
1962 to 75. the first thing we do is
import these libraries because before we
start with the actual tensorflow
activity we need to prepare the data and
so on so for that you can use your
regular python libraries which are like
numpy pandas and so on so that's what we
are doing here and then we read the data
using pandas into a data frame so this
is a data frame milk is a data frame and
we will do some quick exploratory
analysis just to see how our data is
looking initials five records that we'll
get one two three four five that is the
head so it goes from 1960 to January to
1962 May once we re-change or basically
we need to split this into month
specifically separately so that's what
we are doing here day to time so we kind
of do a little bit of a re-indexing and
then if we plot this this is how the
data look as you can see there is a
clear upward Trend and there is some
seasonality and so on but anyway we will
not break that up into those components
we will just use RNN to predict and test
okay so the next thing is to check some
if we can do run like info it will tell
us what is the information about this
data set so let us just run that okay so
it is just telling us how many total
columns and what is the size of the file
and so on and so forth again in case you
are interested in doing some exploratory
analysis so what we'll do next is we
will take the 13 years of data for our
training data set so what are we going
to do now let me step back so what we
have we seen here we have seen that
there are 168 records so which is
nothing but 14 years of data we now have
to split this into our training and test
data set so how do we do that I think in
case of Time series we cannot do it like
80 20 like we do in normal letting in
normal machine learning process here it
is time series data so what we are going
to do is we will take out of this 14
years we will take the first 13 years of
data and we will use that for training
and then we will test it with the last
which is the 14th year data we will use
it for testing okay so that's what we
are going to do here so let's split that
so training set will consist of my 156
records which is nothing but 12 13 into
12 right my 13 years of data I am taking
for training and then my test set will
consist of the bottom 12 observations
which is last one year of data which is
the 14th year okay so that's now done
training and test splitting is done the
next step is to do some normalizing
which is basically we'll use our scaling
rather we will use min max Scala and we
will just scale the data and now we do
it for both tests as well as train now
we are ready to create our RNN model but
before that one quick thing in order to
fetch the data we have to create a
function so that's what we are doing
here we create a function called Next
batch and how you want to fetch the
steps they are all defined as our
constants if you remember and that's
what this function is all about so we
Define that function we will be calling
that in our Training Method All right so
from here onwards up to there we are
done with the preparation of the data
and whatever functions or whatever are
required from here onwards is where the
tensorflow parts starts so the first
thing we do is import the tensorflow
library typically this is a very
standard way of importing the library we
say import tensorflow as TF now TF is
nothing but a name so you can change it
to tf1 or ABC or XYZ whatever so this
part you can change but by and large
everybody uses this so we I would rather
recommend you also use the same syntax
so you say import tensorflow SDF so it's
very easy for others to understand as
well and then you declare or Define a
bunch of constants that's what we are
doing here like for example the number
of time steps in this case it is 12
number of neurons there are 100 number
of outputs it is only one and so on
right and then the learning rate and all
that we are declaring or defining those
variables in this particular block next
is to create placeholders you remember
the placeholders are used for feeding
the data so we have X and Y X is for the
input which is the independent variable
and Y is the output which is the
dependent variable and in our case these
are not different characteristics or
features but it is the same one feature
or one variable but it is over a period
of time so that's the only difference so
that's what we are doing here and now we
need to create our Network right the
neural network so in our case we said we
will create a RNN layer now there are
different ways or different formats of
RNN which is probably not in scope of
this module so for now we will just
assume we are creating one RNN layer and
one type of RNN is Gru cell so we will
use Gru cell and we use this apis for
creating our layer so each cell will be
with an output projection wrapper there
is a need for doing that and again the
details of this we will probably do in
another video where we talk in detail
about RNN so for now we are creating a
GRU cell with the wrapper and the Syntax
for creating the gru cell is like this
the number of units which we see said
there should be 100 neurons what will be
the activation function in this case it
is relu and then number of outputs in
our case it is only one okay so we
create the cell here okay then we got
the gru cell and then we say what is our
output which is nothing but we get the
outputs and the states and their states
and which is uh the way we get that is
TF Dot N N dot Dynamic underscore RNN so
if we call this and we pass the cell and
the data which is basically in
placeholder again remember all we are
doing here is we are creating just the
nodes for the graph so nothing is
actually getting executed from a
tensorflow perspective okay all right so
once that is done now we need to pass
this calculate the outputs and the
states using the dynamic underscore
ordinal method and we pass the cell as a
parameter and then the X values as a
parameter and if we run that we will
have the outputs and the states and this
is where we actually run the Training
Method so or create not really run the
Training Method but we create the nodes
for the training and the optimizer then
we have the initialization of the
variables and we save this model we
create a saber object just to save the
model because we will then restore it
and run it to do our predictions so this
is what we will do here so that is
another node and this is where we
actually create a session and run the
training okay so let's go ahead and do
that that will take a little while
because we said 4000 iterations so we
will allow it to finish we will probably
come back once the training is completed
all right so the training is done now
let's go and run this on the test data
so let's just quickly take a look at the
test data set so this is our one year
data for the year of 1975 so if we see
this this from January February and so
on and we will pass this to our model so
what are we doing here we are restoring
the model here for example right this is
the path that we have given when we were
saving the model let's go back once and
show you let me show you where we did
the saving of the model yes so we save
the model here so that again we will
restore that and we will use that to run
it on our test data and see how well it
predicts so let's go ahead and run this
and this is just 12 records so this will
not take time remember I told you
training is what takes a lot of time the
regular inference this is called
inference doesn't take much time right
so it just depends on how much data
there were only 12 records here so it
was very quick but in training what we
do we pass this multiple times there are
iterations 4000 iterations needed for
example so that takes longer and in
general in machine learning deep
learning training is what takes the
maximum amount of time all right so
let's go ahead and see the results we
will in order to plot it we will have to
kind of adjust the format of the results
otherwise we will not be able to see it
in a proper way and then we will so this
is our so what we have done is we
created a data frame which consists of
the predicted value and the and the
actual value so this is the data frame
so this is the actual value this is 834
or 782 and so on this is what our model
has predicted so it may not be so easy
to see in a tabular format so let's go
ahead and plot it so that we can compare
these two so when we plot it you will
see that the trend is more or less
maintained right so we go from the blue
color is the actual values and the
yellow color or the orange color
whatever is it is the one which is
generated by our model so it pretty much
is following the actual Trend so not bad
for such a quick iteration and training
this tutorial is about object detection
we will walk you through to a tensorflow
code using which we will do object
detection in images we will tell you
what are the libraries that are required
a little bit about the Coco data set and
then we will show you the implementation
code itself a demo of the code all right
so let's get started so what is the
tensorflow object detection API this is
an open source framework which is
actually provided by the tensorflow team
and there are trained models available
and the sample code is also available
which we can use in order to easily
detect objects in images and videos this
is pretty robust and can detect objects
fairly quickly and this is very easy for
people to use as well people with very
less or no knowledge of machine learning
or deep learning can also with a little
bit of Python Programming knowledge can
actually use this API this library to
build object detection applications this
is a list of libraries that are required
and they have been shown in the code as
well the exact purpose of each of this
Library why it is required is out of the
scope of this tutorial but we will see
in the code as we walk through some of
these libraries how and why they are
used the Coco data set Coco stands for
common objects in context so this data
set consists of 300 000 images of 90
most commonly found objects like chairs
and tables and so on and so forth so
this model has been trained or in fact a
set of models have been trained on this
data set and this is pretty good to
detect the most common objects in the
images and videos so with that let's get
into the code all right so the first
part is import all these libraries and
this we have shown you in the slides as
well again a large part of this will be
for doing some helper functions and
maybe for visualizing the images and so
on and so forth so that's the reason
they are required as I said the exact
details of each and every Library
probably is out of scope but these are
needed so as a first step maybe you just
go ahead and include these libraries and
run the code and maybe at later point we
can discuss what each of these libraries
does now this will work with tensorflow
version higher than 1.4 so if you are
having tensorflow version below 1.4 you
may have to upgrade to a higher version
so let me go ahead and execute the cell
and we also need this line of code to
make sure that once we run this object
detection the labeled image images are
displayed within this notebook and many
of you by now must be familiar with this
and we will import a few utility
libraries and you will see that we will
be using some of these for visualization
purpose so once the objects are detected
we need to display the information what
that object is and then what percentage
of confidence the model has so all these
details that's the utility functions
that stored here and then the next part
is to prepare the model as I mentioned
we will be using an existing trained
model the tensorflow team has actually
provided these models the one that we
will be using is SSD with the mobile net
but you can actually use any one of the
ones that are listed in this URL let me
just quickly take you through this URL
these are a bunch of models trained
models that are readily available for
anybody to use it is open source and let
me scroll down the only thing is that if
there are some of them where the
accuracy is much higher but they take
longer and there are some where the
accuracy is not so high and they are
much faster so they are faster but
accuracy may not be that very high so
you can play around with some of these
and we in this particular exercise or in
this particular tutorial we are using
this SSD model which is SSD mobile at
question one so that's the model that
we'll be using so in this cell we are
primarily creating a bunch of variables
with the various for example the name of
the model the path and so on and so
forth so that we will be using these
names in The Next Step which is to
download this model and install it
locally these are also referred to as
Frozen model so once they are trained
and then you kind of extract or you you
freeze the model so that's the reason
they are called Frozen models so that
others can just use this without any
further training so this is where we
download and extract our model locally
so this will take a little while let me
see if I can wait or maybe pause the
video and come back once it is done
might take a little while let's see if
it completes I have a pretty high speed
network but even then it takes some time
so that's good but this part is over now
let us see this part and yes both are
done so once that is done we need to
load some label mapping basically what
this will do is your model as you may be
aware by now if you do some
classification the model will actually
not give any output the text it will
give some numbers so if there are five
classes it will say okay this belongs to
model class one or two or three or five
and so on the numbers now each of these
will obviously the numbers will not not
make any sense to the outside world so
we need to do some small mapping so in
this case let's say one may be a chair
two maybe a table three maybe a balloon
and so on so that kind of number to text
mapping we need to do and that is what
is being done in this particular cell
and then we have a helper code which
will load the image and convert it into
a numpy array so that the number array
is what gets processed and used by the
model to do the detection part of it so
that is what this method is all about so
we will be there later on we will be
calling that function and next is
preparation for detection so here we are
basically telling where the images are
stored and how many images or what is
the naming convention or format of the
images now if you want you can modify
this code for example currently I have
test underscore images as my folder so
let me go and show this to you so this
is under my object detection folder I
have another subfolder where I am
storing my images which is text
underscore images now you can rename
this folder and give some other name and
then in your code you can probably give
that particular name for the subfold
similarly the format of these files what
is the name and format of this files
here it is in a very simple format which
is the names of the files are like beach
one beach two Beach three and so on so I
have taken Beach as the theme so I have
images which are related to beaches so
this is beach one beach two and then
these three are few others but we will
use these three for our demo and so
that's what I'm saying here the name of
the images will be which something dot
jpeg which is jpeg format and in this
curly braces basically we will will be
filled with either one two or three
based on in this part particular for
Loop okay so that is what this is doing
all right so the next step is to run
inference on these images in a loop and
what we are basically doing here is
getting these images one by one and then
running through the model to find out
what are the objects that can be
detected and then against each of the
object a box will be drawn and it will
be labeled with the name and the
percentage of accuracy or confidence
that the model detects these objects
okay so that is the function here and so
let me just run that piece of code and
here is basically where we are calling
this function so we are loading this
images and then we are calling this
function for each image and then we are
displaying this using the matplotlab
library so let's run this it will take
one image at a time and then detect the
images now the beauty is that the same
form of the code can be used for doing
object detection in a video so we have
another video for doing object detection
in a video so most of the code out there
will be reused from here and the only
thing is that instead of reading the
images from the local storage we read
the frames from the video and there is a
neat little video reader that is
available and it will be shown in the
other video and frame by frame we read
the video and then pass on to this
function and it will act as if each of
these frames is an image and then it
will do the same object detection on the
entire video so that's in a separate
video just look out for that and
actually the information about that is
provided in the cards the I symbol so
that's the the video object detection in
video that's the separate tutorial all
right so now that we have all the pieces
together this the large cell is where
the whole action takes place so let's
run this and see how it looks so it will
take probably a little while and there
are about three images let's see what it
detects there we go so good so the first
one it has detected a person and that
too with 97 accuracy which is uh I think
pretty good okay and then the next image
it detects
umbrella and chair there are a few other
options but it's not able to detect it
has detected umbrella with 63 percent
accuracy or confidence rather and
chair with the 58 percent again not bad
then let's see the next image so here
these are actually balloons hot air
balloons but the model thinks it is kite
which is uh probably not that bad it
sees there's something in the sky and
therefore probably it thinks it is a
kite and it detects that with 65 percent
confidence okay so that was pretty much
all I wanted to show you in this
particular tutorial about object
detection in images and in this video I
will walk you through the tensorflow
code to perform object detection in a
video so let's get started this part is
basically you're importing all the
libraries we need a lot of these
libraries for example numpy we need
image i o date time and fill and so on
and so forth and of course matplotlib so
we import all these libraries and then
there are a bunch of variables have some
parts for the files and folders so this
is regular stuff let's keep moving then
we import the matplotlib and make it in
line and a few more Imports all right
and then these are some warnings we can
just ignore them so if I run this code
once again it will go away all right and
then here onwards we do the model
preparation now what we're going to do
is we are going to use an existing
neural network model so we are not going
to chain a new one because that really
will take a long time and it needs a lot
of computation resources and so on and
it is really not required there are
already models that have been trained
and in this case it is the SSD with
mobile net that's the model that we are
going to use and this model is trained
to detect objects and it is readily
available as open source so we can
actually use this and if you want to use
other models there are a few more models
available so you click on this link here
and let me just take you there there are
a few more models but we have chosen
this particular one because this is
faster it may not be very accurate but
that is one of the faster models but on
this link you will see a lot of other
models that are readily available these
are trained models some of them would
take a little longer but they may be
more accurate and so on so you can
probably play around with these other
models okay so we will be using that
model so this piece of code this line is
basically importing that model and this
is also known as a frozen model the term
we use is frozen model so we import
download and import that and then we
will actually use that model in our code
right so these two cells we have
downloaded and import the model and then
once it is available locally we will
then load this into our program all
right so we are loading this into memory
and you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to to map the numbers to text as
you may be aware when we actually build
the model and when we run predictions
the model will not give a text the
output of the model is usually a number
so we need to map that to a text so for
example if the network predicts that the
output is 5 we know that 5 means it is
an airplane things like that so this
mapping is done in this next cell all
right so let's keep moving and then we
have a helper code which will basically
load the data or load the images and
transform into lump IRS this is also
used in doing object detection in images
so we are actually going to reuse
because video is nothing but it consists
of frames which in turn are images so we
are going to pretty much use reuse the
same code which we use for doing object
detection in images so this is where the
actual detection starts so here this is
the path for where the images are stored
so this is once again we are reusing the
code which we wrote for detecting
objects in an image so this is the path
where the images were stored and this is
the extension and this was done for
about two or three images so we will
continue to use this and we go down I'll
skip this section so this is the cell
where we are actually loading the video
and converting it into frames and then
using frame by frame we are detecting
the objects in the image so in this code
what we are doing basically is there are
a few lines of code what they do is
basically once they find an object a box
will be drawn around those each of those
objects and the input file the name of
the input video file is traffic it is
the extension is MP4 and we have this
video reader it's a excellent object
which is basically part of this class
called image i o so we can read and
write videos using that and the video
that we are going to use is traffic dot
MP4 you can use any mp4 file but in our
case I picked up video which has like
cars so let me just show you so this is
in this object detection folder I have
this mp4 file I'll just quickly create
this video it's a little slow yeah okay
so here we go this is the video it's a
short one relatively small video so that
for this particular demo and what it
will do is once we run our code it will
detect each of these cars and it will
annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video I
think I have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's check with this
traffic video so let me go back so we
will be reading this frame by frame and
you know actually we will be reading a
video file but then we will be analyzing
it frame by frame and we will be reading
them at 10 frames per second that is the
rate we are mentioning here and
analyzing it and then annotating and
then writing it back so you will see
that we will have a video file named
something like this traffic underscore
annotated and we will see the annotated
video so let's go back and run through
this piece of code and then we will come
back and see the annotated video this
might take a little while so I will
pause the video after running this
particular cell and then come back to
show you the results all right so let's
go ahead and run it so it is running now
and it is also important that at the end
you close the video writer so that it is
similar to file pointer when you open a
file you should also make sure you close
it so that it doesn't hog the resources
so it's very similar at the end of it
the last piece or last line of code
should be video underscore writer Dot
close all right so I'll pause and then
I'll come back okay so I will see you in
a little bit all right so now as you can
see here the processing is done The
Hourglass has disappeared that means the
video has been processed so let's go
back and check the annotated video we'll
go back to my file manager so this was
the original
traffic.mp4 and now you have here
traffic underscore annotated MP4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here it has got each of these
cars getting detected let me pause and
show you the repos here it says car 70
let us allow it to go a little further
it detects something on top what is that
truck okay so I think because of the
board on top it somehow thinks there is
a truck let's play some more and see if
it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us here so
this is a car and it has confidence
level of 69 percent okay this is again a
car all right so basically till the end
it goes and detects each and every car
that is passing by now we can quickly
repeat this process for another video
let me just show you the other video
which is a cat again there is uh this
cat is not really moving or anything but
it is just standing there staring and
moving a little slowly and our
application well our network will detect
that this is a cat and uh even when the
cat moves a little bit in the other
direction it'll continue to detect and
show that it is a cat Okay so yeah so
this is our original video is let's go
ahead and change our code to analyze
this one and see if it detects how
Network detects this cat close this here
we go and go back to my code all we need
to do is change this traffic to get the
extension it will automatically pick up
because it is given here and then it
will run through so very quickly once
again what it is doing is this video
reader video underscore reader has a
neat little feature or interface whereby
you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you are in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell rest of the stuff
Remains the Same so I will run this cell
again it will take a little while so the
r classes come back I will pause and
then come back in a little while all
right so the processing is done let's go
and check the annotated video go here so
we have get annotated dot MP4 let's play
this all right so you can see here it is
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there it looks like I detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here let's see
yes so what is it trying to show here
it's too small not able to see but it is
trying to detect something I think it is
saying it is a car I don't know all
right okay so in this video there's only
pretty much only one object which is a
cat and uh let's wait for some time and
see if it continues to detect it when
the cat turns around and moves as well
just in a little bit that's going to
happen and we will see there we go and
in spite of turning the other way I
think our network is able to detect that
it is a cat so let me freeze and then
show here it is actually still continues
to detect it as a cat all right so
that's pretty much it I think that's the
only object that it detects in this
particular video okay so close this so
that's pretty much it thank you very
much for watching this video hey there
learner simply learn your master's
program in artificial intelligence
created in collaboration with IBM to
learn more about this course you can
find the course Link in the description
box below in this tutorial we will take
the use case of recognizing handwritten
digits this is like a hello world of
deep learning and this is a nice little
MNS database is a nice little database
that has images of handwritten digits
nicely formatted because very often in
deep learning and neural networks we end
up spending a lot of time in preparing
the data for training and with MNS
database we can avoid that you already
have the data in the right format which
can be directly used for training and
mnist also offers a bunch of built-in
utility functions that we can straight
away use and call those functions
without worrying about writing our own
functions and that's one of the reasons
why MNS database is very popular for
training purposes initially when people
want to learn about deep learning and
tensorflow this is the database that is
used and it has a collection of 70
000 handwritten digits and a large part
of them are for training then you have
tests just like in any machine learning
process and then you have validation and
all of them are labeled so you have the
images and their label and these images
they look somewhat like this so they are
handwritten images collected from a lot
of individuals people have these are
samples written by human beings they
have handwritten these numbers these
numbers going from zero to nine so
people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is MNS
database and the way we are going to to
implement this in our tensorflow is we
will feed this data especially the
training data along with the label
information and the data is basically
these images are stored in the form of
the pixel information as we have seen in
one of the previous slides all the
images are nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called softmax
and for Simplicity what we will do is we
will flatten these pixels so instead of
taking them in a two dimensional
arrangement we just flatten them out so
for example it starts from here it's a
28 by 28 so there are 7484 pixels so
pixel number one starts here it goes all
the way up to 28 then 29 starts here and
goes up to 56 and so on and the pixel
number 784 is here so we take all these
pixels flatten them out and feed them
like one single line into our neural
network and this is a what is known as a
soft Max layer what it does is once it
is trained it will be able to identify
what digit this is so there are in this
output layer there are 10 neurons each
signifying a digit and at any given
point of time when you feed an image
only one of these 10 neurons gets
activated
so for example if this is strained
properly and if you feed a number nine
like this then this particular neuron
gets activated so you get an output from
this neuron let me just use a pen or a
laser to show you here okay so you're
feeding the number nine let's say this
has been trained and now if you're
feeding a number nine this will get
activated now let's say you feed one to
the trained Network then this neuron
will get activated if you feed two this
neuron will get activated and so on I
hope you get the idea so this is one
type of a neural network or an
activation function known as soft Max
layer so that's what we will be using
here this is one of the simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding so this is
how the code would look we will go into
our lab environment in the cloud and we
will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
let me run you through briefly here and
then we will go into the jupyter
notebook where the actual code is and we
will run that as well so as a first step
first of all we are using python here
and that's why the syntax of the
language is Python and the first step is
to import the tensorflow library so and
we do this by using this line of code
saying import tensorflow as TF TF is
just for convenience so you can name
give any name and once you do this TF is
tensorflow is available as an object in
the name of TF and then you can run its
methods and accesses its attributes and
so on and so forth and mnis database is
actually an integral part of tensorflow
and that's again another reason why we
as a first step we always use this
example mnist database example so you
just simply import mnist database as
well using this line of code and and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
let me just use n to show what exactly
it is so when you do this one hot true
what happens is each label is stored in
the form of an array of 10 digits and
let's say the number is 8 okay so in
this case all the remaining values there
will be a bunch of zeros so this is like
array at position zero this is at
position one position two and so on and
so forth let's say this is position
seven then this is position eight that
will be 1 because our input is 8 and
again position 9 will be zero okay so
one hot encoding this one hot encoding
true will kind of load the data and such
a way that the labels are in such a way
that only one of the digits has a value
of one and that indicates So based on
which digit is one we know what is the
label so in this case the eighth
position is one therefore we know this
sample data the value is eight similarly
if you have a 2 here let's say then the
labeled information will be somewhat
like this so you have your labels so you
have this as 0 the 0th position the
first position is also zero the second
position is one because this indicates
number two and then you have third as
zero and so on okay so that is the
significance of this one hot true all
right and then we can check how the data
is looking by displaying the the data
and as I mentioned earlier this is
pretty much in the form of digital form
like numbers so all these are like pixel
values so you will not release see an
image in this format but there is a way
to visualize that image I will show you
in a bit and this tells you how many
images are there in each set so they're
training there are 55 000 images in
training and in the test set there are
10 000 and then validation there are
5000. so all together there are 70 000
images all right so let's move on and we
can view the actual image by using the
matplot flip library and this is how you
can view this is the code for viewing
the images and you can view them in
color or you can view them in grayscale
so the cmap is what tells in what way we
want to view it and what are the maximum
values and the minimum values of the
pixel value so these are the Max and
minimum value so of the pixel values so
maximum is one because this is a scaled
value so one main means it is white and
zero means it is black and in between is
it can be anywhere in between black and
white and the way to train the model
that is a certain way in which you write
your tensorflow code and the first step
is to create some placeholders and then
you create a model in this case we will
use the softmax model one of the
simplest ones and placeholders are
primarily to get the data from outside
into the neural network so this is a
very common mechanism that is used and
then of course you will have variables
which are your remember these are your
weights and biases so for in our case
there are 10 neurons and each neuron
actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
700 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are this is a matrix of
784 values for each of the neurons and
so it is like a 10 by 784 Matrix because
there are 10 neurons and similarly there
are biases now remember I mentioned
biases only one per neuron so it is not
one per input unlike the weights so
therefore there are only 10 biases
because there are only 10 neurons in
this case so that is what we are
creating a variable for biases so this
is something little new in tensorflow
you will see unlike our regular
programming languages where everything
is a variable here the variables can be
of three different types you have
placeholders which are primarily used
for feeding data you have variables
which can change during the course of
computation and then a third type which
is not shown here are constant so these
are like fixed numbers all right so in a
regular programming language you may
have everything has variables or at the
most variables and constants but in
tensorflow you have three different
types placeholders variables and
constants and then you create what is
known as a graph so tensorflow
programming consists of graphs and
tensors as I mentioned earlier so this
can be considered ultimately as a tensor
and then the graph tells how to execute
the whole implementation so that the
execution is stored in the form of for
graph and in this case what we are doing
is we are doing a multiplication TF you
remember this TF was created as a
tensorflow object here one more level
one more so TF is available here now
tensorflow has what is known as a matrix
multiplication or maximal function so
that is what is being used here in this
case so we are using the matrix
multiplication of tensorflow so that you
multiply your input values x with W
right this is what we were doing x w
plus b you're just adding B and this is
in very similar to one of the earlier
slides where we saw Sigma x i w i so
that's what we are doing here matrix
multiplication is multiplying all the
input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to Define what is our loss function and
what is our Optimizer so in this case is
we again use the tensorflows apis so TF
dot NN softmax cross entropy with logits
is the API that we will use and reduce
mean is what is like the mechanism
whereby which says that you reduce the
error and Optimizer for doing direction
of the error what Optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
Optimizer we discussed about this in
couple of slides earlier and for that
you need to specify the learning rate
you remember we saw that there was a
slide somewhat like this and then you
define what should be the learning rate
how fast you need to come down that is
the learning rate and this again needs
to be tested and tried and to find out
the optimum level of this learning rate
it shouldn't be very high in which case
it will not converge or shouldn't be
very low because it will in that case it
will take very long so you define the
optimizer and then you call the method
minimize for that Optimizer and that
will kick start the training process and
so far we've been creating the graph and
in order to actually execute that graph
we create what is known as a session and
then we run that session and once the
training is completed we specify how
many times how many iterations we wanted
to run so for example in this case we
are saying Thousand Steps so that is a
exit strategy in a way so you specify
the exit condition so training will run
for thousand iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques shown here
so let us get into the code quickly and
see how it works so this is our Cloud
environment now you can install
tensorflow on your local machine as well
I'm showing this demo on our existing
Cloud but you can also install
tensorflow on your local machine and
there is a separate video on how to set
up your tensorflow environment you can
watch that if you want to install your
local environment or you can go for
other any cloud service like for example
Google Cloud Amazon or Cloud Labs any of
these you can use and run and try the
code okay so it has got started
with a login
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial code
and this is our tensorflow environment
and so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
Code walkthrough uh in the slides as
well now you will see the actual code in
action so the first thing we need to do
is import tensorflow and then we will
import the data and we need to adjust
the data in such a way that the
one hot is encoding is set to True one
hot encoding right as I explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately and if we
just check what is the type of the data
so you can see that this is a data sets
python data sets and if we
check the number of images the way it
looks so this is how it looks it is an
array of type float32
similarly
the number if you want to see what is
the number of
cleaning images there are 55 000 and
there are test images 10 000 and then
validation images five thousand now
let's take a quick look at the data
itself visualization so we will use
um matplotlib for this
and if we take a look at the shape now
shape gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or or the arrays if you will so
in this case the training data set if we
see the size of the training data set
using the method shape it says there are
55 000 and 50 000 by 784 so remember the
784 is nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into
28 so that is equal to 784 so that's
what it is showing now we can take just
one image and just see what is the the
first image and see what is the shape so
again size obviously it is only 784.
similarly you can look at the image
itself the data of the first image
itself so this is how it it shows a
large part of it will probably be zeros
because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is blank so that's why you
will mostly see Zero say that it is
black or white but then there are these
values are so the values are actually
they are scaled so their values are
between 0 and 1. okay so this is what
you're seeing so certain locations there
are some values and then other locations
there are zeros
so that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image if you
want to view it this is how you view it
so you create like do this reshape and
matplotlab has this feature to show you
these images so we will actually use the
function called IM show and then if you
pass this parameters appropriately you
will be able to see the different images
now I can change the values in this
position so which image we are looking
at right so we can say
if I want to see what is there in maybe
right so
5000 has three similarly you can just
say five what is in five
five as eight what is in 50.
again H so basically by the way if
you're wondering uh how I'm executing
this code shift enter in case you're not
familiar with Jupiter notebooks shift
enter is how you execute each cell
individual cell and if you want to
execute the entire program you can go
here and say run all
so that is how
this score gets executed and here again
we can check what is the maximum value
and what is the minimum value of this
pixel values as I mentioned this is it
is scaled so therefore it is between the
value slide between 1 and 0. now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create one
placeholder and we create two variables
which is for the weights and biases
these two variables are actually
matrices so each variable has 784 by 10
chill values okay so one for this 10 is
for each neuron there are 10 neurons and
784 is for the pixel values inputs that
are given which is 28 into 28. and the
biases as I mentioned one for each
neuron so there will be 10 biases they
are stored in a variable by the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of X into W and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize the
error so let me just execute I think
this code is executed then we Define
what is our the Y value is basically the
label value so this is another
placeholder we had X as one placeholder
and white underscore true as a second
placeholder and this will have values in
the form of uh 10 digit 10 digit arrays
and since we set one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the label for that particular
number all right then we have cross
entropy which is nothing but the loss
loss function and we have the optimizer
we have chosen gradient descent as our
Optimizer that the training process
itself so the training process is
nothing but to minimize the cross
entropy which is again nothing but the
loss function
so we Define all of this in the form of
a graph so the up to here remember what
we have done is we have not exactly
executed any tensorflow code till now we
are just preparing the graph the
execution plan that's how the tensorflow
code works so the whole structure and
format of this code will be completely
different from how we normally do
programming so even with people with
programming experience may find this a
little difficult to understand it and it
needs quite a bit of practice so you may
want to view this video also maybe a
couple of times to understand this flow
because the way tensorflow programming
is done is slightly different from the
normal programming some of you who let's
say have done maybe spark programming to
some extent will be able to easily
understand this but even in spark the
the programming the code it's self is
pretty straightforward behind the scenes
the execution happens slightly
differently but in tensorflow even the
code has to be written in a completely
different way so the code doesn't get
executed in the same way as you have
written so that that's something you
need to understand and a little bit of
practices needed for this so so far what
we have done up to here is creating the
variables and feeding the variables and
or rather not feeding but setting up the
variables and the graph that's all
defining maybe the what kind of a
network you want to use for example we
want to use a soft Max and so on so you
have created the variables how to load
the data loaded the data viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tensorflow now
the next step is the execution in
tensorflow so the first step for doing
any execution in 10 the flow is to
initialize the variables so anytime you
have any variables defined in your code
you have to run this piece of code
always so you need to basically create
what is known as a node for initializing
so this is a node you still are not yet
executing anything here you just created
a node for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code in tensorflow and in
order to execute the code what you will
need is a session tensorflow session so
TF dot session will give you a session
and there are a couple of different ways
in which you can do this but one of the
most common methods of doing this is
with what is known as a with Loop so you
have a width TF dot session as says and
with the colon here and this is like a
block starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and this session is valid till this
block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this with block this
is known as a width block so with TF dot
session as says you say CIS dot run in
it now says Dot one will execute a node
that is specified here so for example
here we are saying SAS dot run SAS is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying TF dot
session so an instance of the session
gets created and we are calling that SAS
and then we run
a node within that one of the nodes in
the graph so one of the nodes here is
init so we say run that particular node
and that is when the initialization of
the variables happens now what this does
is if you have any variables in your
code in our case we have W is a variable
and B is a variable so any variables
that we created you have to run this
code you have to run the initialization
of these variables otherwise you will
get an error
that is the that's what this is doing
then we within this with block we
specify a for Loop and we are saying we
want the system to iterate for thousand
steps and perform the training
that's what this for Loop does run
training for 1000 iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching the data or these images
remember there are about 50 000 images
but it cannot get all the images in one
shot because it will take up a lot of
memory and performance issues will be
there so this is a very common way of
Performing deep learning training you
always do in batches so we have maybe 50
000 images but you always do it in
batches of 100 or maybe 500 depending on
the size of your system and so on and so
forth so in this case we are saying okay
get me 100 images at a time and get me
only the training images remember we use
only the training data for training
purpose and then we use test data for
test purpose you must be familiar with
machine learning so you must be aware of
this but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and You observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next batch
right so this is the advantage of using
MNS database because they have provided
some very nice helper functions which
are readily available otherwise this
activity itself we would have had to
write a piece of code to fetch this data
in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using MNS database and that's why we
use this for the initial learning phase
okay so when we say fetch what it will
do is it will fetch the images into X
and the labels into Y and then you use
this batch of 100 images and you run the
cleaning so SAS dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the new
Network and thereby all the W's and B's
get updated till it reaches thousand
iterations in this case the exit
criteria is thousand but you can also
specify probably accuracy rate or
something like that for the as an exit
criteria so here it is it just says that
okay this particular image was wrongly
predicted so you need to update your
weights and biases that's the feedback
given to each neuron and that is run for
1000 iterations and typically by the end
of this thousand iterations the model
would have learned to recognize these
handwritten images obviously it will not
be 100 accurate okay so once that is
done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done you then
test the accuracy of these models by
using the test data set right so this is
what we are trying to do here the code
may appear a little complicated because
if you're seeing this for the first time
you need to understand uh the various
methods of tensorflow and so on but it
is basically comparing the output with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you are trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not TF dot equal right and
how many of them are correct and so on
and so forth and based on that the
accuracy is calculated as well so this
is the accuracy and that is what we are
trying to see how accurate the model is
in predicting these numbers or these
digits okay so let us run this this
entire thing is in one cell so we will
have to just run it in one shot it may
take a little while let us see and uh
not bad so it has finished the thousand
iterations and what we see here as an
output is the accuracy so we see that
the accuracy of this model is around 91
percent okay now which is pretty good
for such a short exercise within such a
short time we got 90 percent accuracy
however in real life this is probably
not sufficient so there are other ways
in to increase the accuracy we will see
probably in some of the later tutorials
how to improve this accuracy how to
change maybe the hyper parameters like
number of neurons or number of layers
and so on and so forth and so that this
accuracy can be increased Beyond 90
percent
in artificial Intel is created in
collaboration with IBM to learn more
about this course you can find the
course Link in the description box below
we're going to dive right into what is
Karas we'll also go all the way through
this into a couple of tutorials because
that's where you really learn a lot is
when you roll up your sleeves so think
about what is Karas cross is a high
level deep learning API written in
Python for easy implementation of neural
networks it uses deep learning
Frameworks such as tensorflow Pi torch
Etc is back in to make computation
faster
and this is really nice because as a
programmer there is so much stuff out
there and it's evolving so fast it can
get confusing and having some kind of
high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different neural networks is
really powerful it's really powerful to
to have something out really quick and
also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going
so cross works by using complex deep
learning Frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch ml played Etc as a back-end for
fast computation while providing a
user-friendly and easy to learn
front-end and you can see here we have
the cross API specifications and under
that you'd have like TF Karas for
tensorflow thano cross and so on and
then you have your tensorflow workflow
that this is all sitting on top of
and this is like I said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensorflow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to
um dig as deeply into the heavy and
stuff while still having a very robust
package you can get up and running
rather quickly and it doesn't distract
from the processing time because all the
heavy lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow this is the organization on
top of it so the working principle of
Karas
uh the working principle of Karas is
cross uses computational graphs to
express and evaluate mathematical
expressions
you can see here we put them in blue
they have the expression expressing
complex problems as a combination of
simple mathematical operators where we
have like the percentage or in this case
in Python that's usually your left your
remainder or multiplication you might
have the operator of x to the power of
0.3 and it uses useful for calculating
derivatives by using back propagation so
if we're doing with neural networks we
send the error back up to figure out how
to change it this makes it really easy
to do that without really having not
banging your head and having to hand
write everything it's easier to
implement distributed computation and
for solving complex problems specify
input and outputs and make sure all
nodes are connected
and so this is really nice as you come
in through is that as your layers are
going in there you can get some very
complicated uh different setups nowadays
which we'll look at in just a second
and this just makes it really easy to
start spinning this stuff up and trying
out the different models
so we look at Cross models uh cross
model we have a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like the SK learn with their neural
networks and propagation and any of
these setups this should look familiar
you should have your input layer it goes
into your layer one layer two and then
to the output layer
and it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential and this
is the actual code you can see how easy
it is we have a layer that's dense your
layer one as an activation they're using
the relu in this particular example and
then you have your name layer one layer
dense relu name Layer Two and so forth
and they just feed right into each other
so it's really easy just to stack them
as you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model and
this is really where things are at this
is new make sure you update your cross
or you'll find yourself running this
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release
and he uses multi-input and multi-output
model the complex model which Forks into
two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your cross input shape
equals 32 by 32 by 3.
you have your dense layers dense 64
activation relu and this should look
similar to what you already saw before
but if you look at the graph on the
right it's going to be a lot easier to
see what's going on you have two
different inputs and one way you could
think of this is maybe one of those is a
small image and one of those is a full
sized image and that feedback goes into
you might feed both of them into one
node because it's looking for one thing
and then only into one node for the
other one and so you can start to get
kind of an idea that there's a lot of
use for this kind of split and this kind
of setup we have multiple information
coming in but the information is very
different even though it overlaps and
you don't want it to send it through the
same neural network and they're finding
that this trains faster and is also has
a better result depending on how you
split the date up and how you Fork the
models coming down
and so in here we do have the two
complex models coming in we have our
image inputs which is a 32 by 32 by
three or three channels or four if
you're having an alpha channel uh you
have your dense your layers dense is 64
activation using the ray Lou very common
x equals dense inputs X layers dense x64
activation equals relu x outputs equals
layers dense 10 X model equals cross
model inputs equals inputs outputs
equals outputs name equals minced model
uh so we add a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up to have the input
go into different areas
if you're already looking across you
probably already have this answer what
are neural networks but it's always good
to get on the same page and for those
people who don't fully understand neural
networks to dive into them a little bit
or do a quick overview
oh networks are deep learning algorithms
modeled after the human brain they use
multiple neurons which are mathematical
operations to break down and solve
complex mathical problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer
and you can see here we have the really
standard graph input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer one of the
biggest parts of any data processing is
your data pre-processing
so we always have to touch base on that
with a neural network like many of these
models they're kind of uh when you first
start using them they're like a black
box you put your data in
you train it and you test it and see how
good it was
and you have to pre-process that data
because bad data in is bad outputs so in
data pre-processing we will create our
own data examples set with Karas the
data consists of a clinical trial
conducted on 2100 patients ranging from
ages 13 to 100 with a the patients under
65 and the other half over 65 years of
age
we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects due to
their age and you can think of this in
today's world with covid uh what's going
to happen on there and we're going to go
ahead and do an example of that in our
live Hands-On like I said most of this
you really need to have Hands-On to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and open that up and
open up a Jupiter notebook for doing the
python code in
now if you're not familiar with those
you can use pretty much any of your
setups I just like those for doing demos
and showing people especially
shareholders it really helps because
it's a nice visual so let me go and flip
over to our anacond and the Anaconda has
a lot of cool two tools they just added
data lore and IBM Watson Studio clad
into the Anaconda framework but we'll be
in the Jupiter lab or Jupiter notebook
I'm going to do Jupiter notebook for
this because I use the lab for like
large projects with multiple pieces it
has multiple tabs where the notebook
will work fine for what we're doing
and this opens up in our browser window
because that's how Jupiter dope so
Jupiter notebook is set to run
it will go under new create a new Python
3 and it creates an Untitled python
we'll go ahead and give this a title and
we'll just call this uh cross
tutorial
and let's change that to Capital there
we go I'm going to just rename that and
the first thing we want to go ahead and
do is uh
get some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy do
some random number generation
I mentioned SK learn or your site kit if
you're installing sklearn the sklearn
stuff it's a site kit you want to look
up
that should be a tool of anybody who is
doing data science if you're not if
you're not familiar with the sklearn
toolkit it's huge but there's so many
things in there that we always go back
to and we want to go ahead and create
some train labels and train samples for
training our data
and then just a note of what we're we're
actually doing in here let me go ahead
and change this this is kind of a fun
thing you can do we can change the code
to markdown
and then markdown code is nice for doing
examples once you've already built this
our example data we're going to do
experimental
there we go experimental drug was tested
on 2100 individuals between 13 to 100
years of age half the participants are
under 65 and 95 percent of participants
are under 65. experience no side effects
well 95 percent of participants over 65
experience side effects
so that's kind of where we're starting
at and this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more complicated
information
uh and so we want to go ahead and
generate
our setup so we want to do for I and
range and we want to go ahead and create
if you look here we have random integers
train the labels of pen so we're just
creating some random data
and let me go ahead and just run that
and so once we've created our random
data and if you if I mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from Simply learning they'll send you a
copy of this or you can zoom in on the
video and see how we went ahead and did
our train samples append
um
and we're just using this I do this kind
of stuff all the time I was running a
thing on uh that had to do with errors
following a bell-shaped curve on a
standard distribution error and so what
do I do I generate the data on a
standard distribution area to see what
it looks like and how my code processes
it since that was the Baseline I was
looking for in this we're just doing uh
generating random data for our setup
button here
and we could actually go in
print some of the data up let's just do
this print
we'll do train
samples and we'll just do the first five
pieces of data in there to see what that
looks like and you can see the first
five pieces of data in our train samples
is 49 85 41 68 19 just random numbers
generated in there that's all that is
and we generated significantly more than
that
let's see 50 up here 1000 yeah so
there's one thousand here 1 000 numbers
we generated and we could also if we
wanted to find that out we could do a
quick print the links of it
so or you could do a shape kind of thing
and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo setup in there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels oh that was our train labels
we also did samples didn't we
uh so we could also print
do the same thing
oh labels
and let's change this to
labels
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one zero one zero one zero I
guess that's if they have symptoms or
not one symptoms zero none and so we
want to go ahead and take our trade
labels and we'll convert it into a numpy
array and the same thing with our
samples
and let's go ahead and run that
and we also Shuffle this is just a neat
feature you can do in numpy right here
put my drawing thing on which I didn't
have on earlier I can take the data and
I can Shuffle it uh so we have our so
it's it just randomizes it that's all
that's doing
um we've already randomized it so it's
kind of an Overkill it's not really
necessary
but if you're doing a larger package
where the data is coming in and a lot of
times it's organized somehow and you
want to randomize it just to make sure
that that you know the input doesn't
follow a certain pattern
that might create a bias in your model
and we go ahead and create a scalar the
scalar range minimum Max scalar feature
range zero to one
uh then we go ahead and scale the scaled
train samples so we're going to go ahead
and fit and transform the data so it's
nice and scaled and that is the age so
you can see up here we have 49 85 41.
we're just moving that so it's going to
be between 0 and 1. and so this is true
with any of your neural networks
you really want to convert the data to
zero and one otherwise you create a bias
so if you have like a hundred creates a
bias versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated
if you actually start multiplying stuff
because a lot of multiplication addition
going on in there that higher end value
will eventually multiply down and it
will have a huge bias as to how the
model fits it and then it will not fit
as well and then one of the fun things
we can do in jupyter Notebook is that if
you have a variable you're not doing
anything with it it's the last one on
the line it will automatically print
and we're just going to look at the
first five samples on here and so it's
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go
0.9195 0.791 so everything's between 0
and 1.
and that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good it really
helps a lot to do these kind of print
UPS halfway through you never know
what's going to go on there
I don't know how many times I've gotten
down and found out that the data sent to
me that I thought was scaled was not
and then I have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensorflow and cross
tensorflow
if you don't know the history of
it helps to jump into we'll just use
Wikipedia
careful don't quote Wikipedia on these
things because you get in trouble uh
but it's a good place to start back in
2011 Google brain built disbelief as a
proprietary machine learning setup
tensorflow became the open source for it
so tensorflow is a Google product and
then it became
open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the de factos when it
comes for neural networks as far as
where we're at so when you see the
tensorflow setup
it's got like a huge following there are
some other setups like the side kit
under the SK learn has their own little
neural network but the tensorflow is the
most robust one out there right now and
cross sitting on top of it makes it a
very powerful tool so we can leverage
both the cross easiness in which we can
build a sequential setup on top of
tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensorflow and then
we have the rest of this is all Karas
here from number two down uh we're going
to import from tensorflow the cross
connection and then you have your
tensorflow across models import
sequential it's a specific kind of model
we'll look at that in just a second if
you remember
from the files that means it goes from
one layer to the next layer to the next
layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that
uh and then we have from tensorflow
across layers we're going to import our
activation and our dense layer
and we have our Optimizer atom this is a
big thing to be aware of how you
optimize your data when you first do it
atoms as good as any atom is usually
there's a number of Optimizer out there
there's about there's a couple main ones
but atom is usually assigned to bigger
data
it works fine usually the lower data
does it just fine but atom is probably
the mostly used but there are some more
out there and depending on what you're
doing with your layers your different
layers might have different activations
on them and then finally down here
you'll see our setup where we want to go
ahead and use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics for categorical cross
entropy so we can see how everything
performs when we're done that's all that
is a lot of times you'll see us go back
and forth between tensorflow and then
site kit has a lot of really good
metrics also for measuring these things
again it's the end of the day you know
at the end of the story how good does
your model do and we'll go ahead and
load all that and then comes the fun
part I actually like to spend hours
messing with these things
and four lines of code you're like oh
you're gonna spend hours on four lines
of code
no we don't spend hours on four lines of
code that's not what we're talking about
when I say spend hours on four lines of
code uh what we have here let me explain
that in just a second we have a model
and it's a sequential model if you
remember correctly we mentioned the
sequential up here where it goes from
one layer to the next
and our first layer is going to be your
input
it's going to be what they call dense
which is uh usually it's just dense and
then you have your input and your
activation
how many units are coming in we have 16
what's the shape What's the activation
and this is where it gets interesting
because we have in here uh relu
on two of these and softmax activation
on one of these
there are so many different options for
what these mean and how they function
how does the relu how does the softmax
function
and they do a lot of different things
we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different activations
and just some of it is just almost like
you're playing with it
like an artist you start getting a fill
for like a inverse tangent activation or
the 10h activation
takes up a huge processing amount so you
don't see it a lot yet it comes up with
a better solution especially when you're
doing when you're analyzing Word
documents and you're tokenizing the
words and so you'll see this shift from
one to the other because you're both
trying to build a better model and if
you're working on a huge data set
it'll crash the system it'll just take
too long to process
and then you see things like soft Max
softmax
generates an interesting
setup
where a lot of these when you talk about
Ray Lewis oops let me do this uh regular
there we go relu has a setup where if
it's less than zero it's zero and then
it goes up and then you might have what
they call Lazy setup where it has a
slight negative to it so that the errors
can translate better same thing with
softmax it has a slight laziness to it
so that errors translate better all
these little details
make a huge difference on your model so
one of the really cool things about data
science that I like is you build your
what they call you build to fail and
it's an interesting design setup oops I
forgot the end of my code here
the concept to build a fail is you want
the model as a whole to work so you can
test your model out
so that you can do uh
you can get to the end and you can do
your let's see where was it overshot
down here you can test your test out the
quality of your setup on there and
see where did I do my tensorflow oh here
we go I did it was right above me there
we go we started doing your cross
entropy and stuff like that is you need
a full functional set of code so that
when you run it
you can then test your model out and say
hey it's either this model works better
than this model and this is why and then
you can start swapping in these models
and so when I say I spend a huge amount
of time on pre-processing data it's
probably 80 of your programming time
well between those two it's like 80 20.
you'll spend a lot of time on the models
once you get the model down once you get
the whole code and the flow down set
depending on your data your models get
more and more robust as you start
experimenting with different inputs
different data streams and all kinds of
things and we can do a simple model
summary here
's our sequential here's our layer our
output our parameter
this is one of the nice things about
cross is you just you can see right here
here's our sequential one model boom
boom boom boom everything's set and
clear and easy to read so once we have
our model built uh the next thing we're
going to want to do is we're going to go
ahead and train that model
and so the next step is of course model
training and when we come in here this a
lot of times it's just paired with the
model because it's so straightforward
it's nice to print out the model setup
so you can have a tracking
but here's our model
the keyword in Cross is compile
Optimizer atom learning rate another
term right there that we're just
skipping right over that really becomes
the meat of
the setup is your learning rate so
whoops I forgot that I had an arrow but
I'll just underline it
a lot of times the learning rate set to
0.0 uh set to 0.01 depending on what
you're doing this learning rate can
overfit and underfit so you'd want to
look up I know we have a number of
tutorials out on overfitting and
underfinning that are really worth
reading once you get to that point in
understanding and we have our loss
sparse categorical cross entropy so this
is going to tell Karas how far to go
until it stops
and then we're looking for metrics of
accuracy so we'll go ahead and run that
and now that we've compiled our model
we want to go ahead and run it fit it so
here's our model fit we have our scaled
to train samples
our train labels our validation split in
this case we're going to use 10 percent
of the data for validation
batch size another number you kind of
play with not a huge difference as far
as how it works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit most of the time though a
batch size is between 10 to 100
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we want to go ahead
and Shuffle it we're going to go through
30 epics
and put a verbose of two and let me just
go ahead and run this and you can see
right here here's our epic here's our
training
here's our loss now if you remember
correctly up here we set the loss let's
see where was it
compiled our data
there we go loss so it's looking at the
sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
much how much does the error go down is
the best way to look at that and you can
see here the lower the number the better
it just keeps going down and vice versa
accuracy we want let's see where's my
accuracy
value accuracy at the end and you can
see 0.619 0.69 0.74 it's going up we
want the accuracy would be ideal if it
made it all the way to one but we also
the loss is more important because it's
a balance you can have 100 accuracy and
your model doesn't work because it's
overfitted
again you will look up overfitting and
under fitting models
and we went ahead and went through 30
epics it's always fun to kind of watch
your code going
to be honest I usually uh the first time
I run it I'm like oh that's cool I get
to see what it does and after the second
time of running it I'm like I like to
just not see that and you can request
those of course in your code repress the
warnings in the printing
and so the next step is going to be
building a test set and predicting it
now so here we go we want to go ahead
and build our test set and we have just
like we did our training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set up but we'll go ahead and do
a separate set on here
and this is just what we did above now
there's no difference as far as
the randomness that we're using to build
this set on here the only difference is
that
we are already did our scalar up here
well it doesn't matter because the the
data is going to be across the same
thing but this should just be just
transformed down here instead of fit
transform because you don't want to
refit your data on your testing data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data easy to mistake to make
especially on an example like this where
we're not doing
you know we're randomizing the data
anyway so it doesn't matter too much
because we're not expecting something
weird
and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model is we take our model we
predict and we're going to do here's our
X scale data batch size 10 verbose and
now we have our predictions in here and
we could go ahead and do a
I will print
predictions
and then I guess I could just put down
predictions in five so we can look at
the first five of the predictions
and what we have here is we have our age
and the prediction on this age versus
what we think it's going to be but what
we think is going to they're going to
have symptoms or not and the first thing
we notice is it's hard to read because
we really want a yes no answer so we'll
go ahead and just round off the
predictions
using the ARG Max the numpy ARG Max for
prediction so it just goes to a zero one
and if you remember this is a Jupiter
notebook so I don't have to put the
print I can just put in rounded
predictions and we'll just do the first
five and you can see here zero one zero
zero zero so that's what the predictions
are that we have coming out of this is
no symptoms symptoms no symptoms
symptoms no symptoms
as we were talking about at the
beginning we want to go ahead and take a
look at this there we go confusion
matrixes for accuracy check
most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the site kit the SK learn metrics site
kit being where that comes from
import confusion Matrix some iteration
tools and of course a nice matplot
Library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to um
I have a nice graph to look at pictures
worth a thousand words
and then we'll go ahead and call it CM
for confusion Matrix y true equals test
labels y predict rounded predictions
and we'll go ahead and load in our cm
and I'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting going over the different
plotting code
you can spend like whole we have whole
tutorials on how to do your different
plotting on there but we do have here is
we're going to do a plot confusion
Matrix there's our CM our classes
normalize false title confusion Matrix
cmap is going to be in blues
and you can see here we have uh to the
nearest cmap titles all the different
pieces whether you put tick marks or not
the marks the classes the color bar
so a lot of different information on
here as far as how we're doing the
printing of the of the confusion Matrix
you can also just dump the confusion
Matrix into a Seaborn and real quick get
an output it's worth knowing how to do
all this uh when you're doing a
presentation to the shareholders you
don't want to do this on the Fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice like our guys in the back
did and let's go ahead and do this we
forgot to put together our CM plot
labels
we'll go ahead and run that
and then we'll go ahead and call the
little the definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
Matrix that's our the little script we
just wrote and we're going to dump our
data into it so our confusion Matrix our
classes title confusion Matrix and let's
just go ahead and run that
and you can see here we have our basic
setup no side effects 195 had side
effects 200 no side effects that had
side effects so we predicted the 10 of
them who actually had side effects and
that's pretty good I mean I don't know
about you but you know that's five
percent error on this and this is
because there's 200 here that's where I
get five percent is uh divide these both
by by two and you get five out of a
hundred uh you can do the same kind of
math up here not as quick on the Fly
because it's 15 and 195. not an easily
rounded number but you can see here
where they have 15 people
who predicted to have no uh
with the no side effects but had side
effects
kind of setup on there and these
confusion Matrix are so important at the
end of the day this is really where
where you show whatever you're working
on comes up and you can actually show
them hey this is how good we are or not
how messed up it is
so this was a uh I spent a lot of time
on some of the parts uh but you can see
here is really simple uh we did the
random generation of data but when we
actually built the model coming up here
here's our model summary
and we just have the layers on here that
we built with our model on this and then
we went ahead and trained it and ran the
prediction
now we can get a lot more complicated uh
let me flip back on over here because
we're going to do another demo so that
was our basic introduction to it we
talked about the uh oops here we go okay
so implementing a neural network with
Karas after creating our samples and
labels we need to create our cross
neural network model we will be working
with a sequential model which has three
layers and this is what we did we had
our input layer our hidden layers and
our output layers and you can see the
input layer coming in was the age Factor
we had our hidden layer and then we had
the output are you going to have
symptoms or not so we're going to go
ahead and go with something a little bit
more complicated
training our model is a two-step process
we first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set so we
have compiling compiling converts the
code into a form of understandable by
machine
we use the atom in the last example a
gradient descent algorithm to optimize a
model and then we trained our model
which means it let it learn on training
data
and I actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let me go back here
[Music]
here's our model that we created
summarized uh we come down here and we
compile it
so it tells it hey we're ready to build
this model and use it and then we train
it this is the part where we go ahead
and fit our model and and put that
information in here and it goes through
the training on there and of course we
scaled the data which was really
important to do and then you saw we did
the creating a confusion Matrix with
Karas as we are performing
classifications on our data we need a
confusion Matrix to check the results a
confusion Matrix breaks down the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the accuracy
and so you can see here this is what we
did with the true positive false
positive true negative false negative
and that is what we went over let me
just scroll down here
on the end we printed it out and you see
we have a nice printout of our confusion
Matrix with the true positive false
positive false negative true negative
and so the blue ones we want those to be
the biggest numbers because those are
the better side and then we have our
false predictions on here as far as this
one so I had no side effects but we
predicted
let's see no side effects predicting
side effects and vice versa if getting
your learning started it's half the
battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now uh saving and loading models with
Karas we're going to dive into a more
complicated demo
uh and you're gonna say oh that was a
lot of complication before well if you
broke it down we randomized some data we
created the cross setup we compiled it
we trained it we predicted and we ran
our Matrix
uh so we're going to dive into something
a lot a little bit more fun is we're
going to do a face mask detection with
Karas so we're going to build a cross
model to check if a person is wearing a
mask or not in real time and this might
be important if you're at the front of a
store this is something today which is
um
might be very useful as far as some of
our you know making sure people are safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
no mask and let's start with a little
bit on the data
and so in my data I have with a mask you
can see they just have a number of
images showing the people in masks and
again if you want some of this
information contact simply learn and
they can send you some of the
information as far as people with and
without masks so you can try it on your
own and this is just such a wonderful
example of this setup on here
so before I dive into the mass detection
talk about being in the current with
covid and seeing if people are wearing
masks this particular example I had to
go ahead and update to a python 3.8
version it might run in a three seven
I'm not sure I haven't I kind of skipped
three seven and installed three eight
so I'll be running in a three Python 3 8
and then you also want to make sure your
tensorflow is up to date because the
um they're called functional
uh layers with that's where they split
if you remember correctly from back oh
let's take a look at this remember from
here the functional model in a
functional layer allows us to feed in
the different layers into different you
know different nodes into different
layers and split them a very powerful
tool very popular right now in the edge
of where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so I've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and go through
our next example which includes multiple
layers
programming it to recognize whether
someone wears a mask or not and then
saving that model so we can use it in
real time so we're actually almost a
full
end-to-end development of a product here
of course this is a very simplified
version and it'd be a lot more to it
you'd also have to do like recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this
so let's go ahead and jump into that
code and we'll open up a new Python 3
oops python3
it's working on it there we go
um and then we want to go ahead and
train our mask we'll just call this
train mask
and we want to go ahead and train mask
and save it
uh so it's it's uh it's save mask train
mask detection not to be confused with
masking data a little bit different
we're actually talking about our
physical mask on your face
and then from the cross standpoint we
got a lot of imports to do here
and I'm not going to dig too deep on the
Imports we're just going to go ahead and
notice a few of them so we have in here
alt D there we go
have something to draw with a little bit
here we have our image processing
and the image processing right here let
me underline that
deals with how do we bring images in
because most images are like a a square
grid and then each value in there has
three values for the three different
colors cross and tensorflow do a really
good job of working with that so you
don't have to do all the heavy listening
and figuring out what's going to go on
uh and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2D this again is
how do we deal with the images and
pulling them uh dropout's a cool thing
worth looking up if you haven't when as
you get more and more into Karas and
tensorflow it'll Auto drop out certain
nodes that way you'll get a better
um the notes just kind of die and they
find that they actually create more of a
bias and a help and they also add
processing time so they remove them
and then we have our flattened that's
where you take that huge array with the
three different colors and you find a
way to flatten it so it's just a
one-dimensional array instead of a two
by two by three
dense input we did that in the other one
so that should look a little familiar
oops there we go our input our model
again these are things we had on the
last one here's our Optimizer with our
atom
we have some pre-processing on the input
that goes along with bringing in the
data in more pre-processing with image
to array loading the image this stuff is
so nice it looks like a lot of works you
have to import all these different
modules in here but the truth is is it
does everything for you you're not doing
a lot of pre-processing you're letting
the software do the pre-processing
um and we're gonna be working with the
setting something to categorical
again that's just a conversion from a
number to a category 0 1 doesn't really
mean anything it's like true false
um label binderizer the same thing uh
we're changing our labels around and
then there's our train test split
classification report
our IM utilities let me just go ahead
and let's scroll down here a notch for
these this is something a little
different going on down here this is not
part of the tensorflow or the SK learn
this is the site kit setup and
tensorflow above
the path this is part of opencv and
we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the opencv so if you want
to know more about opencv you'll get a
glance on it in this software especially
the second piece when we reload up the
data and hook it up to a video camera
we're going to do that on this round
but this is part of the opencv thing and
you'll see CV2 is usually how that's
referenced but the IM utilities has to
do with how do you rotate pictures
around and stuff like that
and resize them and then the matplot
library for plotting because it's nice
to have a graph tells us how good we're
doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just a straight OS
access wow so that was a lot of imports
uh like I said I'm not going to spend I
spend a little time going through them
but we didn't want to go too much into
them
and then I'm going to create some
variables that we need to go ahead and
initialize we have the learning rate
number of epics to train for and the
batch size and if you remember correctly
we talked about the learning rate to the
negative 4.0001
a lot of times it's 0.001 or 0.001
usually it's in that variation depending
on what you're doing and how many epics
and they kind of play with the epics the
epics is how many times we're going to
go through all the data
now I have it as two the actual setup is
for 20 and 20 works great the reason I
have it for two is it takes a long time
to process one of the downsides of
Jupiter
is a Jupiter isolates it to a single
kernel so even though I'm on an eight
core processor with 16 dedicated threads
only one thread is running on this no
matter what so it doesn't matter so it
takes a lot longer to run even though
tensorflow really scales up nicely and
the batch size is how many pictures do
we load at once in process again those
are numbers you have to learn to play
with depending on your data and what's
coming in and the last thing we want to
go ahead and do is there's a directory
with the data set we're going to run
uh and this just has images of mass and
not masks
and if we go in here you'll see data set
and you have pictures with mass they're
just images of people with mass on their
face and then we have the opposite let
me go back up here without masks so it's
pretty straightforward they look kind of
Askew because they tried to format them
into very similar setup on there so
they're they're mostly squares you'll
see some that are slightly different on
here
and that's kind of important thing to do
on a lot of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run in
the in this processing of images up here
and the cross layers and importing and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these and a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with
so you have a couple things going on
there
and so we're now going to be this is now
loading the images and let me see
and we'll go ahead and create data and
labels here's our here's the features
going in which is going to be our
pictures and our labels going out and
then for categories in our list
directory directory and if you remember
I just flashed that at you it had a face
mask or or no face mask those are the
two options
and we're just going to load into that
we're going to append the image itself
and the labels so we're just going to
create a huge array and you can see
right now this could be an issue if you
had more data at some point
thankfully I have a 32 gig hard drive or
Ram
even that doesn't you could do with a
lot less of that probably under 16 or
even eight gigs would easily load all
this stuff
and there's a conversion going on in
here I told you about how we are going
to convert the size of the image so it
resizes all the images that way our data
is all identical the way it comes in
and you can see here with our labels we
have without mask without mask without
mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
and then we need to change it to the why
not hot encoding
and this is going to take our
up here we had was it labels and data we
want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to categorical and our labels then equal
a categorical list
we'll run that and again if we do uh
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10. let's do the last 10 just
because
minus 10 to the end there we go just so
we can see where the other side looks
like we now have one that means they
have a mask one zero one zero so on
one being they have a mask and zero no
mask
and if we did this in reverse
I just realized that this might not make
sense if you've never done this before
let me run this
0 1. so 0 is do they have a mask on zero
do they not have a mask on one so this
is the same as what we saw up here
without mask one equals the second value
is without mass so with mass without
mask
and that's just a with any of your data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a zero
one output
it causes issues as far as training and
setting it up so we always want to use a
one hot encoder if the values are not
actual linear value or regression values
they're not actual numbers
if they represent a thing
and so now we need to go ahead and do
our trainax test X train y test y train
split test data
and we'll go ahead and make sure it's
going to be random and we'll take 20
percent of it for testing and the rest
for setting it up as far as training
their model
this is something that's become so cool
when they're training these set they
realize we can augment the data what
does augment mean well if I rotate the
data around and I zoom in I zoom out I
rotate it share it a little bit flip it
horizontally
fill mode as they do all these different
things to the data it is able to it's
kind of like increasing the number of
samples I have uh so if I have all these
perfect samples what happens when we
only have part of the face or the face
is tilted sideways or all those little
shifts cause a problem if you're doing
just a standard set of data so we're
going to create an augment in our image
data generator which is going to rotate
zoom and do all kinds of cool things and
this is worth looking up this image data
generator and all the different features
it has
a lot of times I'll the first time
through my models I'll leave that out
because I want to make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know you build the whole
process and then you start adding these
different things in so that you can
better train your model and so we go and
run this and then we're going to load
um and then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have gotten an error if
you hadn't put this piece in right here
I haven't run it myself because the guys
in the back did this we take our base
model and one of the things we want to
do is we want to do a mobile net V2 and
this will be this is a big thing right
here include the top equals false
a lot of data comes in with a label on
the top row so we want to make sure that
that is not the case and then the
construction of the head of the model
that will be placed on the top of the
base model
uh we want to go ahead and set that up
and you'll see a warning here I'm kind
of ignoring the warning because it has
to do with the size of the pictures and
the weights for input shape
um so they'll they'll switch things to
defaults to say hey we're going to Auto
shape some of this stuff for you you
should be aware of that with this kind
of imagery we're already augmenting it
by moving it around and flipping it and
doing all kinds of things to it so
that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have we have our base
model we're going to do our head model
equals our base model output
and what we've got here is we have an
average pooling 2D pool size 77 head
model
head model flatten so we're flattening
the data so this is all processing and
flattening the images and the pooling
has to do with some of the ways it can
process some of the data we'll look at
that a little bit when we get down to
the lower level in this processing it
and then we have our dense we've already
talked a little bit about a dense just
what you think about and then the head
model has a drop out of 0.5
what do we can do with a dropout
yeah
the Dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training so when you actually use the
model it will use all the notes but this
drops certain ones out and it helps stop
biases from forming so it's really a
cool feature in here they discovered
this a while back we have another dense
mode and this time we're using soft Max
activation lots of different activation
options here softmax is a real popular
one for a lot of things so is the relu
and you know there's we could do a whole
talk on activation formulas and why what
their different uses are and how they
work
when you first start out you'll you'll
use mostly the relu and the softmax for
a lot of them just because there are
some of the basic setups that's a good
place to start
and then we have our model equals model
inputs equals base model dot input
outputs equals head model so again we're
still building our model here we'll go
ahead and run that
and then we're going to Loop over all
the layers in the base model and freeze
them so they will not be updated during
the first training process
uh so for layer and base model layers
layers.trainable equals false
a lot of times when you go through your
data you want to kind of jump in part
way through I I'm not sure why in the
back they did this for this particular
example but I do this a lot when I'm
working with series and and specifically
in stock data I wanted to iterate
through the first set of 30 Data before
it does anything
um I would have to look deeper to see
why they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model so compiling the model atom
init layer Decay
initial learning rate over epics and we
go ahead and compile our loss is going
to be the binary cross entropy which
we'll have that print out Optimizer for
opt metrics is accuracy
same thing we had before not a huge jump
as far as the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model so train the
head of the network print info training
head run
now I skipped a little time because it
you'll see the run time here is at 80
seconds per epic takes a couple minutes
for it to get through on a single kernel
one of the things I want you to notice
on here while we're well it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on so anytime the trainex and
trading y go in there's some Randomness
going on there it is jiggling it around
what's going into our setup
of course we're batch sizing it so it's
going through whatever we set for the
batch values how many we process at a
time
and then we have the steps per epic the
trainx the batch size validation data
here's our test X and Test Y where we're
sending that in
uh and this again it's validation one of
the important things to know about
validation is our when both our training
data and our test data have about the
same accuracy that's when you want to
stop that means that our model isn't
biased if you have a higher accuracy on
your testing you've trained it and your
accuracy is higher on your actual test
data then something in there is probably
uh has a bias and it's overfitted
uh so that's what this is really about
right here with the validation data and
validation steps
so it looks like it's let me go ahead
and see if it's done processing looks
like we've gone ahead and gone through
two epics again you could run this
through about 20 with this amount of
data and it would give you a nice
refined model at the end we're going to
stop at two because I really don't want
to sit around all afternoon and I'm
running this on a single thread so now
that we've done this we're going to need
to evaluate our model and see how good
it is and to do that we need to go ahead
and make our predictions
these are predictions on our test X to
see what it thinks they're going to be
so now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then we'll go ahead and go
down here
and we will need to uh turn the index in
because remember it's it's either 0 or 1
it's a zero one zero one so you have two
outputs uh not wearing uh wearing a mask
not wearing a mask and so we need to go
ahead and take that argument at the end
and change those predictions to a zero
or one coming out and then to finish
that off we want to go ahead and let me
just put this right in here and do it
all in one shot we want to show a nicely
formatted classification report so we
can see what that looks like on here
and there we have it we have our
Precision uh it's 97 with a mask there's
our F1 score support without a mask 97
percent
um so that's pretty high high setup on
there you know you three people are
going to sneak into the store who are
without a mask and the things they have
a mask and there's going to be three
people with a mask that's going to flag
the person at the front to go oh hey
look at this person you might not have a
mask that's if I guess if it's a setup
in front of a store
um so there you have it and of course
one of the other cool things about this
is if someone's walking into the store
and you take multiple pictures of them
um you know this is just an it would be
a way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those thick pictures and
make sure they match or don't match if
you're on the back end and
important step because we're gonna this
is just cool I love doing this stuff uh
so we're going to go ahead and take our
model and we're going to save it so
model save massdetector.model we're
going to give it a name we're going to
save the format in this case we're going
to use the H5 format
and so this model we just programmed has
just been saved so now I can load it up
into say another program what's cool
about this is let's say I want to have
somebody work on the other part of the
program well I just save the model they
upload the model now they can use it for
whatever and then if I get more
information and we start working with
that at some point
I might want to update this model and
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where I take this model
and maybe I'm running a prediction on
making money for a company and as my
model gets better
I want to keep updating it and then it's
real easy just to push that out to the
actual end user and here we have a nice
graph you can see the training loss and
accuracy as we go through the epics we
only did the you know only shows just
the one Epic coming in here but you can
see right here as the
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy
it starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is the convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're I know
when I work in the psych kit with SK
learn neural networks this is what
they're talking about a convergence is
our loss and our accuracy come together
and also up here and this is why I'd run
it more than just two epics as you can
see they still haven't converged all the
way so that would be a cue for me to
keep going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new Python 3
program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it and show you in a live action
get a view of both myself in the
afternoon along with my background of an
office which is in the middle still of
reconstruction for another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
uh we have our
mobilenet V2 import pre-processing input
so we're still going to need that we
still have our tensorflow image to array
we have our load model that's where most
of the stuff's going on
this is our CV2 or opencv again I'm not
going to dig too deep into that we're
going to flash a little opencv code at
you and we actually have a tutorial on
that coming out
our numpy array our IM utilities which
is part of the opencv or CV2 setup
and then we have of course time and just
our operating system so those are the
things we're going to go ahead and set
up on here and then we're going to
create this takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting so we're going to
detect and predict the mask we have
frame face net Mass net
these are going to be generated by our
opencv we have a frame coming in and
then we want to go ahead and create a
mask around the face it's going to try
to detect the face and then set that up
so we know what we're going to be
processing through our model
um and then there's a frame shape here
this is just our height versus width
that's all each W stands for they've
called it blob which is a CV2 DNN blob
form image frame so this is reformatting
this Frame it's going to be coming in
literally from my camera and we'll show
you that in a minute that little piece
of code that shoots that in here
and we're going to pass the blob through
the network and obtain the face
detections so facenet dot set in Port
blob
detections face net forward
print detections shape
so this is this is what's going on here
this is that model we just created we're
going to send that in there and I'll
show you in a second where that is but
it's going to be under facenet
and then we go ahead and initialize our
list of faces they're corresponding
locations and the list of predictions
from our face mask Network
we're going to Loop over the detections
and this is a little bit more work than
you think as far as looking for
different faces what happens if you have
a crowd of faces
so We're looping through the detections
and the shapes going through here
and probability associated with the
detection here's our confidence of
detections
we're going to filter out weak detection
by ensuring the confidence is greater
than the minimum confidence
so we've said it remember zero to one so
0.5 would be our minimal confidence
probably is pretty good
um
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if I'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an opencv and I really want
to stick to just the cross part
and so I'm just kind of jumping through
all this code you can get a copy of this
code from Simply learn and take it apart
or look for the opencv coming out
and we'll create a box the box sets it
around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
the dimensions of the frame
so we create a box around what's going
to we hope it's going to be the face
extract the face Roi convert it from BGR
to RGB Channel
again this is an opencv issue not really
an issue but it has to do with the order
I don't know how many times I've
forgotten to check the order colors
we're working with opencv because
there's all kinds of fun things when red
becomes blue
and blue becomes red and we're going to
go ahead and resize it process it frame
it face frame setup again the face the
CBT color we're going to convert it
we're going to resize it image to array
pre-process the input pin the face
locate face start x dot y and x boy that
was just a huge amount and I skipped
over a ton of it but the bottom line is
we're building a box around the face and
that box because the opencv does a
decent job of finding the face and that
box is going to go in there and see hey
does this person have a mask on it
uh and so that's what that's what all
this is doing on here and then finally
we get down to this where it says
predictions equals massnet.predict faces
batch size 32 so these different images
where we're guessing where the face is
are then going to go through and
generate an array of faces if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it and
that's what's going right here is our
prediction that's the big thing that
we're working for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the location just tells
where on the picture it is and then the
prediction tells us what it is is it a
mask or is it not a mask
all right so we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from disk
and we have our the path that it was
saved in obviously going to put in a
different path depending on where you
have it or however you want to do it and
how you saved it on the last one where
we trained it
and then we have our weights path
and so finally our face net here it is
equals
cb2.dnn dot read net
prototext path weights path and we're
going to load that up on here so let me
go ahead and run that
and then we also need to I'll just put
it right down here I always see it
separating these things in there and
then we're going to load the actual mass
detector model from disk this is the the
model that we saved so let's go ahead
and run that on there also so this is
pulling in all the different pieces we
need for our model and then the next
part is we're going to create open up
our video
and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the opencv
the video setup
let me just put this all in as one
there we go so we're going to go ahead
and open up our video we're going to
start it and we're going to run it until
we're done
and this is where we get some real like
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what I like to work about with
images and videos is that when you start
working with images and videos it's all
like right there in front of you it's
Visual and you can see what's going on
uh so we're going to start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream Source zero start
that means it's grabbing my main camera
I have hooked up
and then you know starting video you're
going to print it out here's our video
Source equals zero start Loop over the
frames from the video stream
oops a little redundancy there let me
close
I'll just leave it that's how they had
it in the code so so while true we're
going to grab the frame from the
threaded video stream and resize it to
have the maximum width of 400 pixels so
here's our frame we're going to read it
from our visual stream
we're going to resize it
and then we have a returning remember we
return from the our procedure the
location and the prediction so detect
and predict mask we're sending it the
frame we're sending it the face net and
The Mask net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on here
and then it returns our location and
predictions and then for our box and
predictions in the location and
predictions
and the boxes is again this is an opencv
set that says hey this is a box coming
in from the location because you have
the two different points on there
and then we're going to unpack the box
and predictions and we're going to go
ahead and do mask without a mask equals
prediction
we're going to create our label no mask
and create color if the label equals
mask l0225 and you know this is going to
make a lot more sense when I hit the Run
button here but we have the probability
of the label
we're going to display the label
bounding box rectangle on the output
frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
show the output from the frame CV2 IM
show frame frame and then the key equals
CV2 weight key one we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our feed
and we're going to do this until we hit
the stop button pretty much
so are you ready for this to see if it
works we've distributed our our model
we've loaded it up into our distributed
code here we've got a hooked into our
camera and we're going to go ahead and
run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
pop-up
and there I am in my office with my
funky headset on
uh and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here no
mask oh no I don't have a mask on I
wonder if I cover my mouth
what would happen
you can see my no mask
goes down a little bit I wish I brought
a mask into my office it's up at the
house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98 percent
chance that I don't have a mask on and
it's true I don't have a mask on right
now and this could be distributed this
is actually an excellent little piece of
script that you can start you know you
install somewhere on a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then you'd have this really neat setup
saying hey do you have a mask on when
you enter a store or a public
transportation or whatever it is where
they're required to wear a mask
let me go ahead and stop that
now if you want a copy of this code
definitely give us a holler we will be
going into opencv and another one so I
skipped a lot of the opencv code in here
as far as going into detail
really focusing on the cross saving the
model uploading the model and then
processing a streaming video through it
so you can see that the model works we
actually have this working model that
hooks into the video camera
which is just pretty cool and a lot of
fun
so I told you we're going to dive in and
really Roll Up Our Sleeve and do a lot
of coding today we did the basic demo up
above for just pulling it across and
then we went into a cross model where we
pulled in data to see whether someone
was wearing a mask or not so very useful
in today's world as far as a fully
running application
so if you want to see expertise in deep
learning skills and aspect to be a part
of Cutting Edge field of building
chatbots and service Bots using deep
learning are Caltech postage program in
Ai and machine learning provides
comprehensive coverage of the latest
tools and Technologies within the AI
ecosystem
it offers master classes read by esteem
Caltech faculty and IBM experts engaging
hackathons and interactive ask me
anything sessions by enrolling in this
program delivered in partnership with
IBM you will gain the expertise needed
to become a professional in a and ml
this comprehensive artificial
intelligence course will equip you with
the knowledge about various AI based
Technologies empowering you to excel in
this field so do check out the course
Link in the description for more details
let's get started now
now let's move on to the differences
between tensorflow Keras and pythonch
the first difference that we'll be
looking at is called level of API there
are two main types of apis a low level
API and a high level API apis stands for
application programming interface
a low level application programming
interface is generally more detailed and
allows you to have more detailed control
to manipulate functions within them on
how to use and Implement them while a
high level API is more generic and
simple and provides more functionality
with one command statements than a lower
level API high level interfaces are
comparatively easier to learn and to
implement the models using them they
allow you to write code in a shorter
amount of time and to be less involved
with the details in this case tensorflow
is a high and low level API
pure tensorflow is a low level API while
tensorflow wrapped in Keras is a high
level API
Keras in itself is a high level API
which uses multiple low-level apis as a
backend and simplifies the operation of
these low level apis pie torch is a low
level API the next criteria that we'll
be looking at is speed tensorflow is
very fast and is used for high
performances Keras is slower as it works
on top of tensorflow not only does it
have to wait for tensorflow to finish
implementation it then starts its own
implementation
meanwhile Pi torch works at the same
speed as tensorflow as both of them are
both low level apis now Keras is a
wrapper class for tensorflow and has
added abstraction functionalities on top
of tensorflow which make it slower than
tensorflow and pytouch in computation
speed both tensorflow and pytorch are
almost equal and in development speed
Keras is faster as it has built-in
functionalities which can significantly
reduce your development time the next
difference is on the architecture
tensorflow is not very easy to use and
even though it provides Keras as a
framework that makes it work easier
tensorflow still has a very complex
architecture which is hard to use
meanwhile Keras is a simpler
architecture and is easier to use it
provides a high level of abstraction
which makes implementation of programs
in Keras significantly easier pie touch
on the other hand also has a complex
architecture and the readability is less
when compared to Keras tensorflow uses
computational graphs which makes it very
complex and hard to interpret but it has
amazing computational ability across
platforms pytorch is a little hard for
beginners but is really good for
computer vision and deep learning
purposes
data sets and debugging tensorflow works
with large data sets due to its high
execution speed and debugging is really
hard in tensorflow due to its complex
nature meanwhile Keras only works with
very small data sets as its speed of
execution is low
programs do not require frequent
debugging in Keras as they are
relatively simpler and pytorch can
manage high level tasks in higher
Dimension data sets and is easier to
debug than both Keras and tensorflow
next we'll be looking at ease of
development as we said before tensorflow
works with many hard Concepts such as
computational graphs and tensors which
means that writing code in tensorflow is
very hard it is generally used by people
when they are doing research work and
really need very specific
functionalities
Keras on the other hand provides a high
level of abstraction which makes it very
easy to use it is best for people who
are just starting out with python and
machine learning pie torch is easier
than tensorflow but is still
comparatively hard than Keras it is not
very easy to learn for beginners but is
significantly more powerful than just
plain carers ease of deployment
tensorflow is very easy to deploy as it
uses tensorflow serving tensorflow
serving is a flexible high performance
serving system for machine learning
models designed for production
environments tensorflow serving makes it
easy to deploy new algorithms and
experiments while keeping the same
server architecture and apis tensorflow
serving provides out of the box
integration with tensorflow models but
can be easily extended to serve other
types of models and data in Keras model
deployment can be done with either
tensorflow serving or flask which makes
it relatively easy but not as easy as
you as it would be with tensorflow and
pytouch pie touch uses iTouch mobile
which makes deployment easy but again
for tensorflow deployment is way easier
as tensorflow serving can update your
machine learning backend on the fly
without the user even realizing there's
a growing need to execute ml models on
edge devices to reduce latency preserve
privacy and enable new interactive use
cases in the past Engineers used to
train models separately they would then
go through a multi-step error prone and
often complex process to train the
models for execution on a mobile device
the mobile runtime was often
significantly different from the
operations available during training
leading to inconsistent developer and
eventually user experience
all of these frictions have been removed
by pi torch Mobile by allowing a
seamless process to go from training to
deployment by staying entirely within
the pytorch ecosystem it provides an
end-to-end workflow that simplifies the
research to production environment for
mobile devices in addition it paves the
way for privacy preserving features via
Federated learning techniques
at the end of the day the question that
really matters is which framework should
you use Keras tensorflow or Pi torch
now tensorflow has implemented various
levels of abstraction to make
implementation of deep learning and
neural networks easy this has also made
debugging easier Keras is simple and
easy but not as fast as tensorflow it is
more user friendly than any other deep
learning API however and is easier to
learn for beginners if I torch on the
other hand is the preferred deep
learning API for teachers but it is not
as widely used in production as
tensorflow is it is faster but it has
lower GPU utilization
at the end of the day the framework that
we would suggest that you use is
tensorflow
why while Pi torch may have been the
preferred deep learning library for
researchers tensorflow is much more
widely used in day-to-day production pie
torches ease of use combined with the
default ego execution mode for easier
debugging predestines it to be used for
fast hacky Solutions and smaller scale
models but tensorflow's extensions for
deployment on both servers and mobile
devices combined with the lack of python
overhead makes it the preferred option
for companies that work with deep
learning models in addition the
tensorflow board visualization features
offers a nice way of showing the inner
workings of your model to say your
customers
meanwhile between tensorflow and Keras
the main difference isn't in performance
tensorflow is a bit faster due to less
overhead but also the level of control
you would like Keras is much easier to
start with than plain tensorflow but if
you want to do something with Keras that
doesn't come out of the box it will be
harder to implement that tensorflow on
the other hand allows you to create any
arbitrary computational graph providing
much more flexibility so if you're doing
more research type of work tensorflow is
the sure route to go due to the
flexibility that it provides so if you
want to see expertise in deep learning
skills and aspect to be a part of
Cutting Edge field of building chatbots
and service Bots using deep learning are
Caltech postage program in Ai and
machine learning provides comprehensive
coverage of the latest tools and
Technologies within the AI ecosystem
it offers master classes led by esteemed
Caltech faculty and IBM experts engaging
hackathons and interactive ask me
anything sessions by enrolling in this
program delivered in partnership with
IBM you will gain the expertise needed
to become a professional in a and ml
this comprehensive artificial
intelligence course will equip you with
the knowledge about various AI based
Technologies empowering you to excel in
this field so do check out the course
Link in the description for more details
let's get started now
so what are generative adversial
Networks
generative adversarial networks or Gans
introduced in 2014 by Ian J good fellow
and co-authors became very popular in
the field of machine learning
Gan is an unsupervised learning task in
machine learning it consists of two
models that automatically discover and
learn the patterns in input data
the two models called generator and
discriminator compete with each other to
analyze capture and copy the variations
within a data set
dance can be used to generate new
examples that possibly could have been
drawn from the original data set
in the image below you can see that
there is a database that has real 100
rupee nodes the generator which is
basically a neural network generates
fake hundred rupees nodes the
discriminator network will identify if
the nodes are real or fake let us now
understand in brief about what is a
generator a generator in Gans is a
neural network that creates fake data to
be trained on the discriminator
it learns to generate plausible data the
generated instances become negative
training examples for the discriminator
it takes a fixed length random Vector
carrying noise as input and generates a
sample now the main aim of the generator
is to make the discriminator classify
its output as real
the portion of the Gan that trains a
generator includes
a noisy input Vector the generator
Network which transforms the random
input into a data instance a
discriminator network which classifies
the generated data and a generator loss
which penalizes the generator for
failing to dolt the discriminator
the back propagation method is used to
adjust each weight in the right
direction by calculating the weights
impact on the output
the back propagation method is used to
obtain gradients and these gradients can
help change the generator weights now
let us understand in brief what a
discriminator is a discriminator is a
neural network model that identifies
real data from the fake data generated
by the generator the discriminator's
training data comes from two sources
the real data instances such as real
pictures of birds humans currency notes
Etc are used by the discriminator as
positive samples during the training the
fake data instances created by the
generator are used as negative examples
during the training process while
training the discriminator it connects
with two loss functions during
discriminator training the discriminator
ignores the generator loss and just uses
the discriminator loss in the process of
training the discriminator the
discriminator classifies both real data
and fake data from the generator the
discriminator loss penalizes the
discriminator for misclassifying a real
data instance as fake or a fake data
instance as real now moving ahead
let's understand how Gans work now Gans
consists of two networks a generator
which is represented as G of X and A
discriminator which is represented as D
of X they both play an adversarial game
where the generator tries to fool the
discriminator by generating data similar
to those in the training set the
discriminator tries not to be fooled by
identifying fake data from the real data
they both work simultaneously to learn
and train complex data like audio video
or image files you are aware that Gans
consists of two networks as generator G
of X and discriminator D of X now the
generator Network takes a sample and
generates a fixed sample of data the
generator is trained to increase the
probability of the discriminator network
to make mistakes on the other hand
the discriminator network decides
whether the data is generated or taken
from the real sample using a binary
classification problem with the help of
a sigmoid function that gives the output
in the range 0 and 1.
here is an example of a generative
adversarial Network trying to identify
if the 100 rupee nodes are real or fake
so first a noise vector or the input
Vector is fed to the generator Network
the generator creates fake 100 rupee
nodes
the real images of 100 rupee notes
stored in a database are passed to the
discriminator along with the fake nodes
the discriminator then identifies the
nodes and classifies them as real or
fake we train the model calculate the
loss function at the end of the
discriminator network and back propagate
the loss into both discriminator and
Generator now the mathematical equation
of training again can be represented as
you can see here now this is the
equation
and these are the parameters here G
represents generator D represents the
discriminator now P data of X is the
probability distribution of real data P
of Z is the distribution of Generator X
is the sample of probability data of x z
is the sample size from P of z d of X is
the discriminator network and G of Z is
the generator Network now the
discriminator focuses to maximize the
objective function such that D of X is
close to 1 and Z of Z is close to 0. it
simply means that the discriminator
should identify all the images from the
training set as real that is one and all
the generated images are fake that is 0
the generator wants to minimize the
objective function such that D of Z of Z
is 1 this means that the generator tries
to generate images that are classified
as real that is one by the discriminator
network next let's see the steps for
training a neural network so we have to
first Define the problem and collect the
data
then we'll choose the architecture of
Gan now depending on your problem choose
how your Gan should look like then we
need to train the discriminator in real
data that will help us predict them as
real for n number of times next you need
to generate fake inputs for the
generator after that you need to train
the discriminator on feed data to
predict the generator data is fake
finally train the generator on the
output of discriminator
with discriminator predictions available
train the generator to fool the
discriminator let us now look at the
different types of Gans so first we have
vanilla Gans
now vanilla Gans have min max
optimization formula that we saw earlier
where the discriminator is a binary
classifier and is using sigmoid cross
entropy loss during optimization
in vanilla Gans the generator and the
discriminator a simple multi-layer
perceptroms the algorithm tries to
optimize the mathematical equation using
stochastic gradient descent up next we
have deep convolutional Gans or DC Gans
now DC Gans support convolutional neural
networks instead of vanilla neural
networks at both discriminator and
Generator they are more stable and
generate higher quality images the
generator is a set of convolutional
layers with fractional strided
convolutions or transpose convolutions
so it unsamples the input image at every
convolutional layer the discriminator is
a set of convolutional layers with
strided convolutions so it down samples
the input image at every convolutional
layer moving ahead
the third type you have is conditional
gains or C Gans vanilla Gans can be
extended into conditional models by
using an extra label information to
generate better results in seagan an
additional parameter called Y is added
to the generator for generating the
corresponding data labels are fed as
input to the discriminator to help
distinguish the real data from fake data
generated
finally we have super resolution Gans
now Sr Gans use deep neural networks
along with adversarial neural network to
produce higher resolution images super
resolution Gans generate a
photorealistic high resolution image
when given a low resolution image let's
look at some of the important
applications of Gans
so with the help of DC Gans you can
train images of cartoon characters for
generating faces of Anime characters and
Pokemon characters as well next
Gans can be used on the images of humans
to generate realistic faces the faces
that you see on your screens have been
generated using Gans and do not exist in
reality third application we have is
cans can be used to build realistic
images from textual descriptions of
objects like birds humans and other
animals we input a sentence and generate
multiple images fitting the description
here is an example of a text to image
translation using Gans for a bird with a
black head yellow body and a short beak
the final application we have is
creating 3D objects
so Gans can generate 3D models using 2D
pictures of objects from multiple
perspectives cans are very popular in
the gaming industry
guns can help automate the task of
creating 3D characters and backgrounds
to give them a realistic feel
so if you want to see
an aspect to be a part of Cutting Edge
field of building chatbots and service
Bots using deep learning are Caltech
postages program in Ai and machine
learning provides comprehensive coverage
of the latest tools and Technologies
within the AI ecosystem
it offers master classes led by esteemed
Caltech faculty and IBM experts engaging
hackathons and interactive ask me
anything sessions by enrolling in this
program delivered in partnership with
IBM you will gain the expertise needed
to become a professional in a and ml
this comprehensive artificial
intelligence course will equip you with
the knowledge about various AI based
Technologies empowering you to excel in
this field so do check out the course
Link in the description for more details
let's get started now
so computational graphs are really the
heart and soul of neural networks we
talk about a computational graph there
are a visual representation of
expressing and evaluating mathematical
equations the nodes and data flow in a
graph correspond to mathematical
operations and variables
you'll hear a lot some of the terms you
might hear are node and Edge The Edge
being the data flow in this case it
could also represent an actual value
they have oh I think in spark they have
a graph x which works just on Computing
edges there's all kinds of stuff that
has evolved from computational graphs
we're focusing just on Karas and on
neural networks so we're not going to go
into great detail on everything a
computational graph does it is a core
component of a neural network is what's
important to know on this
so cross offers a python user-friendly
front-end while maintaining a strong
computation Power by using a low level
API like tensorflow Pi torch Etc which
use computational graphs as a back end
so one this allows for abstraction of
complex problems while specifying
control flow
if you've ever looked at some of the
back end or the original versions of
tensorflow it's really a nightmare you
have all these different settings you
have to put in there and create it's a
lot of a lot of back-end programming
this is like the old computers when you
had to tell it how to dispose of a
variable and how to properly re-allocate
the memory for use
all that is covered nowadays in our
higher level programming well this is
the same thing with Karas is it covers a
lot of this stuff and does things for
you that you would could spend hours on
just trying to figure out
it's useful for calculating derivatives
by using back propagation we're
definitely not going to teach a class on
derivatives in this little video but
understanding a derivative is the rate
of change so if you have a particular
function you're using in your neural
network a lot of them is just simple y
equals MX plus b your euclidean geometry
where you just have a simple slope times
the intercept and they get very
complicated they have the inverse
tangent function for Activation as
opposed to just a linear euclidean model
and you can think about this as you have
your data coming in and you have to
alter it somehow
well you alter it going down to get an
answer you end up with an error and that
error goes back up and you have to have
that back propagation with the
derivative you want to know how it
changed so that you can figure out how
to adjust it for the error
a lot of that's hidden so you don't even
have to worry about it with Karas and in
today's cross it'll even if you create
your own formula for computing an answer
it will automatically compute the back
prop the the derivative for you in a lot
of cases
it's easier to implement distributed
computation so cross is a really nice
way to package it and get it off on
different computers and share it and it
allows parallelism which means that two
operations can run simultaneously
so as we start developing these back
ends it can do all kinds of cool things
and utilize multiple cores gpus on a
computer to get that parallel processing
up
what are neural networks well like I
said there are already we've talked
about in computational edges you have a
node and you have a connection or your
Edge so neural networks are algorithms
fashioned after the human brain which
contain multiple layers each layer
contains a node called a neuron which
performs a mathematical operation they
break down complex problems into simple
operations
so one an input layer takes in our data
and pre-processes it when we talk about
pre-processing when you're dealing with
neural networks you usually have to
pre-process your data so it's between
-1 and 1 or 0 and 1 into some kind of
value that's usable that occurs before
it gets to the neural network in fact 80
percent of data science is usually in
prepping that data and getting it ready
for your different models
two you have hidden layer performs a
non-linear transformation of input now
it can do a hidden a linear
transformation it can use just a basic
euclidean geometry and you could think
of a node adding all the different
connections coming in so each connection
would have a weight and then it would
add to that weight plus an Intercept in
the node itself so you can actually use
euclidean geometry but a lot of these
get really complicated they have all
these different formulas and they're
really cool to look at but when you
start looking at them look at how they
work you really don't need to know the
high math behind it to figure them out
and figure out what they're doing
which is really cool that means a lot of
people can use this without having to go
get a PhD in mathematics
number three the output layer takes the
results from hidden layer transform them
and gives a final output
so sequential models so what makes this
a sequential model sequential models are
linear stacks of layers where one layer
leads to the next it is simple and easy
to implement and you just have to make
sure that the previous layer is the
input to the next layer
so you have used for plain stack of
layers where each layer has one input
and one output tensor and this is what
tensorflow is named after is each one of
these layers is like a tensor each node
is a tensor and then the layer is also
considered a tensor of values
and it's used for simple classifier
declassifier models you can it's also
used for regression models too so it's
not just about this is something this is
a teapot this is a cat this is a dog
it's also used for generating
regret the actual values you know this
is worth ten dollars that's worth thirty
dollars the weather is going to be 90
degrees out or whatever it is so you can
use it for both classifier and
declassifier models
and one more note when we talk about
sequential models the term sequential is
used a lot and it's used in different
areas in different notations when you're
in data science so when we talk about
time series we'll talk about sequential
that is something very different uh
sequential in this case means it goes
from the input to layer 1 to layer 2 to
the output so it's very directional it's
important to note this because if you
have a sequential model can you have a
non-sequential model and the answer is
yes if you master the basics of a
sequential model you can just as easily
have another model that shares layers
you can have another model where you
have an input coming in and it splits
and then you have one set that's doing
one set of nodes maybe they're doing a
yes no kind of node where it's either
putting out a zero or a one a classifier
and the other one might be regression
it's just processing numbers and then
you recombine them for the output that's
what they call across the cross AP API
so there's a lot of different
availabilities in here and all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as
encoding and decoding and all kinds of
things and you can share layers and
things like that
we're just focusing on the basic cross
model with the sequential model
so let's dive into the meat of the
matter let's do a do a demo on here
today's demo in this demo we'll be
performing flower classification using
sequential model and cross and we'll use
our model to classify between five
different types of flowers
now for this demo and you can do this
demo whatever platform you want or
whatever
user interface for developing python I'm
actually using anaconda and then I'm
using Jupiter notebooks to develop in
and if you're not familiar with this you
can go under environment once you've
created an environment you can come in
here to open a terminal window and if
you don't have the different modules in
here you can do your conda install or
whatever module it is
just happened that this particular setup
didn't have a Seaborn in it which I
already installed
so here's our anaconda and then I'm
going to go back
and start up my Jupiter notebook
where I already created a new python
project python3 come in Python 3.8 on
this particular one
sequential model for flowers
so lots of fun there so we're going to
jump right into this the first thing is
to make sure you have all your modules
installed
so if you don't have numpy pandas
matplot library and Seabourn in the
cross
and SK learn or site kit it's not
actually sklearn you'll need to go ahead
and install all of those
now having done this for years and
having switched environments and doing
different things
I get all my imports done and then we
just run it and if we get an error we
know we have to go back and install
something
um right off the bat though we have
numpy pandas matplot Library Seaborn
these are built on top of each other
append is a data frame and built on top
of numpy the
data array
and then we bring in our SK learn or
scikit this is the site kit setup SCI
kit even though you use SK learn to
bring it in it's a sidekit and then our
cross we have our pre-processing the
images image data generator
um our model this is our basic model our
sequential model
uh and then we bring in from Cross
layers import dents optimizers
these optimizers a lot of them already
come in these are your different
optimizers and it's almost a lot of this
is so automatic now
um Adam
is the a lot of times the default
because you're dealing with a large data
and then we get our SGD which is a
smaller data does better on smaller
pieces of data and I'm not going to go
into all of these different optimizers
we didn't even use these in the actual
demo you just have to be aware that they
are different optimizers and the Digger
the more you dig into these models
you'll hit a point where you do need to
play with these a little bit but for the
most part leave it at the default when
you're first starting out
and we're doing just the sequential
you'll see here layers dense
and then if we come down a little bit
more when they put this together and
they're running the dense layers you'll
also see they have drop out they have
flattened they have activation they have
the convolutional layer 2D Max pooling
2D batch normalization
what are all these layers and we get to
the model we're going to talk about them
a lot of times when you're just starting
you can just import cross dot layers and
then you have your drop out your
flattened your convolutional neural
network 2D
and we'll we'll cover what these do in
the actual example when we get down
there what I want you to take from here
though is you need to run your Imports
and load your different aspects of this
and of course your tensorflow TF because
this is all built on tensorflow
and then finally import random is RN
just for random generation
and then we get down here we have our
CV2 that is your open image or your
opencv they call it for processing
images that's what the cvd 2 is
uh we have our tqdm
the TQ DM is for is a progress bar just
a fancy way of adding when you're
running a process you can view the bar
going across in the Jupiter uh setup not
really necessary but it's kind of fun to
have
um we want to be able to shuffle some
files again these are all different
things pills and other
um
image processor it goes with the CV2 a
lot of times you'll see both of those
and so we run those we've got to bring
them all in
and the next thing is to set up our
directories
and so we come into the directories
there's an important thing to note on
here other than we're looking at a lot
of flowers which is fun
uh as we get down here we have our
directory archive flowers that just
happens to be where the different files
for different flowers are put in
we're denoting an X and a z and the x is
the date of the image and the Z is the
tag for it what kind of flower is this
and the image size is really important
because we have to resize everything if
you have a neural network and if you
remember from our neural networks let me
flip back to that slide
we look at this slide we have two input
nodes here with an image you have an
input node depending on how you set it
up for each pixel and that pixel has
three different color schemes usually in
it sometimes four so if you have a
picture that's 150 by 150 you multiply
150 times 150 times 30. that's how many
nodes input layers coming in that means
this is a massive input a lot of times
you think oh yeah it's just a small
amount of data or something like that no
it's a full image coming in and then you
have your hidden layers A lot of times
they match what the image size is coming
in so each one of those is also just as
big and then we get down to just a
single output
so that's kind of a thing to note in
here what's going on behind the scenes
and of course each one of these layers
has a lot of processes and stuff going
on
and then we have our different
directories on here let me go ahead and
run that so I'm just setting the
directories that's all this is archive
flowers Daisy sunflower tulip dandelion
Rose just our different directories that
we're going to be looking at
and then we want to go ahead and we need
to assign labels remember we defined x
and z
so we're just going to create a
definition here
and the first thing is a return flower
type okay
[Laughter]
just returns it what kind of flower it
is I guess assign the label to it but
we're going to go ahead and make our
train data
and when you look at this there's a
couple things to take away from here the
first one is we're just appending right
onto our numpy array the image
we're gonna let numpy handle all that
different aspects as far as 150 by 150
by three we just dump it right into the
numpy which makes it really easy we
don't have to do anything funky on the
processing and we want to leave it like
that and I'm going to talk about that in
a minute and then of course we have to
have the string a pin the label on there
and I want you to notice right here
we're going to read the image in
and then we're going to size it and this
is important because we're just changing
this to 150 by 150 we're resizing the
image so it's uniform every image comes
in identical to the other ones this is
something that's so important is when
you're resizing or reformatting your
data you really have to be aware of
what's going on
with images it's not a big deal because
with an image you just resize it so it
looks squishy or spread out or stretched
the neural network picks up on that and
it doesn't really change how it
processes it
so let's go ahead and run that
and now we've got our definition set up
on there
and then we want to go ahead and make
our
training data so make the train data
daisy flower daisy directory print
length of X so here we go let's go and
run that and we're just loading up the
flower daisy so this is going all in
there and it's setting it's adding it in
to the our setup on there to our x and z
set up and we see we have 769.
and then of course you can see this nice
bar here this is the bar going across is
that little added code in there that
just makes it really cool for doing
demos not necessarily when you're
building your own model or something
like that but if you're going to display
this to other people adding that little
what was it called um
tqdm I can never remember that but the
tqdm module in there is really nice and
we'll go ahead and do sunflowers and of
course you could have just created an
array of these
but this has an interesting problem
that's going to come up and I want to
show you something
it doesn't matter how good the people in
the back are or how good you are
programming
errors are going to come up and you got
to figure out how to handle them and so
when we get all the way down to
the um where is it dandelion here's our
dandelion directory we're going to build
Jupiter has some cool things it does
which makes this really easy to deal
with
but at the same time you want to go back
in there depending on how many times you
rerun this how many times you pull this
so when you're finding errors
I'm going in here there's a couple
things you can do and we're just going
to oh it wasn't there it is there's our
error I knew there was an error
this processed
1062 out of 1065.
now I can do a couple things one I could
go back into our definition
and I can just put in here try and so if
it has a bad conversion because this is
where the air is coming from uh just
skip it that's one way to do it
when you're doing a lot of work in data
science and you look at something like
this where you're losing three points of
data at the end you just say okay I lost
three points who cares or you can go in
there and try to delete it it really
doesn't matter for this particular demo
and so we're just going to leave that
error right alone and skip over because
it's already added all the other files
in there and this is a wonderful thing
about jupyter notebook is that I can
just continue on there in the x and z
which we're creating is still running
and we'll just go right into the next
flower row so all these flowers are in
there
um that's just a cool thing about
Jupiter notebook
and then we can go ahead and just take a
quick look and see
what we're dealing with and this is of
course really when you're dealing with
the other people and showing them stuff
this is just kind of fun where we can
just play it on the plot Library here
and we're just going to go through and
let's see what we got here uh looks like
we're going to do like five of each of
them I think
is that how they set this up
um
plot Library five by two okay oh I see
how they did it okay so two each so we
have five by two set up on our axes and
we're just going to go in and look at a
couple of these flowers
it's always a good thing to look at some
of your data no matter what you're doing
we've reformatted this to 150 by 150 you
can see how it really blurs this one up
here on the Tulip that is that resize to
150 by 150. and these are what's
actually going in these are all 150 by
150 images you can check the dimensions
on the side
and you can see just a quick sampling of
the flowers we're actually going to
process on here
and again like I said at the beginning
most of your work in data science is
reprocessing
this different information so we need to
go ahead and take our labels
and run a label encoder on there and
then we're just going to Ellie is a
label encoder one of the things we
imported
and then we always use the fit
to categorical y comma 5 x here's our
array
X so if you look at this here's our fit
we're going to transform Z
that's our Z array we created
and then we have Y which equals that and
then we go ahead and do to categorical
we want five different categories
and then we create our X in P array of x
x equals x over 255.
so what's going on here there's two
different Transformations one we've
turned our categories into zero one two
three four five as the output and we
have taken our X array
and remember the X array is three values
of your different colors
this is so important to understand when
we do this across a numpy array this
takes every one of those three colors so
we have 150 by 150 pixels
out of those 150 by 150 pixels they each
have three
um color arrays and those color arrays
range from 0 to 250. so when we take the
x equals x over 255
I'm sorry range between 0 to 255. this
converts all those pixels to a number
between 0 and 1. and you really want to
do that when you're working with neural
networks now if you do a linear
regression model it doesn't affect it as
much and so you don't have to do that
conversion if you're doing straight
numbers but when you're running neural
networks if you don't do this you're
going to create a huge bias and that
means they'll do really good on
predicting one or two things and they'll
just totally die on a lot of other
predictions
so now we have our
X and Y values X being the data n y
being our known output
and with any good setup we want to
divide this data into our training so we
have X train we have our X test this is
the data we're not going to program the
model with
and of course your y train corresponds
to your X train and your y test
corresponds to your X test the outputs
and this is when we do the train test
split this was from the site kit sklearn
we imported train test split and we're
just going to go ahead and do the test
size at about a quarter of the data 0.25
and of course random is always good
this is such a good tool I mean
certainly you can do your own division
um
you know you could just take the first
you know 0.25 of the data or whatever to
the length of the data not real hard to
do but this is randomized so if you're
running this test a few times you can
kind of get an idea whether it's going
to work or not
sometimes what I will do
is I'll just split the data into three
parts
and then I'll test it on two with one
being the or I train it on two of those
parts with one being the test and I
rotate it so I come up with three
different answers which is a good way of
finding out just how good your model is
but for setting up let's stick with the
X train X test and the SK learn package
and then we're going to go ahead and do
a random seed
now a lot of times the cross actually
does this automatically but we're going
to go ahead and set it up on here and
you can see we did an NP random seed
from 42 and we get a nice RN number and
then we do TF random we set the seed so
you can set your Randomness at the
beginning of your tensorflow and that's
what the tf.random dot set is
so that's a lot of prep
um all this prep and then we finally get
to the exciting part
um this is where you probably spend once
you have the data prepped and you have
your pipeline going and you have
everything set up on there this is the
part that's exciting is building these
models
and so we look at this model one we're
going to designate a sequential they
have the API which is across the cross
tensorflow API versus sequential
sequential means we're going one layer
to the next so we're not going to split
the layer and bring it back together
it looks almost the same with the
exception of bringing it back together
so it's not a huge step to go from this
to an API
and the first thing we're going to look
at is our convolutional neural network
in 2D
so what's going on here there's a lot of
stuff that's going on here the default
for well let's start with the beginning
what is a convolutional 2d Network
well a convolutional 2d Network creates
a number of small windows and those
small Windows float over the picture and
each one of them is their own neural
network and it's basically becomes like
a uh a categorization and then it looks
at that and it says oh if we add these
numbers up a certain way uh we can find
out whether this is the right flower
based on this this little window
floating around which looks at different
things
and we have filters 32 so this is
actually creating 32 Windows is what
that's doing
and the kernel size is five by five so
we're looking at a five by five square
remember it's 150 by 150 so this narrows
it down to a five by five it's a 2d so
it has your X Y coordinates and when we
look at this five by five remember each
one of these is it's actually looking at
five by five by three
so we're actually looking at 15 by 15
different pixels
and padding is just
usually I just ignore that activation by
default is relu we went ahead and put
the rayleu in there
there's a lot of different activations
relu is for your smaller uh when you
remember I mentioned atom when you have
a lot of data data use an atom kind of
activation or use an atom processing
we're using the rayleu here uh it kind
of gives you a yes or no but it it
doesn't give you a full yes or no it has
a a zero and then it kind of shoots off
at an angle
very common it's the most common wand
and then of course here's our input
shape 150 by 150 by 3 pixels
and then we have to pool it so whenever
you have a two convolutional 2D
layer we have to bring this back
together and pull this into a neural
network and then we're going to go ahead
and repeat this
so we're going to add another Network
here one of the cool things if you look
at this is that it as it comes in it
just kind of automatically assumes
you're going down to the next layer
and so we have another convolutional
null Network 2D here's our Max pooling
again we're going to do that again Max
pooling and we're just going to filter
on down
now one of the things they did on this
one is they changed the kernel size they
changed the number of filters and so
each one of these steps
kind of looks at the data a little bit
differently and that's kind of cool
because then you get a little added
filtering on there
this is where you start playing with the
model you might be looking at a
convolutional neural network which is
great for image classifications
um
we get down to here one of the things we
see is flattened so we add we just
flatten it remember this is 150 by 150
by three well and actually the pool size
changes so it's actually smaller than
that flattened just puts that into a 1D
array so instead of being you know a
tensor of this really complexity with
the the pixels and everything it's just
flat and then the dense
it's just another activation on there by
default it is probably relu as far as
this activation
and then oh yeah here we go in
sequential they actually added the
activation is relu so this just because
this is sequential this activation is
attached to the dense
and there's a lot of different
activations but Rayleigh is the most
common one and then we also see a soft
Max softmax is similar but it has its
own kind of variation and one of the
cool things you know what let me bring
this up because if we if you don't know
about these activations this doesn't
make sense
and I just did a quick Google search on
images of tensorflow activations
um I should probably look at which
website this is
but this is the output of the values so
as your X as it adds in all those
weighted X values going into the node
it's going to activate it a certain way
and that's a sigmoid activation and you
can see it goes between 0 and 1 and has
a nice curve there this also shows the
derivatives and if we come down the
seven popular activation functions
non-linear activations there's a lot of
different options on this let me see if
I can find the
oops we can find the specific to relu
so this is a leaky Ray Lou and you can
see instead of it just being 0 and then
a value between going up it has a little
leaky there otherwise your Rayleigh
loses some notes they just become
inactive
um but you can see there's a lot of
different options here here's a good one
right here with the ray Lou you can see
the Rayleigh function on the upper on
the upper left here and then the Leaky
Rayleigh over here on the right which is
very commonly used also
one of the things I use with processing
um language is the Sig is the
exponential one or the tangent H the
hyperbolic tangent because they have
that nice funky curve that comes in that
has a whole different meaning and
captures word use better
again these are very specific to domain
and you can spend a lot of time playing
with different models for a basic model
we'll stick to the relu and the soft Max
on here and we'll go ahead and run and
build this model
so now that we've had fun playing with
all these different models that we can
add in there we need to go ahead and
have a batch size on here
128 epics 10
this means that we're going to send 128
uh rows of data or flowers at a time to
be processed
and the epics 10 that's how many times
we're going to Loop through all the data
deuce the values and verbose verbose
equals one means that we're going to
show what's going on
value the monitor what we're monitoring
we'll see that as we actually train the
model this is what's what's going to
come out of there if you set the verbose
equal to zero you don't have to watch it
train the model although it is kind of
nice to actually know what's going on
sometimes
and since we're still working on
bringing the data in here's our batch
side here's our epics we need to go
ahead and create a data generator this
is our image data generator
and it has all the different settings in
here almost all of these are defaults so
if you're looking at this going oh my
gosh this is confusing most of the time
you can actually just ignore most of
this vertical flip so you can randomly
flip pictures you can randomly
horizontally flick them you can shift
the picture around this kind of helps
gives you multiple data off of them
zooming rotation there's all kinds of
different things you can do with images
most of these we're just going to leave
as false we don't really need to do all
that um setup because we already have a
huge amount of data if your short data
you can start flipping like a horizontal
picture and it will generate it's like
doubling your data almost
so the upside is you double your data
the downside is that if you already have
a bias in your data you already have
um
5000 sunflowers and only two roses
that's a huge bias it's also going to
double that bias that is the downside of
that
and so we have our model com model
compile and this you're going to see in
all the cross we're going to take this
model here we're going to take all this
information as far as how we want it to
go and we're going to compile it
this actually builds the model and so
we're going to run that and I want you
to notice uh learning rate
very important this is the default zero
zero one there's there you really don't
this is how slowly it adjusts to find
the right answer
and the more data you have you might
actually make this a smaller number with
larger with you have a very small sample
of data you might go even larger in that
and then we're going to look at the loss
categorically categorical cross entropy
most commonly used
and this is uh how how much it improves
the model is improving is what this
number means or yeah that's that's
important on there and then the accuracy
we want to know just how good our model
is on the accuracy
and then
one of the cool things to do is if
you're in a group of people who are
studying the model if you're in
shareholders you don't want to do this
is you can run the model summary
I do this by default and you can see the
different layers that you built into
this model just a quick summary on there
so we went ahead and we're going to go
ahead and create a
we'll call it history but we want to do
a model fit generator
and so what this history is doing is
this is tracking what's going on as well
it fits the model
now there's a lot of new setups in here
where they just use fit and then you put
the generator in here
we're going to leave it like this even
though the new default
is a little different on that it doesn't
really matter it does the same thing and
we'll go ahead and just run that
and you can see while it's running right
here we're going through the epics we
have one of ten now we're going through
6 to 25 here's our loss we're printing
that out so you can see how it's
improving and our accuracy the accuracy
gets better and better and this is 6 out
of 25. this is going to take a couple
minutes to process because we are
training 150 by 150 by 3 pixels across
six layers or eight layers whatever it
was
that is a huge amount of processing so
this will take a few minutes to process
this is when we talk about the hardware
and the problems that come up in data
science and why it's only now just
exploding being able to do neural
networks this is why this process takes
a long time
now you should have seen a jump on the
screen here because I did pause the
recorder to let this go ahead and run
all the way through it's epics
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what these epics are and if you set the
verbose to zero instead of one it won't
show what's going on in the behind the
scene to just training it so we look at
this epic 10 epic so we went through all
the data 10 times if I remember
correctly there's roughly a gig of data
there so that's a lot of data
the first thing you're going to notice
is the 270 seconds that's how much each
of those epics took to run and so if you
divide 60 in there you roughly get about
five minutes worth of each epic so if I
have 10 epics that's 50 minutes almost
an hour of run time
that's a big deal we talk about
processing uh in on this particular
computer I actually have what is it uh
eight cores with 16 dedicated threads so
it runs like a 16 core computer it
alternates the threads going in and it
still takes it five minutes for each one
of these epics so you start to see that
if you have a lot of data this is going
to be a problem if you have a number of
models you want to find out how good the
models are doing what model to use
and so each of those models could take
all night to run in fact I have a model
I'm running now that takes over uh takes
about a day and a half to test each
model it takes four days to do with the
whole data so what I do is I actually
take a small piece of the data
test it out to find out get an idea of
how the different setups are going to do
and then I increase that size of the
data and then increase it again and I
can just take that that curve and kind
of say okay if the data is doing this
then I need to add in more dense layers
or whatever so you can do a small chunks
of data then figure out what it costs to
do a large set of data and what kind of
model you want
the loss as we see here continues to go
down this is the error this is how much
error is in there it really isn't a
user-friendly number other than the more
it Trends down the better and so if you
continue to see the loss going down
eventually it'll get to the point where
it stops going down and it goes up and
down and kind of wavers a little bit at
that point you know you've run too many
epics you're starting to get a bias in
there and it's not going to give you a
good model fit
the accuracy just turns us into
something that we can use and so the
accuracy is what percentage of guesses
in this case is categorical so this is
the percentage of guesses are correct
value loss is similar you know it's a
minus a value loss
and then you have the value accuracy and
you'll see the value accuracy is pretty
similar to the accuracy just rounds it
off basically and so a lot of times you
come down here and you go okay we're
doing 0.5.6
0.7 and that is 70 accuracy or in this
case
68.59 accuracy that's a very usable
number and it's very important to have
if you're identifying uh flowers that's
probably good enough if you can get
within a close distance and knowing what
flower you're identifying if you're
trying to figure out whether someone's
going to die from a heart attack or not
you might want to rethink it a little
bit or re-key how you're building your
model so if I'm working with a a group
of clients shareholders in a company or
something like that you don't really
want to show them this you don't want to
show them hey you know this is what's
going on with the accuracy these are
just numbers and so we want to go and
put the finishing touches just like when
you are building a house and you put in
the frame and the trim on the house it's
nice to have something a nice view of
what's going on and so we'll go ahead
and do a pi plot and we'll just plot the
history of the loss the history of the
value loss
over here epics train and test and so
we're just going to compute these this
is really important and what I want you
to notice right here is when we get to
about oh five epics a little more than
five six epics you see a crossover here
and it starts Crossing as far as the
value loss and what's going on here is
you have the loss in your actual model
and your actual data and you have the
value loss where it's testing it against
the the test data the data wasn't used
to program your model wasn't used to
train your model on
and so when we see this crossing over
this is where the bias is coming in this
is becoming overfitted and so when you
put these two together uh right around
five and six you start to see how it
does this this switch over here and
that's really where you need to stop
right around five yeah six
um it's always hard to guess because at
this point the model is kind of a black
box uh see but you know that right
around here if you're saving your model
after each run you want to use the one
that's right around five epics because
that's the one that's going to have the
least amount of bias so this is really
important as far as guessing what's
going on with your model and its
accuracy and when to stop it also is you
know I don't show people this mess up
here
um I show somebody this kind of model I
say this is where the training and the
testing comes in on this model
it just makes it easier to see and
people can understand what's going on
so that completes our demo and you can
see we did what we were set out to do we
took our flowers and we were able to
classify them within about you know 68
70 accuracy whether it's going to be a
dahlia sunflower cherry blossom Rose a
lot of other things you can do with your
output as far as a different tables to
see where the errors are coming from and
what problems are coming up
and we're going to take a look at image
classification using cross and the basic
setup and we'll actually look at two
different demos on here
what's in it for you today what is image
classification
Intel image classification data creating
neural networks with Karas and the vtg16
model
what is image classification
the process of image classification
refers to assigning classes to an entire
image images can be classified based on
different categories like weather it is
a nighttime or daytime shot what the
image represents Etc you can see here we
have mountains looking for mountains
we'll actually be doing some
pictures of scenery and stuff like that
in deep learning we perform image
classification by using neural networks
to extract features from images and
classify them based on these features
you can see here where it has like with
computer sees and this is oh yeah we see
mostly 4S maybe a little bit of
mountains because the way the image is
and this is really where one of the
areas that neural networks really shines
if you try to run this stuff through
more like a linear regression model
you'll still get results but the results
kind of miss a lot of things as the as
the neural networks get better and
better at what they do with different
tools we have out there
uh so Intel image classification data
the data being used is the Intel image
classification data set which consists
of images of six types of land areas
let's say we have Forest building
glaciers and mountains sea and Street
and you can see here is a couple of the
images out of there as a setup in the in
the
Intel image classification data that
they use
and then we're going to go into creating
a neural networks with Karas
the convolutional neural network that we
are creating from scratch looks as shown
below
you'll see here we have our input layer
um
they have it listed Max pooling so you
have
as you're coming in with the input layer
and the input layer is actually
um before this but the first layer that
it's going to go into is going to be a
convolutional neural network then you
have a Max pooling that pulls those the
the convolutional neural networks
returns in this case they have two of
those that is very standard with
convolutional neural networks one of the
ones that I was looking at earlier that
was standard being used by I want to one
of the larger companies I can't remember
which one for doing a large amount of
identification had two convolutional
neural networks each with their Max
pooling and then about 17 dense layers
after it we're not going to do that
heavy duty of a of a code but we'll get
you ahead in the right direction and
that gives you an idea of what you're
actually going to be looking at when you
look at the flattened part and then the
dense we're talking like 17 dense layers
afterwards
I find that a lot of the stuff I've been
working on I end up maxing it out right
around nine dense layers it really
depends on what you have going in and
what you're working with
and the vgg16 model
vgg16 is a pre-trained CNN model which
is used for image classification it is
trained on a large varied data set and
fine-tuned to fit image classification
data sets with ease
foreign
you can see down here we have the input
coming in uh the convolutional neural
network one to one one to two and then
pooling and then we do two to one two to
two convolutional Network then pooling
three to two and you can see there's
just this huge layering of convolutional
neural networks and in this case they
have five such layers going in and then
in three dents going out or uh more now
when they took this setup this actually
won an award back in 2019 for this
particular setup
and it does it does really good except
that again we only show the three dense
layers here and as you find out
depending on your data going in what you
have set up that really isn't enough on
one of these setups and I'm going to
show you why we restricted it because it
does take up a lot of processing power
in some of these things
so let's go ahead and rope our sleeves
and we're going to look at both the
setups we're going to start with the the
first classification and then we'll go
into the vgg 16 and show you how that's
set up now I'm going to be using
anaconda and let me flip over to my
anaconda so you can see what that looks
like
now I'm running in the Anaconda here uh
you'll see that I've set up a main
Python 3 8 I always put that in there
because this is where I'm doing like
most of my kind of playing around uh
this is done in Python version 3.8 we're
not going to dig too much into versions
uh at this point you should already have
cross installed on there usually cross
takes a number of extra steps
and then our usual
um uh setup is the numpy the pandas uh
your SK your site kit which is going to
be the SK learn your Seaborn and I'll
show you those in just a minute and then
I'm just going to be in the Jupiter lab
where I've created a new
notebook in here
and let's flip on over there to my blank
notebook
now there's a couple cool things to note
in here is that one I use the the
Anaconda Jupiter notebook setup because
it keeps everything separate except for
cross cross is actually running
separately in the back I believe it's a
c program
uh what's nice about that is that it
utilizes the multi-processors on the
computer and I'll mention that just in a
little bit when we actually get down to
running the code
it's and when we look in here the couple
things to note is here's our
oops I thought I grabbed the other
drawing thing but here's our numpy and
our pandas right here and our operating
system this is our PSI kit you always
import it as SK learn for the
classification report we're going to be
using well usually import like Seabourn
brings in all of your pipelot library
also
kind of nice to throw that in there I
can't remember if we're actually using
Seaborn if they just the people in the
back just threw that together and then
we have the sklearn shuffle for
shuffling data here's our matplot
library that the Seaborn is pretty much
built on
um CV2 if you're not familiar with that
that is our image module for importing
the image and then of course we have our
tensorflow down here which is what we're
really working with
and then the last thing is just for
visual effect while we're running this
if you're doing a demo and you're
working with the partners or the
shareholders this TQ DM is really kind
of cool it's an extensible progress bar
for Python and I'll show you that too
remember data science is not I mean you
know most is code when I'm looking
through this code I'm not going to show
half of this stuff to the shareholders
or anybody I'm working with they don't
really care about pandas and all that we
do because we want to understand how it
works
uh so we need to go ahead and import
those different
um
setup on there and then the next thing
is we're going to go ahead and set up
our classes uh now we remember if we had
Mountain Street Glacier Building C and
Forest those were the different images
that we have coming in
and we're going to go ahead and just do
class name labels and we're going to
kind of match that class name of ifri
class name
equals the class names so our labels are
going to match the names up here
and then we have the number of classes
in the print the class names and the
labels and we'll go ahead and set the
image size this is important that we
resize everything because if you
remember with neural networks they take
one size data coming in and so when
you're working with images you really
want to make sure they're all resized
the same setup it might squish them it
might stretch them that generally does
not cause a problem in these and some of
the other tricks you can do with if you
if you need more data and this is one
that's used regularly we're not going to
do it in here is you can also take these
images and not only resize them but you
can tilt them one way or the other crop
parts of them so they process slightly
differently and it'll actually increase
your accuracy of some of these
predictions and so you can see here we
have Mountain equals zero that's what
this class name label is Street equals
one Glacier equals two buildings equals
three C4 Forest equals five
now we did this as an enumerator so each
one is 0 through 5. a lot of times we do
this instead as
um
0 1 0 1 0 1 so you have five outputs and
each one's a zero or a one coming out so
the next thing we really want to do is
we want to go ahead and load the data up
and just put a label in there loading
data
just just so you know what we're doing
I'm going to put in the loading data
down here make sure it's well labeled
and we'll create a definition for this
and this is all part of your
pre-processing
at this point you could replace this
with all kinds of different things
depending on what you're working on and
if you once you download you can go
download this data set send a note to
the simply learn team here in YouTube
and they'll be happy to direct in the
right direction and make sure you get
this path here so you have the right
whatever wherever you saved it a lot of
times I'll just abbreviate the path or
put it as a sub thing and just get rid
of the directory but again double check
your paths we're going to separate this
into a segment for training and a
segment for testing and that's actually
how it is in the folder let me just show
you what that looks like
so when I have my lengthy path here
where I keep all my programming simply
learned this particular setup we're
working on image classification and
image classification clearly you
probably wouldn't have that lengthy of a
list
and when we go in here you'll see
sequence train sequence test they've
already split this up this is what we're
going to train the data in and again you
can see buildings Force Glacier Mountain
C Street and if we double click let's go
under Forest you can see all these
different Forest images and there's a
lot of variety here I mean we have
winter time we have summertime so it's
kind of interesting you know here's like
a Fallen Tree versus a road going down
the middle that's really hard to train
and if you look at the buildings
a lot of these buildings you're looking
up a skyscraper we're looking down the
setup
here's some trees with one I want to
highlight this one it has trees in it
let me just open that up so you can see
it a little closer
the reason I want to highlight this is I
want you to think about this we have
trees growing is this the city or a
forest
um so this kind of imagery makes it
really hard for a classifier and if you
start looking at these you'll see a lot
of these images do have trees and other
things in the foreground weird angles
really a hard thing for a computer to
sort out and figure out whether it's
going to be a forest or a city
and so in our loading of data uh one we
have to have the path of directory we're
going to come in here we have our images
and our labels
so we're going to load the images in one
section the label is in another
um
and if you look through here it just
goes through the different folders in
fact let me do this let me
there we go as we look at this we're
just going to Loop through the three the
six different folders that have the
different Landscapes and then we're
going to go through and pull each file
out
and each label so we set the label we
set the folder for file and list here's
our image path join the paths this is
all kind of not General stuff so I'm
kind of skipping through it really quick
and here's our image setup if you
remember we're talking about the images
we have our CV2 reader so it reads the
the image in it's going to go ahead and
take the image and convert it to from
blue green red to red green green blue
this is a CV2 thing almost all the time
it Imports it and instead of importing
it as a standard that's used just about
everywhere it Imports it with the BGR
versus RGB RGB is pretty much a standard
in here you have to remember that with
CV2 and then we're going to go ahead and
resize it this is the important part
right here we've set it we've decided
what the size is and we want to make
sure all the images have the same size
on them
and then we just take our images we're
just going to impend the image pin the
label and then the images it's going to
turn into a numpy array this just makes
it easier to process and manipulate and
then the labels is also a numpy array
and then we just return the output
append images and labels and we return
the output down here
so we've loaded these all into memory we
haven't talked much there'd be a
different setup in there because there
is ways to feed the files directly into
your cross model but we want to go ahead
and just load them all because it's
really
he for today's processing and that what
our computers can handle that's not a
big deal
and then we go ahead and set the train
images train labels test images test
labels and that's going to be returned
in our output append and you can see
here we did um images and labels set up
in there and it just loads them in there
so we'll have these four different
categories let me just go ahead and run
that
uh
so now we've gone ahead and loaded
everything on there
and then if you remember from before uh
we imported let me just go back up there
Shuffle here we go here's our sklearn
utilities import Shuffle and so we want
to take these labels and shuffle them
around a little bit just mix them up so
it's not having the same if you run the
same process over and over uh then you
might run into some problems on there
and just real quick let's go ahead and
do
a plot so we can just you know we've
looked at them as far as from outside of
our code we pulled up the files and I
showed you what that was going on we can
go ahead and just display them here too
and I tell you when you're working with
different people
this should be highlighted right here
um this thing is like when I'm working
on code and I'm looking at this data and
I'm trying to figure out what I'm doing
I skipped this process
the second I get into a meeting and I'm
showing what's going on to other people
I skip everything we just did so and go
right to here but we want to go ahead
and display some images and take a look
at it
and in this display I've taken them and
I've resized the images to 20 by 20.
[Music]
that's pretty small so we're going to
lose just a massive amount of detail and
you can see here these nice pixelated
images I might even just stick with the
folder showing them what images we're
processing
again this is you'll be a little careful
this
maybe resizing it was a bad idea in fact
let me try it without resizing it and
see what happens oops so I took out the
image size and then we put this straight
in here
one of the things again this is um
but the D there we go one of the things
again that we want to note
whenever we're working on these things
uh is the CV2
there are so many different uh image
classification setups it's really a
powerful package when you're doing
images
but you do need to switch it around so
that it works with the pi plot and so
make sure you take your numpy array and
change it to a u integer 8 format
because it comes in as a float otherwise
you'll get some weird images down there
and so this is just basically we've
split up or we've created a plot
we went ahead and did the plot 20 by 20
or
plot figure size is 20 by 20 and then
we're doing 25 so 5x5 subplot nothing
really going on here too exciting but
you can see here where we get the images
and really when you're showing people
what's going on this is what they want
to see so you skip over all the code and
you have your meeting you say okay
here's our images of the building
don't get caught up in how much work you
do get caught up in what they want to
see so if you want to work in data
science that's really important to know
and this is where we're going to start
having fun uh here's our model this is
where it gets exciting when you're
digging into these models
and you have here let me get
there we go
when you have here if you look here
here's our convolutional neural network
2D
and 2D is an image you have two
different dimensions x y and even though
there's three colors it's still
considered 2D if you're running a video
you'd be convolutional neural network 3D
if you're doing a series going across a
Time series it might be one D
and on these you need to go ahead and
have your convolutional neural network
if you look here there's a lot of really
cool settings going on to dig into we
have our input shape so everything's
been set to 150 by 150 and it has of
course three different color schemes in
it that's important to notice
activation
default is relu this is small amounts of
data being processed on a bunch of
little
neural networks
and right here is the 32 that's how many
of these convolutional neural networks
are being strung up on here
and then the three by three
when it's doing its steps it's actually
looking at a little three by three
Square on each image and so that's
what's going on here and with
convolutional neural networks the window
floats across and adds up all these
numbers going across on this data and
then eventually it comes up with a 30 in
this case 32 different feature options
that it's looking for and of course you
can change that 32 you can change the
three by three so you might have a
larger setup you know if you're going
across 150 by 150 that's a lot of steps
so we might run this as 15 by 15.
there's all kinds of different things
you can do here
we're just putting this together again
that would be something you would play
with to find out which ones are going to
work better on this setup and there's a
lot of play involved
that's really where it becomes an art
form is guessing at what that's going to
be the second part I mentioned earlier
and I can only begin to highlight this
when you get to these dense layers one
is the activation is a relu they use a
relu and a soft Max here
it's a whole a whole setup just
explaining why these are different
um
and how they're different because
there's also an exponential there's a
tangent in fact there's just a ton of
these and you can build your own custom
activations depending on what you're
doing
a lot of different things go into these
activations there are two or three major
thoughts on these activations and relu
and soft Max are uh
well relu
you're really looking at just the number
you're adding all the numbers together
and you're looking at euclidean geometry
ax plus b x 2 plus c x three plus bias
with soft Max this belongs to the party
of
um it's activated or it's not except
it's they call it soft Max because when
you get the the to zero instead of it
just being zero it's actually slightly
a little bit less than zero so that when
it trains it doesn't get lost
there's a whole series of these
activations another activation is the
tangent
where it just drops off and you have
like a very narrow area where you have
from minus one to one or exponential
which is zero to one so there's a lot of
different ways to do the activation
again we can do that would be a whole
separate lesson on here we're looking at
the convolutional neural network and
we're doing the two pools this is so
common you'll see two two convolutional
neural networks decked on top of each
other each with its own Max pull
underneath and let's go ahead and run
that so we've built our model there and
then we need to go ahead and
compile the model so let's go ahead and
do that
uh we are going to use the atom
Optimizer the bigger the data the atom
fits better on there there's some other
Optimizer but I think atom is a default
I don't really play with the optimizer
too much that's like the if once you get
a model that works really good you might
try some different optimizers but atoms
usually the most and then we're looking
at loss
pretty standard we want to minimize our
lot we want to
oh maximize the loss of error and then
we're going to look at accuracy
everybody likes theocracy I'm going to
tell you right now
I started talking to people and like
okay what's what's the loss on this and
that and as a data science yeah I want
to know how the lot what's going on with
that we'll show you why in a minute
but everybody wants to see accuracy we
want to know how accurate this is
and then we're going to run the fit and
I'm going to do this just so I can show
you
even though we're in Python setup in
here where Jupiter notebook is using
only a single processor I'm going to
bring over my little CPU tool this is
eight cores on 16 dedicated threads so
it shows up as 16 processors
and actually I got to run this and then
move it over so we're going to run this
and hopefully it doesn't destroy my mic
and as it comes in you can see it's
starting to do go through the epics and
we said I said it for five epics
and then this is really nice because
cross uses all the different threads
available
so it does a really good job of doing
that this is going to take a while if
you look at here it's uh
ETA 2 minutes and 25 seconds 24 seconds
so this is roughly two and a half
minutes per epic and we're doing five
epics so this is going to be done in
roughly 15 minutes
I don't know about you but I don't think
you want to sit here for 15 minutes
watching The Green bars go across so
we'll go ahead and let that run
and there we go uh there was our 15
minutes it's actually less than that uh
because I did when I went in here
realized that uh where was it
here we go here's our model compile
here's our model flip fit and here's our
epics so I did four epics so a little
bit better a little more like 10 to 11
minutes instead of uh doing the full
15. and when we look at this here's our
model we did we talked about the
compiler here's our history we're going
to history equals the model fit we'll go
into that in just a minute
and we're looking at is we have our
epics here's our validation split so as
we train it uh we're weighing the
accuracy versus you kind of pull some
data off to the side uh while you're
training it
and the reason we do that is that you
don't want to overfit and we'll look at
that chart in just a minute
uh here's back size
this is just how many images you're
sending through at a time the larger the
batch it actually increases the
processing speed and there's reasons to
go up or down on the batch size because
of the uh the the smaller the batch
there's a certain point where you get
two large of a batch and it's trying to
fit everything at once uh so yeah 128 is
kind of big depends on the computer
you're on what it can handle
and then of course we have our train
images and our train labels going in
telling you what we're going to train on
and then we look at our four epics here
here's our accuracy we want the accuracy
to go up and we get all the way up to
0.83 or 83 percent now this is actual
percentage based pretty much and we can
see over here our loss we want our loss
to go down really fluctuates 55
1.2.77.48
uh so we have a lot of things going on
there
let's go ahead and graph those
turn that up
and our team in the back did a wonderful
job of putting together this basic plot
set up here's our subplot coming in
we're going to be looking at um
from the history we're going to see that
the accuracy and the value accuracy
labels and set up on there and we're
going to also look at loss and value
loss so you can see what this looks like
what's really interesting about this
setup and let me let me just go ahead
and show you because without actually
seeing the plots it doesn't make a whole
lot of sense
it's just basic plotting of of the data
using the pi plot Library
and I want you to look at this this is
really interesting
um
when I ran this the first time I had
very different results
and they vary greatly and you can see
here our accuracy continues to climb
and there's a crossover here
put it in here right here's our
crossover
and I point that out because as we get
to the right of that crossover where our
accuracy and we're like oh yeah I got
0.8 percent we're starting to get an
overfit here that's what this this
switchover means
um as our value as a training set versus
a value accuracy stays the same and so
that this is the one we're actually
really want to be aware of and where it
crosses
that's kind of where you want to stop at
and we can see that also with the train
loss versus the value loss right here we
did one Epic and look how it just
flat lines right there with our loss
so really one Epic is probably enough
and you're going to say wow okay 0.8
percent
um certainly if I was working with the
shareholders
um telling them that it has an 80
accuracy isn't quite true and we'll look
at that a little deeper it really comes
out here that the accuracy of our actual
values is closer to point four one
percent right here even after running it
this number of times and so you really
want to stop right here at that
crossover one Epic would have been
enough so the data is a little
overfitted on this when we do four epics
foreign
there we are okay
my drawing won't go away
um let's see if I can get there we go
for some reason I've killed my drawing
ability and my recorder
all right took a couple extra clicks uh
so let's go ahead and take a look at our
actual test loss so you see where a
cross is over that's where I'm looking
at that's where we start overfitting the
model
and this is where if we were going to go
back and continually upgrade the model
we would start taking a look at the
images and start rotating them we might
start playing with the convolutional
neural network instead of doing the
three by three window we might expand
that or you know find different things
that might make a big difference as far
as the way it processes these things so
let's go ahead and take a look at our uh
our test loss and remember we had our
training data and then we're going to
look at our test images and our test
labels
for our test loss here and this is just
model evaluate just like we did fit up
here where was it
um one more model fit with our training
data going in now we're going to
evaluate it on the and and this data has
not been touched yet so this model has
never seen this data this is on uh
completely new information as far as the
model is concerned of course we already
know what it is from the labels we have
and this is what I was talking about
here's the actual accuracy right here
0.48 or 4847 so this 49 of the Time
guesses what the image is
uh and I mean really that's the bottom
dollar does this work for what you're
needing does 49 work do we need to
upgrade the model more
um in some cases this might be uh oh
what was I doing I was working on stock
evaluations and
we were looking at what stops were the
top performers well if I get that 50
correct on top performers uh I'm good
with that
um that's actually pretty good for stock
evaluation in fact the number I had for
stock was more like uh um 30 something
percent as far as being a top performer
stock much harder to predict but at that
point you're like well you'll make money
off of that so again this number right
here depends a lot on the domain you're
working on
and then we want to go ahead and bring
this home a little bit more as far as
looking at the different setup in here
and one of the from sklearn if you
remember actually let's go back to the
top we had the classification report and
this came in from our sklearn or Psy kit
setup and that's right here you can see
it right here on the um
see there we go
classification report right here
sklearnmetrics import classification
report this we're going to look at next
a lot of this stuff depends on who
you're working with
so when we start looking at precision
you know this is like for each value I
can't remember what 111 was probably
mountains so if 44 is not good enough if
you're doing like
um you're in the medical department and
you're doing cancer is it is this
cancerous or not and I'm only 44
accurate not a good deal you know I
would not go with that
um so it depends on what you're working
with on the different labels and what
they're used for Facebook
you know 44 I'm guessing the right
person I would hope it does a little bit
better than that
um but here's our main accuracy this is
what almost everybody looks at they say
oh 48 that's what's important
um again it depends on what domain
you're in and what you're working with
and now we're going to do the same model
oops somehow I got my there it goes I
thought I was gonna get stuck on there
again uh this time we're going to be
using the vdg 16 and remember this one
is uh all those layers
going into it so it's basically a bunch
of convolutional neural networks getting
smaller and smaller on here and so we
need to go ahead and um import all our
different stuff from Karas we're
importing the main one is the V
g16 setup on there and just aim that
there we go
um
there's kind of a pre-processing images
applications pre-process input this is
all part of the VG g16 setup on there
and once we have all those we need to go
ahead
and create our model
and we're just going to create a vgg16
model in here inputs model inputs
outputs model inputs I'm not going to
spend as much time as they did on the
other one we're going to go through it
really quickly one of the first things I
would do is if you remember in Cross you
can trade create a model like you would
a layer
and so at this point I would probably
add a lot of dense layers on after the
vgg 16 model and create a new model with
all of those things in there and we'll
go ahead and run this because here's our
model coming in and our setup
and I'll take it just a moment to
compile that what's funny about this is
I'm waiting for it to download the
package since I pre-ran this
um it takes it a couple minutes to
download the vgg 16 model into here
um and so we want to go ahead and train
features for the model we're going to
predict that we're going to predict the
train images and we're going to test
features on the predict test images on
here
and then I told you I was going to
create another model 2 and the people in
the back did not disappoint me they went
ahead and did just that
and this is really an important part
this is worth stopping for I told you I
was going to go through this really
quick
so here's our uh
we at we have our model 2
coming in and we've created a model up
here with the vgg16 model equals model
inputs model inputs and so we have our
vgg16 this has already been
pre-programmed uh and then we come down
here and I want you to notice on this
right here layered model two layers
minus four to One X layer X
um
we're basically taking this model and
we're adding stuff onto it and so uh
we've taken we've just basically
duplicated this model we could have done
the same thing by using model up here as
a layer we could have the input go to
this model
and then have that go down here so we've
added on this whole setup this whole
block of code from 13 to 17 has been
added on to our vgg16 model and we have
a new model uh with the layer my input
and X down here
let's go ahead and run that and compile
it and that was a lot to go through
right there when you're building these
models this is the part that gets so
complicated
did you get stuck playing in and yet
it's so fun uh it's like a puzzle how
can I Loop these models together
and in this case you can see right here
that the layers we're just copying
layers over and adding each layer in
this is one way to build a new model
and we'll go ahead and run that
like I said the other way is you can
actually use the model as a layer I've
had a little trouble playing with it
sometimes when you're using the Straight
model over
you run into issues um
and it seems like it's going to work and
then you mess up on the input and the
output layers there's all kinds of
things that come up
let's go ahead and do the new model
we're going to compile it again here's
our metrics accuracy sparse categorical
loss pretty straightforward just like we
did before you got to compile the model
and just like before we're going to take
our create a history on the history is
going to be a new model fit train 128
and just like before if you remember
when we started running this stuff we're
going to have to go ahead and it's going
to light up our setup on here and this
is going to take a little bit to get us
all set up it's not going to just happen
in a couple minutes so let me go ahead
and pause the video and run it and then
we'll talk about what happened
okay now when I ran that these actually
took about six minutes each
um so it's a good thing I put it on hold
we did four epics I actually had this
topic says at 10 and switch it to four
because I didn't want to wait an hour
and you can see here our accuracy
um and our loss numbers going down and
just at a glance
it actually performed if you look at the
accuracy
0.2658 so our accuracy is going down or
you know 26 percent
34 35 percent and you can see here at
some point it just kind of kicks the
bucket again this is overfitting
that's always an issue when you're
running on uh programming these
different neural networks
then we're going to go ahead and plot
the accuracy history we built that nice
little subroutine up above so we might
as well use it and you can see it right
here
there's that crossover again
and if you look at this look how the how
the the red shifts up how the uh our
loss functions and everything crosses
over we're over fitting after one Epic
we're clearly
not helping the problem or doing better
we're just going to it's just gonna
Baseline this one actually shows with
the training versus the loss
value loss maybe second epic so on here
we're now talking more between the first
and the second epic and that also shows
kind of here so somewhere in here it
starts over fitting
and right about now you should be saying
oh uh something went wrong there I
thought that when we went up here and
ran this
look at this we have the accuracy up
here is hitting that 48 percent
and we're down here
um
you know you look at the score down here
that looks closer to 20 percent not
nearly anywhere in the ballpark of what
we're looking for and we'll go ahead and
run it through the uh the actual test
features here and and there it is
um we actually run this on the Unseen
data and everything
0.18 or 18 percent
um I don't know about two but I wouldn't
want you know at 18 this did a lot worse
than the other one
I thought this was supposed to be the
supermodel the model that beats all
models the vgg16 that won the awards and
everything well the reason is is that
um one we're not pre-processing the data
so it needs to be more there needs to be
more
um as far as like rotating the data at
you know 45 degree angle taking partials
of it so you can create a lot more data
to go through here and that would
actually greatly change the outcome on
here and then we went up here we only
added a couple dense layers uh we added
a couple convolutional neural networks
this huge pre-trained setup is looking
for a lot more information coming in as
far as how it's going to train and so
this is one of those things where I
thought it would have done better and I
had to go back and research it and look
at it and say why didn't this work why
am I getting only uh 18 here instead of
44 or better
and that would be wise it doesn't have
enough training data coming in and again
you can make your own training data so
it's not that we have a shortage of data
it's that that some of that has to be
switched around and moved around a
little bit
and this is interesting right here too
if you look at the Precision
we're getting it on number two and yet
we had zero on everything else so for
some reason is not seeing the different
variables in here so it'd be something
else to look in and try to track down
um
and that probably has to do with the
input but you can see right here we have
a really good solid 0.48 up here and
that's where I'd really go with is
starting with this model and then we
look at this model and find out why are
these numbers not coming up better is it
the data coming in where is the setup on
there
and that is the art of data science
right there is finding out which models
work better and why
so if you want to see
an aspect to be a part of
cut and service Bots using deep learning
are Caltech postage program in Ai and
machine learning provides comprehensive
coverage of the latest tools and
Technologies within the AI ecosystem
it offers master classes led by esteem
Caltech faculty and IBM experts engaging
hackathons and interactive ask me
anything sessions by enrolling in this
program delivered in partnership with
IBM you will gain the expertise needed
to become a professional in a and ml
this comprehensive artificial
intelligence course will equip you with
the knowledge about various AI based
Technologies empowering you to excel in
this field so do check out the course
Link in the description for more details
let's get started now
now let's talk about our first deep
learning project
we have image classification using the
c410 data set
now this data set was created by the
Canadian Institute for advanced research
the CIFA 10 data set contains 60 032
crores 32 color images in 10 different
classes the 10 different classes are
airplanes cars Birds cats deer and
others which you can see on the screen
there are 6000 images of each class now
there are 50 000 training images and 10
000 test images you can build a
convolutional neural network model using
the Keras library to classify each image
into a category
so it is more of an image recognition
kind of a project that is recommended
for beginners who are new to deep
learning the next project in our list is
brain tumor detection
such projects are heavily used in the
healthcare Industries for detecting
diseases before they occur brain tumors
are the consequence of abnormal growths
and uncontrolled cell division in the
brain
they can lead to death if they are not
detected early and accurately
brain tumors can be classified into two
types benign and malignant
deep learning can help Radiologists in
tumor Diagnostics without invasive
measures
a deep learning algorithm that has
achieved significant results in image
segmentation and classification is the
convolutional neural network
it can be used to detect a tumor through
brain using magnetic resonance imaging
or MRI
image pixels are First Fed as input to
the CNN softmax fully connected layers
are used to classify the images
the accuracy of the convolutional neural
network can be obtained with the radial
basis function classifier
next we have Anna chatbot
now this chatbot is the world's first
open source conversation platform which
comes with a graphical chart flow
designer and chat simulator
its supported channels of web chat
Android iOS and Facebook Messenger
the Anna chat board is available to
answer your questions 24 hours a day 365
days a year Anna is free for personal
and commercial use with the Anna Studio
server simulator and SDK which is
software development kit your
development time is cut from days to
hours
you can create chat Bots to suit your
needs
chat Bots play an important role in
customer support for an e-commerce
website
you can share real-time order and
shipping updates personalized product
recommendations and targeted offers
within the conversation
similarly automobile Brands showrooms
and service centers can use a chatbot
for lead generation scheduling test
drives and roadside assistance
you can check the GitHub repository
that's on the screen to know more about
working on this project
the next project we have in deep
learning is image captioning
now image captioning is the process of
generating textual description of an
image it uses both methods from computer
vision to understand the content of the
image and a language model from the
field of natural language processing to
turn the understanding of the image into
words in the right order
Microsoft has built its own caption bot
where you can upload an image or the URL
of an image and it will display the
textual description of the image on the
screen you can see we have the picture
of Elon Musk and the caption bot has
generated a description that says I
think it's Elon Musk wearing a suit and
a tie and he seems
it ends with an emoticon
another such application that suggests a
perfect caption and best hashtags for a
picture is caption AI automatic image
caption generation software can be built
using recurrent neural networks and long
sorter memory networks or lstms
now we have image colorization as our
next project
image colorization has seen significant
advancements using deep learning
image colorization is the process of
taking an input of a grayscale image and
then producing an output of a colored
image or a colorized image
colorization is a highly undetermined
problem that requires mapping a real
valued luminance image to a
three-dimensional colored value one that
has not a unique solution
chroma Gan is an example of a picture
colorization model
a generative network is framed in an
adversarial model that learns to
colorize by incorporating perceptual and
semantic understanding of color and
class distributions
the model is trained using a fully
supervised strategy if you want to
implement chroma Gan check the GitHub
link that's on the screen below next in
our list of projects we have open nmt
machine translation open nmt is an open
source ecosystem for neural machine
translation a neural sequence learning
it started in December 2016 by the
Harvard NLP group and systran the
project has since been used in several
research and Industry applications
neural machine translation or nmt is a
new methodology for machine translation
that has led to significant improvements
particularly in terms of human
evaluation compared to rule based and
statistical machine translation systems
open nmt provides implementations in two
popular deep learning Frameworks Pi
torch and tensorflow
please feel free to refer to the below
GitHub link to learn more about neural
machine translation
now we have music generation
using deep learning it is possible for a
machine to learn the notes structures
and patterns of Music and start
producing music automatically music 21
is a python toolkit used for
computer-aided musicology
it allows us to teach the fundamentals
of Music Theory generate music examples
and study music the toolkit provides a
simple interface to acquire the music
notation of MIDI files
which stands for musical instrument
digital interface
using webenet architecture and long
short term memory networks you can
generate music without human
intervention
Amper music mubert and Duke deck produce
smart music powered by Deep learning
algorithms
then we have alphago
now alphago was created by Google
deepmind and is the first computer
program to defeat a professional human
go player alphago's algorithm uses a
combination of machine learning and
research techniques combined with
extensive training both from human and
computer play it uses Monte Carlo
research Guided by a value Network and a
policy Network both implemented using
deep neural network technology alphago
was initially trained to mimic human
play by attempting to match the moves of
expert players from recorded historical
games
it was done using a database of around
30 million moves once it had reached a
certain degree of proficiency by being
set to play large number of games
against other instances of itself using
reinforcement learning to improve its
play next in our list of projects we
have deep dream deep dream is a computer
vision program which uses a
convolutional neural network to find and
enhance patterns in images via
algorithmic paradolia it then creates a
dream like hallucinogenic appearance
in the over processed images
deep dream is an experiment that
visualizes the patterns learned by a
neural network
similar to when a child watches clouds
and interprets and tries to interpret
random shapes deep dream over interprets
and enhances the patterns it sees in an
image
do check the given GitHub link to
install dependencies listed in the
notebook and play with the code locally
then we have deep voice deep voice was
developed by Baidu which is an AI system
that can clone an individual's voice
the train model takes just 3 seconds to
replicate the output of a person's voice
deep voice 3 is a fully convolutional
attention based neural text to speech
system that converts text to
spectrograms or other acoustic
parameters to be used with an audio
waveform synthesis method below you can
find the GitHub link for pytorch
implementation of convolutional networks
based text to speech synthesis models
now we have IBM Watson IBM Watson helps
run machine learning models anywhere
across any Cloud using IBM Watson
machine learning you can build
analytical models and neural networks
trained with your own data that you can
deploy for use in applications
with its open extensible model operation
Watson machine learning helps businesses
simplify and harness AI at scale across
any cloud
it is used in healthcare teaching
assistant chatbot as well as for weather
forecasting
and finally in our list of deep learning
projects we have the YOLO real-time
object detection
you only look once or YOLO is a
state-of-the-art real-time object
detection system it frames object
detection in images as a regression
problem to spatially separated bounding
boxes and Associated class probabilities
using this approach a single neural
network divides the image into regions
and predicts bounding boxes and
probabilities for each region the neural
network predicts bounding boxes and
class probabilities directly from full
images in one evaluation the base YOLO
model processes images in real time at
45 frames per second
you can use the Coco data set and
tensorflow library to train and test the
model
to learn more about YOLO object
detection check the GitHub link that's
shown on the screen below
so if you want to see expertise in deep
learning skills and aspect to be a part
of Cutting Edge field of building
chatbots and service Bots using deep
learning are Caltech postage program in
Ai and machine learning provides
comprehensive coverage of the latest
tools and Technologies within the AI
ecosystem
it offers master classes led by esteemed
Caltech faculty and IBM experts engaging
hackathons and interactive ask me
anything sessions by enrolling in this
program delivered in partnership with
IBM you will gain the expertise needed
to become a professional in a and ml
this comprehensive artificial
intelligence course will equip you with
the knowledge about various AI based
Technologies empowering you to excel in
this field so do check out the course
Link in the description for more details
let's get started now
deep learning interview questions and
we're going to go from the very basics
of neural networks and deep learning
into some of the more commonly used
models so you can have an understanding
of what kind of questions are going to
come up and what you need to know in
interview questions we'll start with a
very general concept of what is deep
learning this is where we take large
volumes of data in this case on cats and
dogs or whatever A lot of times you use
a training setup to train your model
remember it's kind of like a magic Black
Box going on there then we use that to
extract features or extract information
and in this case classify the image of a
cat and a dog so the primary takeaway
we're talking about deep learning is it
learns from large volumes of structured
and even unstructured data and uses
complex algorithms to train neural
network it also performs complex
operations to extract hidden patterns
and features and if we're going to
discuss deep learning in this very
simplified overview and we also have to
go over what is a neural network this is
a common image you'll see of a drawing
of a forward propagation neural network
and it's it's human brain inspired
system which replicate the way humans
learn so this has inspired how our own
neurons and our brain fire but at a much
simplified level obviously it's not
ready to take over the human uh
population and and be our leader yet not
for many years it's very much in its
infant stage but it's inspired by how
our brains work and they use a lot of
other Inspirations you can study brains
of moths and other animals that they've
used to figure out how to improve these
neural networks the most common one
consists of three layers of network and
this is generally how you view these
networks is you have an input you have a
hidden layer and an output and the
neural network is broken up into many
pieces but we focus just on the neural
network it's always on the hidden layers
that we're making all the adjustments
and figuring out how to best set up
those hidden layers for their functions
to both train faster and to function
better when we look at this of course we
have our input hidden in output each
layer contains neuron ones called as
nodes that perform various operations
and you can see here we have the list of
the nodes we have both our input nodes
and our output nodes and then our hidden
layer notes and it's used in deep
learning algorithm like CNN rnngan
Etc we'll address some of these models a
little closer at least the most common
models as we go down the list and we
study the Deep learning and the neural
network framework let's start with what
is a multi-layer precipitron or MLP a
lot of time is it referred to and you'll
see these abbreviations I'll be honest I
have to write them down on a piece of
paper and go through them because I
never remember what they all mean even
though I play with them all the time
what is a multi-layer precipitron well
if you look at the image on the right
it's very similar to what we just looked
at you have your input layer your hidden
layer and your output layer and that's
exactly what this is it has the same
structure of a single layer precipitron
with one or more hidden layers except
the input layer each node in the other
layers uses a non-linear activation
function what that means is your input
layer is your data coming in and then
your activation function is based upon
all those nodes and weights being added
together and then it has the output MLP
uses supervised learning method called
back propagation for training the model
very key word there is back propagation
single layer precipitron can classify
only linear reciprocals with binary
output 0 1 but the MLP can classify by
non-linear classes so let's break this
down just a little bit the multi-layer
precipitron with an input layer and a
hidden layer and an output layer as you
see that it comes in there it has adds
up all the numbers and weights depending
on how your setup is it then goes to the
next layer that then goes to the next
hidden layer if you have multiple hidden
layers and finally to the output layer
the back propagation takes the error
that it sees so whatever the output is
it says hey this has an error to it it's
wrong and it sends that error backwards
from where it came from and there's a
lot of different functions used to train
this based on that error and how that
error goes backwards in the notes so
forward is you get your answers back
where it is for training you see this
every day even my Google pixel phone has
this it they train the neural network
which takes a lot more data to train
than it does to use and then they load
up that neural network into in this case
I have a pixel 2 which actually has a
built-in neural network for processing
pictures and so it's just a forward
propagation I I use when it processes my
photos but when they were training it
you use the back propagation to train it
with the errors they had we'll be coming
back to different models that are used
for right now though multi-layer
precipitron MLP put that down as your
vocabulary word and of course back
propagation what is data normalization
and why do we need it this is so
important we spend so much time in
normalizing our data and getting our
data clean and setting it up so we talk
about data there's a pre-processing step
to standardize the data so whatever we
have coming in we don't want it to be a
you know one gigabyte file here a two
gigabyte picture here and a three
kilobyte text there even as a human I
can't process those all in the same
group I have to reformat them in some
way that Loops them together so the
standardized format we use this data
normalization in pre-processing to
reduce it and eliminate data redundancy
a lot of times the data comes in and you
end up with two of the same images or uh
the same information in different
formats then we want to rescale values
to fit into a particular range for
achieving better convergence what this
means is with most neural networks they
form a bias we've seen this in recently
in attacks on neural networks where they
light up one pixel or one piece of the
view and it skews the whole answer so
suddenly because one pixel is really
bright it doesn't know what to do well
when we start rescaling it we put all
the values between say minus one and one
and we change them and refit them to
those values it helps get rid of that
bias helps fix for some of those
problems and then finally we restructure
the data and improve the Integrity we
want to make sure that we're not missing
values or we don't have partial data
coming in one way to look at this is bad
data in bad data out so we want clean
data in and you want good answers coming
out one of the most basic models used is
a boltzmann machine so let's address
what is a boltzmann machine and if you
know we just did the m MLP multi-layer
precipitron so now we're going to come
into almost a simplified version of that
and in this we have our visible input
layer and we have our hidden layer the
boltzmann machines are almost always
shallow they're usually just two layer
neural Nets that make stochastic
decisions whether a neuron should be on
or off true false yes no first layer is
a visible layer and second layer is the
hidden layer nodes are connected to each
other across layers but no two nodes are
the same layer connected hence it is
also known as restricted boltzmann
machine now that we've covered a basic
MLP or multi-layer precipitron and we've
gone over the boltzmann machine also
known as the restricted boltzmann
machine let's talk a little bit about
activation formulas and this is a huge
topic that can get really complicated
but it also is automated so it's very
simple so you have both a complicated
and a simple at the same time so what is
the role of activation functions in a
neural network activation function
decides whether a neuron should be fire
or not that's the most basic one and
that actually changes a little bit
because it's either weather fired or not
in this case activation function or what
value should come out when it's fired
but in these models we're looking at
just the boltzmann restricted layers so
this is what causes them to fire either
they don't or they do it's a yes or no
true false All or Nothing it accepts a
weighted sum of the inputs the bias as
input to any activation function so
whatever activation function is it needs
to have the sum of the weights times the
input so each input if you remember on
that model and let's just go back to
that model real quick and then you
always have to add a bias and you can
look at the bias if you remember from
your euclidean geometry you draw a
straight line formula for that line has
a y coordinate at the end it's always c
x plus M or something like that where m
is where it crosses the Y coordinates if
you're doing a straight line with these
weights it's very similar but a lot of
times we just add it in as its own
weight we take it as a no code of a one
value coming in and then we compute its
new weight and that's how we compute
that bias just like we compute all the
other weights coming in the node which
gets fires depends on the Y value and
then we have a step function and the
step function this is where I remember I
said is going to get complicated and
simple all at the same time we have a
lot of different step functions we have
the sigmoid function we have just a
standard step function we have the relu
it's pronounced like Ray the ray from
the Sun and Lou like a name so relu
function and we have the tangent H
function and if you look at these they
all have something similar they all
either force it to be one value or the
other they force it to be in the case of
the first three is zero or one and in
the last one it's either a minus one or
a one and you can easily convert that to
a zero one yes no true false and on this
one of the most common ones is the step
function itself because there is no
middle value there is no discrepancy
that says well I'm not quite sure but as
you get into different models probably
the most commonly used used to be the
sigmoid was most commonly used but I see
the relu used more often really
depending on what you're doing you just
have to play with these and find out
which one works best depending on the
data and your output the reason to have
a non-zero one answer or something kind
of in the middle is when you're looking
at this and it's coming out you can
actually process that middle ground as
part of the answer into another neural
network so it might be that the relu
function says hey this is only a 0.6 not
a one and even though the one is what's
going into the next neural network or
the next hidden layer as an input the
0.6 value might also be going in there
to let you know hey this is not a
straight up one or straight up zero
someplace in the middle this is a little
uncertain what's coming out here so it's
a very powerful tool open the basic
neural network you usually just use the
step function it's yes or no let's take
a a big step back and take a kind of an
overview the next function is what is a
cost function that we're going to cover
this is so important because this is
your end result that you're going to do
over and over again and use to decide
whether the model is working or not
whether you need to try a different step
function whether you need to try a
different activation whether you need to
try a fully different model used so what
is the cost function cost function is a
measure to evaluate how good your
model's performance is it is also
referred as loss or error used to
compute the error of the output layer
during back propagation there's our back
propagation where we're training our
model that's one of our keywords mean
squared error is an example of a popular
cost function and so here we have the
cost function C equals half of Y minus y
predicted and then you square that so
the first thing is you know real quick
if you haven't done statistics this is
not a percentage it's not a percentage
of how accurate it is it's just a
measurement of the error and we take
that error if we're training it we push
that error backwards through the neural
network and we use that through the
different training functions depending
on what model you're using to train the
neural network so when you deploy the
network you're usually done training it
because it takes a lot of computational
force to train it this is a very simple
model and so you deploy the trained one
but we want to know how your error is
and so how do we do that well you split
your data part of your data is for
trading and part of your data is for
testing and then we can also test the
error on there so it's very important
and then we're going to go one more step
on this we've got to look at both the
local and the global setup it might work
great to test your data on what you have
on your computer but that's different
than in the field so when we're talking
about all these different tests in the
error test as far as your loss you don't
you want to make sure that you're in a
closed environment when you do initial
testing but you also want to open that
up and make sure you follow up with the
testing on the larger scale of data
because it will change it might not fit
the larger scale there might be
something in there in the way you
brought the data in specifically or the
data group you used or any of those
could cause an error here so it's very
important to remember that we're looking
at both the local and the global context
of our error and just one other side
note on a lot of the newer models of
neural networks by comparing the error
we get on the data our training data
with a portion of the test data we can
actually figure out how good the model
is whether it's overfitted or not we'll
go into that a little bit more as we go
into some of the different models so we
have our output we're able to figure out
the error on it based on the Square
means usually although there's other
functions used so we want to talk about
what is gradient descent another
vocabulary word gradient descent is an
optimization algorithm to minimize the
cost function or to minimize the error
aim is to find the local or Global
Minima of a function determine the
direction the model should take to
reduce the error so as we're looking at
this we have our squared error that we
just figured out the cop based on the
cost function it says how bad is my
model fitting the data I just put
through it and then we want to read do
set error so how do you figure out what
direction to do that in well it could be
that you're looking at just that line of
that line of data coming in so that
would be a local Minima we want to know
the error of that particular setup
coming in and then you have your Global
your Global Minima we want to minimize
it based on the overall data we're
putting through it and with this we can
figure out the global minimum cost we
want to take all those local minimum
costs of each piece of data coming in
and figure out the global one how are we
going to adjust this model to fit all
the data we don't want it to be biased
just on three or four lines of data
coming in we want it to kind of
extrapolate a general answer for all the
data coming in at this of course we
mentioned it briefly about back
propagation this is where it really
comes in handy is training our model
neural network technique to minimize the
cost function helps to improve the
performance of the network back
propagates the error and updates the
weights to reduce the error so as you
can see here is a very nice depiction of
a back propagation we we have our
predicted y coming out and then we have
since it's a training set we already
know the answer and the answer comes
back and based on case of the square
means was one of the functions we looked
at one of the activation functions based
on cost function that cost function then
depending on what you choose for your
back propagation method and there's a
number of them we'll change the weights
it will change the weight going to each
of the one of those nodes in the hidden
layer and then based upon the error
that's still being carried back it'll
change the weights going to the next
hidden layer and then it computes an
error level on that and sends that back
up and you're going to say well if it
computes the error into the first hidden
layer and fixes it why would it stop
there well remember we don't want to
create a biased neural network so we
only make small adjustments on these
weights we don't make a big adjustment
that changes everything right off the
bat so no matter how far back you go
you're always going to have a small
amount of error and that's still going
to continue to go all the way back up
the hidden layers for right now focus on
the back propagation is taking that
error and moving it backwards on the
neural network to change the weights and
help program it so that it'll have the
correct answers so far we've been
talking about forward propagation neural
networks everything goes forwards goes
left to right but let's let's take a
little detour and let's see what is the
difference between a feed forward neural
network and a recurrent neural network
now this is in the function not when
we're training it using the back
propagation so you've got new
information coming in and you want to
get the answer and there's a couple
different networks out there we want to
know we have a feed forward neural
network and we have a new vocabulary
term recurrent neural network a feed
forward neural network signals travel in
one direction from input to Output no
feedback loops considers only the
current input cannot memorize previous
inputs one example of one of these feed
forward neural networks and we've
covered a number of them but one of the
ones that has a big highlight nowadays
is the CNN a convolutional neural
network tensorflow the and put out by
Google is probably most known for their
CNN where the information goes forward
it first takes a picture splits it apart
goes through the individual pixels on
the picture so it picks up a different
reading then calculates based on that
and goes into a regular feed forward
neural network and then gives your
categorization on there now we're not
covering the CNN today but we do have a
video out that you can look up on
YouTube put out by simply learn the
convolutional neural network wonderful
tutorial check that out and learn a lot
more about the convolutional neural
network but you do need to know that the
CNN is a forward propagation neural
network only so it's only moving in One
Direction so we will look at a recurrent
neural network signals travel in both
directions making it a looped Network
considers the current input along with
the previous received inputs for
generating the output of a layer has the
ability to memorize past data due to its
internal memory and you can see they
have a nice image here we have our input
and for some reason they always do the a
current neural network in Reverse from
bottom up in the images kind of a
standard although I'm not sure why your
X goes into your hidden layer and your
hidden layer the answer for part of the
answer from that it generates feeds back
into the hidden layer so now you have an
input of both X and part of the Hidden
layer and then that feeds into your
output now if we go back to the forward
let me just go back a slide and we're
looking at our forward propagation
Network one of the tricks you can do to
use just a forward propagation network
is if you're in a what they call a Time
sequence that's a good term to remember
or a Time series meaning that a
sequential data each term comes after
the other you can trick this by creating
your input nodes as with the history so
if you know that you have values 1 5 and
7 going in and you know what the output
is from one what those outputs are you
can expand the input to include the
history input that's one of the ways to
trick a forward propagation Network into
looking at that but when you deal with
recurrent neural network you let the
hidden layer do that for you it sends
that data and reprocesses it back into
itself what are some of the applications
of recurrent neural network the RNN can
be used for sentiment analysis and text
mining getting up early in the morning
is good for health and it's a positive
sentiment one of the catches you really
want to look at this when you're looking
at the language is that I could switch
this around and totally negate the
meaning of what I'm doing so no longer
be positive so when you're looking at a
sentence knowing the order of the words
is as important as the meaning of the
words you can't just count how many good
words there are versus bad words to get
a positive sentiment you now have to
know what they're addressing and there's
lots of other different uses kids are
playing football or soccer as we call it
in the U.S RN can help you capture an
image So based on previous information
coming in it refeeds that back in and
you have a image Setter and then time
series problems like predicting the
prices of stocks in a month or quarter
or sell a product X can be solved using
an RNN and this is a really good example
you have whatever your stocks were doing
earlier this month will have a huge
effect on what they're doing today if
you're investing so having an RNN Model
A recurrent neural network feeding into
itself was happening previously allows
it to take that model and program in
that whole series without having to put
in the whole a month at a time of data
you can only put in one day at a time
but if you keep them in order it will
look back and say oh this because of
what happened yesterday I need some
information from that and I'm going to
use that to help predict today's and so
on and so on we're going to go back to
our activation functions remember I told
you Rayleigh was one of the most common
functions used so let's talk a little
bit more about relu and also softmax
softmax is an activation function that
generates the output between 0 and 1. it
divides each output such that the total
sum of the outputs is equal to one it is
often used in the output layers softmax
L of the N equals e to L on the N over
the absolute value of e to the L so what
is this function mean I mean what is
actually going on here so we have our
output nodes and our output nodes are
giving us let's say they give us 1.2.9
and 0.4 as a human being I look at that
and I say well the greatest value is 1.2
so whatever category that is if you have
three different categories maybe you're
not just doing if it's a cat or it's a
dog or oh let's say it's a cow maybe we
had cats and dogs earlier why the cats
and dogs are hanging out with a cow I
don't know but we have a value and it
might say 1.2 is a cat 0.9 is the dog
and 0.4 is a cow for some reason it
thinks that there's a chance of it being
any one of these three items and that's
how it comes out of the output layer
well as a human I can look at 1.2 and
say this is definitely what it is it's
definitely a cat or whatever it is Maybe
different kinds of cars might be a
bidder whether it's a car truck or a
motorcycle maybe that'd be a better
example well from a computer standpoint
that might be a little confusing because
they're just numbers waving at us and so
with the soft Max we want all those
numbers to always add up to one so when
I add three numbers together I want the
final output to be one on there and so
it goes through this formula changes
each of these numbers in this case it
changes them to 0.46 0.34 and 0.20 they
all add up to one and that's a lot
easier to register because it's very set
it's a set output it's never going to be
more than one it's never going to be
less than zero and so you can see here
that there's probably a pretty high
chance that it's the first one so you're
as a human being we have no problem
knowing that but this output can then
also go into say another input so it
might be an automated car that's picking
up images and it says that image in
front of us is probably a big truck we
should deal with it like it's a big
truck it's probably not a motorcycle or
whatever those categories are that's the
soft Max part of it but now we have the
relu well what where's the railu coming
from well the railu is what's generating
the 1.2 and the 0.9 and the 0.4 and so
if you remember our relu stands for
rectified linear unit and is the most
widely used activation function we
looked at a number of different
activation functions including tangent
age the step function remember I said
the step function is really used if
that's what your actual output is
because then you know it's a zero or one
but the relu if you have that as your
output you now have a discrepancy in
there and if that's going into another
neural network or another process having
that discrepancy is really important and
it gives an output of x if x is positive
and zero otherwise so it says my x value
is going to be somewhere between 0 or 1
and then the usually unless it's really
uncertain the output is usually a one or
zero and then you have that little piece
of uncertainty there that you can send
forward to another Network where you can
look at to know that there's uncertainty
involved and is often used in the hidden
layers this is what's coming out of the
Hidden layers into the output layer
usually or as we reference the
convolutional neural network the CNN
you'd have to go to another video to
review the relu is the most common used
for convolutional part of that Network
it has a bunch of little pieces that are
very simplified looking at all the
different images or different sections
of the map and the Rayleigh works really
good for that like I said there's other
formulas used but that this is the most
common one and you'll see that in the
hidden layers going maybe between one
layer and the next layer so just a quick
recap we have our soft Max which means
that if you have numerous categories
only one of them is going to be picked
but you also want to have some value
attached to it how well it picked it and
you put that between 0 and 1 so it's
very standardized so we have our soft
Max we looked at that let's go back one
we looked at that here where it
transforms the numbers and then we have
our relu function which takes the
information and the summation and puts
it between a zero and a one where it's
either clearly a zero or pending on how
confident our model is it'll go between
the zero and one value what are hyper
parameters well this is a great
interview question hyper parameters when
you are doing neural networks this is
what you're playing with most the time
once you've gotten the data formatted
correctly a hyper parameter is a
parameter whose value is set before the
learning process begins determines how a
network is trained and the structure of
the network this includes things like
the number of hidden units how many
hidden layers are you going to have and
how many nodes in each layer learning
rate learning rate is usually multiplied
once you've figured out the error and
how much you want to change the weights
we talked about or I mentioned it
earlier just briefly you don't want to
just make a huge change otherwise you're
going to have a biased model so you only
take some little incremental changes and
that's what the learning rate is is a
small incremental changes epics how many
times are you going to go through all
the data in your training set so one
Epic is one trip through all the data
and there's a lot of other things
depending on which model you're working
with and which programming scripture
working with like the python sklearn
package will have a slightly different
than say Google's tensorflow package
which will be a little bit different
than the spark machine learning package
so these are just some examples of the
hyper parameters and so you see in here
we have a nice image of our data coming
in and we train our model then we do a
comparison to see how good our model is
and then we go back and we say hey this
this model is pretty good but it's
biased so and we send it back and we
change our hyper parameters to see if we
can get an unbiased model or we can have
a better prediction on it that matches
our data closer what will happen if
learning rate is set too low or too high
we have a nice couple graphs here we
have one over here is a learning rate
set two load you can see that it slowly
Works its way down the curve and on the
right you can see a learning rate set
too high it's just bouncing back and
forth when your learning rate is too low
so we studied two slides over this what
the learning rate was training of the
model will progress very slowly as we
are making very tiny updates to the
weights we'll take many updates before
reaching the minimum point so I just
mentioned epic going through all the
data might have to go through all the
data a thousand times instead of 500
times for it to train learning rate too
high causes undesirable Divergent
Behavior to the loss function due to
drastic updates and weights at times it
may fail to converge or even diverge so
if you have your learning rate set too
high and it's training too quickly maybe
you'll get lucky and it trains after one
epic run but a lot of times it might
never be able to train because the
weights are changing too fast they flip
back and forth too easy and you see down
here we've introduced two new terms
converge and diverge a converge means
that our model has reached a point where
it's able to give a fairly good answer
for all the data we put in all those
weights have adjusted and has minimized
the error diverge means that the data is
so chaotic that it can never manage to
to train to that data the data is just
too chaotic for it to train so we have
two new words there converge and diverge
are important to know also one what is
drop out and batch normalization Dropout
is a technique of dropping out hidden
and visible units of a network randomly
to prevent overfitting of data it
doubles the number of iterations needed
to converge the network so here we have
our standard neural network and then
after applying Dropout now it doesn't
mean we actually delete the node the
node is still there and we're still
going to use that note what it means is
that we're only going to work with a few
of the nodes a lot of times I think the
most common one right now used is 20
percent so you'll drop out 20 percent of
the nodes when you do your training you
reverse propagate your data and then
you'll randomly pick another 20 nodes
the next time you go through an epic
data training so each time you go
through one Epic you will randomly pick
20 of those nodes not to not to mess
with and this allows for less
overfitting of the data so by randomly
doing this you create some I guess it
just kind of pulls some nodes off to the
sides it says we're going to handle the
data later on so we don't over fit batch
normalization is the technique to
improve the performance and stability of
neural network the idea is to normalize
the inputs in every layer so that they
have mean output and activation of zero
and standard deviation of one this
question covers a lot of different
things which is great it's a great
interview question because it pulls in
that you have to understand what the
mean value is so a mean output
activation of zero that means our
average activation is zero so when you
normalize it remember usually we're
going between
-1 and 1 on a lot of these it's a very
standard setup so you have to be very
aware that this is your mean output
activation of zero and then we have our
standard deviation of one so we want to
keep our error down to just a one value
the benefits of this doing a batch
normalization is it provides
regularization it trains faster Higher
Learning rates and weights are easier to
initialize what is the difference
between batch gradient descent and
stochastic gradient descent batch
gradient descent batch gradient computes
the gradient using the the entire data
set it takes time to converge because
the volume of data is huge and weights
update slowly so you can look at the
batches a lot of times if you're using
big data batch the data in but you still
go through a full epic you still go
through all the data on there so bash
gradient descent means you're going to
use it to fit all the data and look for
convergence there stochastic gradient
descent stochastic gradient computes the
gradient using a single sample it
converges much faster than batch
gradient because it updates weight more
frequently explain overfitting and
underfitting and how to combat them
overfitting happens when a model learns
the details and noise and the training
data to the degree that it adversely
impacts the execution of the model on
the new information it is more likely to
occur with non-linear models that have
more flexibility when learning a Target
function an example of this would be if
you're looking at say cars and trucks
and motorcycles it might only recognize
trucks that have a certain box like
shape it might not be able to notice a
flatbed truck unless it's only a
specific kind of flatbed truck or only
Ford trucks because that's what it saw
on the training set this means that your
model performs great on your train data
and rate on maybe a small test amount of
data but when you go to use it in the
rural World it leaves out a lot and
start and is not very functional outside
of your small area your small laboratory
data coming in underfitting doing the
opposite when you underfit your data
underfitting alludes to a model that is
neither well trained on training data
nor can generalize to new information
usually happens when there is less and
improper data to train a model as a bird
performance and accuracy so if you're
using underfitted data and you generate
a model and you distribute that in a
commercial Zone you'll have a lot of
people unhappy with you because it's not
going to give them very good answers so
we've explained overfitting and
underfitting so now we want to ask how
to combat them combating overfitting and
underfitting resampling the data to
estimate the model accuracy k-fold cross
validation having a validation data set
to evaluate the model so we do the
resampling we're randomly going to be
picking out data we'll run it a few
times to see how that works depending on
our random data and how we sample the
data to generate our model and then we
want to go ahead and validate the data
set by having our training data and then
keeping some data on the side testing
data to validate it how are weights
initialized in a network initializing
all weights to zero all the weights are
set to zero this makes your model
similar to a linear model so if you have
linear data coming in doing a basic
setup like that might work all the
neurons in every layer perform the same
operation given the same output and
making the Deep net useless right there
is a key word it's going to be useless
if you initialize everything to zero at
that point be looking into some other
machine learning tools initializing all
weights randomly here the weights are
assigned randomly by initializing them
very close to zero it gives better
accuracy to the model since every neuron
performs different computations and here
we have the weights are set randomly we
have our input layer the hidden layers
and the output layer and W equals NP
random random in layer size L layer size
L minus one this is the most commonly
used is to randomly generate your
weights what are the different layers in
CNN convolutional neural network first
is the convolutional layer that performs
a convolutional operation we have our
other video out if you want to explore
that more so go into detail exactly how
the C the convolutional layer works in
the CNN as far as creating a number of
smaller picture windows that go over the
data the second step is as a Rayle layer
relu brings non-linearity to the network
and converts all the negative pixels to
zero output is rectified feature map so
it goes into a mapping feature there
pooling layer pooling is a down sampling
operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map so we
have all our relu layer which is pulling
all these little Maps out of our
convolutional layer it's taking that
picture and little creating little tiny
neural networks to look at different
parts of the picture uh then we need to
pull it together and then finally the
fully connected layer so we've flattened
our pulling layer out and we have a
fully connected layer recognizes and
classifies the objects in the image and
that's actually your forward propagation
reverse propagation training model
usually I mean there's a number of
different models out there of course
what is pooling in CNN and how does it
work pooling used to reduce the spatial
dimensions of a CNN performs down
sampling operation to reduce the
dimensionality creates a pulled feature
map by sliding a filter Matrix over the
input Matrix I mentioned that briefly on
the previous slide it's important to
know that you have if you see here they
have a rectified feature map and so each
one of those colors like the yellow
color that might be one of the a smaller
little neural network using the relu
you'll look at it'll just kind of go
over the main picture and look at all
the different areas on the main picture
so you might step one two three four
spaces and then you have another one
that's also looking at features and it
has a 2785 five each one of those is a
map so it might be the first one might
be a map looking for cat ears and the
second one looking for human eyes when
it does this you then have this
rectified feature map looking at these
different features and the max pooling
with the two by two filters and a strata
tube stride means instead of skipping
every pixel you're going to go every two
pixels you take the maximum values and
you can see over here we look at a
pulled feature map one of the features
says hey I had a max value of eight so
somewhere in here we saw a human eye
labeled as eight pretty high label and
maybe seven was a human hand and maybe
four was cat whiskers or something that
we thought might be cat whiskers four is
kind of a low number in this particular
case compared to the other ones so you
have your full pool feature map you can
see the process here is we have our
stepping we look for the max value and
then we create a pulled feature map of
the maxed values how does a lstm network
work that's long short term memory so
the first thing to know is that an lstms
are a special kind of recurrent neural
network capable of learning long-term
dependencies remembering information for
long periods of time is their default
Behavior we did look at the RNN briefly
talked about how the hidden layer feeds
back into itself with the lstm as a much
more complicated feedback and you can
see here we have the hidden layer of T
minus one and the hidden Larry that's
what the H stands for hidden layer of T
and the formula is going in as we can
see here we have the hidden layers we
have T minus 1 and then h of T where T
stands for time so this is a series
remember working with series and we want
to remember the past and you can see you
have your X your input of T and that
might be a frame in a video as the frame
comes in they usually use in this one
the tangent H activation formula but you
also see that it goes through a couple
other formulas the Omega formula and so
when it combines these that then goes
into the next layer your next hidden
layer that then goes into the data
that's submitted to the next input so
you have your X of t t plus one so when
you have that coming in then you have
your H value that's coming forward from
the last process and depending on how
many of these Omega structures you put
in there depends on how long term the
memory gets so it's important to
remember this is more for your long-term
recurrent neural networks the three
steps in an lstm step one decides what
to forget and what to remember step two
selectively update cell State values So
based on what we want to remember and
forget we want to update those cell
values and then decide what part of the
current state make it to the output so
now we have to also have an output on
there what are Vanishing and exploding
gradients this is a great question to
fix all our neural networks while
training an RNN your slope can become
either too small or too large and this
makes the training difficult when the
slope is too small the problem is known
as Vanishing gradient so our slope we
have our change in X and our change in y
when the slope decreases gradually to a
very small value sometimes negative and
makes training difficult when the slope
tends to grow exponentially instead of
decaying this problem is called
exploding gradient the slope grows
exponentially you see a nice graph of
that here issues in gradient problem
Long training time poor performance and
low accuracy what is the difference
between Epic bat and iteration and deep
learning epic an epic represents one
iteration over the entire data set so
that's everything you're going to go
ahead and put into that training model
batch we cannot pass the entire data set
into the neural network at once so we
divide the data set into a number of
batches and then iteration if we have 10
000 images as data and a batch size of
200 then the Epic should run ten
thousand times over 200 so that means we
have our total number over the 200
equals 50 iteration so in each epic
we're running over all the data set
we're going to have 50 iterations and
each of those iterations includes a
batch of 200 images in this case why
tensorflow is the most preferred library
in deep learning what first tensorflow
provides both C plus plus and python
apis that makes it easier to work on has
a faster compilation time than other
deep learning libraries like Karas and
torch tensorflow supports both CPUs and
gpus Computing devices so right now
tensorflow is at the top of the market
because it's so easy to use for both
programmer side and for Hardware side
and for the speed of getting something
up and running what do you mean by
tensor and tensorflow tensor is a
mathematical object represented as a
rays of higher Dimension these arrays of
data with different dimensions and ranks
that are fed as input to the neural
network are called tensors you can see
here we have a tensor of Dimensions five
comma four so it's a two-dimensional
tensor coming in you can look at an
image like this that each one of those
pixels is a different value if it's a
black and white so it might be zero and
ones and then each one represents a
black and white image in a color photo
you might either find a different value
system or you might have a tensor value
that has the X Y coordinates as we see
here Plus colors so you might have three
more different dimensions for the three
different images the red the blue and
the yellow coming in and even as you go
from one layer or one tensor to the next
these layers might change we might
flatten them might bring in numerous in
the case of the convergence neural
network we have all those smaller
different mappings of features that come
in so each one of those layers coming
through is a tensor if it has multiple
Dimensions coming in and weights
attached to it what are the programming
elements in tensorflow well we have our
constants constants are parameters whose
value does not change to define a
constant we use tf.constant command
example a equals tf.constant 2.0 TF
float32 so it's a tensorflow value of
32. b equals TF constant 3.0 print a b
if we did a print of a b we'd have
tf.constant and then of course B is that
instance of it variables variables allow
us to add new trainable parameters to
graph to Define a variable we use
tf.variable command and initial lies
them before running the graph in session
example W equals TF variable 0.3 D type
TF float32 or b equals the TF variable
minus three comma D type float 32
placeholders placeholders allow us to
feed data to a tensorflow model from
outside a model it permits a value to be
assigned later to define a placeholder
we use TF placeholder command example a
equals TF placeholder b equals a times
two with the TF session as sess result
equals session run B comma feed
dictionary equals a 3.0 print result so
we have a nice example of the replace
holder session a session is run to
evaluate the nodes this is called as the
tensorflow runtime so for example you
have a equals TF constant 2.0 b equals
TF constant 4.0 C equals a plus b and at
this point you'd go ahead and create a
session equals TF session and then you
can evaluate the tensor C print session
run C that would input c as an input
into your session what do you understand
by a computational
everything in tensorflow is based on
creating a computational graph it has a
network of nodes where each node
performs an operation nodes represent
mathematical operation and edges
represent tensors since data flows in a
form of a graph it is also called a data
flow graph and we have a nice visual of
this graph or graphic image of a
computational graph and you can see here
we have our input nodes our add multiply
nodes and our multiply node at the end
and then we have the edges where the
data flows so we have from a going to C
A going to D you can see we have a two
flowing four flowing explain generative
adversarial Network along with an
example suppose there's a wine shop that
purchases wine from dealers which they
will resell later dealer point of the
wine our shop owner that then sells it
for a profit but there are some
malfactor dealers who sell fake Y in
this case the shop owner should be able
to distinguish between fake and
authentic wine the forger will try to
different techniques to sell fake wine
and make sure certain Tech techniques go
past the shop owner's check so here's
our forager fake wine shop owner the
shop owner would probably get some
feedback from the wine experts that some
of the wine is not original the owner
would have to improve how he determines
whether a wine is fake or authentic goal
of forger to create wines that are
indistinguishable from the authentic
ones goal of shop owner to accurately
tell if the wine is real or not there
are two main components of generative
adversarial Network and we'll refer it
to as a noise Vector coming in where we
have our forger who's going to generate
fake wine and then we have our real
authentic wine and of course our shop
owner who has to figure out whether it's
real or fake the generator is a CNN that
keeps producing images that are closer
in appearance to the real images while
the discriminator tries to determine the
difference between real and fake images
the ultimate aim is to make the
discriminator to learn to identify real
and fake images what is an auto encoder
the network is trained to reconstruct
its inputs it is a neural network that
has three layers here the input neurons
are equal to the output neuron the
Network's Target outside is same as the
input it uses dimensionality reduction
to restructure the input input image
comes in we have our Latin space
representation and then it goes back out
reconstructing the image it works by
compressing the input to a Latin space
representation and then reconstructing
the output from this representation what
is bagging and boosting bagging and
boosting are Ensemble techniques where
the idea is to train multiple models
using the same learning algorithm and
then take a call so we have in here
where we're bagging we take a data set
and we split it we have our training
data and our test data very standard
thing to do then we're going to randomly
select data into the bags and train your
model separately so we might have bag
one model one bag two model two bag
three model three and so on in boosting
the emphasis is to select the data
points which give wrong output in order
to improve the accuracy so in boosting
we have our data set again we split it
to test data and train data and we'll
take bag one it will train the model
data points with wrong predictions then
go into Bag two and we then train that
model and repeat and with this we have
come to the end of this Advanced deep
learning full course if you like this
video subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn please let us
know in the comment section below if you
need help opting for this Caltech post
charger programming and machine learning
course we will get back to you as soon
as possible until next time thank you
and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign